séance est ouverte le compte rendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribué il n'y a pas
ation le procès verbal est adopté sous
les réserves
d'usage l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
considéré comme adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale en l'application de l'article
49 ala 3 de la Constitution pour
2024 dans la discussion générale la
parole est à Monsieur Aurélien Rousseau
ministre de la santé et de la prévention
monsieur le ministre
monsieur le
Président ma madame la ministre monsieur
le ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur générale Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs thématiques
mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs issue de la rencontre fut-elle
improbable des esprits visionnaires de
Pierre laroc Alexandre parodie et
Ambroise croisa la sécurité sociale est
l'un des plus grands acquis du modèle
social français elle est notre bien
commun à tous le premier patrimoine de
ceux qui nen on pas c'est un système qui
à maintees reprise a montré sa
performance et son utilité nous l'avons
vu pendant la crise sanitaire nous
l'avons vu face à l'inflation nous le
ressentons chaque jour dans un pays où
le reste à charge des assurés en matière
de santé et l'un des plus faibles du
monde mais c'est aussi un système qui
contient des fragilités et qui doit
faire face aujourd'hui à de très grands
défis je pense évidemment au grandes
transformations démographiques sociales
et environnementales de notre temps qui
appelle des adaptations
indispensable mais je pense aussi à une
autre échelle à la fraude qui mine la
de tous les
acteurs c'est donc dans un état d'esprit
à la fois réaliste et ambitieux que je
tiens à aborder nos débats sur ce
premier projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale que j'ai l'honneur
de de porter et dont j'ai l'honneur
aujourd'hui d'ouvrir la discussion
générale je pense indispensable avant
toute chose d'élargir notre regard et et
d'inscrire l'examen de ce texte dans un
contexte global car bien évidemment
toute notre politique sociale ne se dé
loi pas uniquement via ce seul véhicule
législatif vous avez il y a 15 jours
adopté la proposition de loi relative à
l'accès aux soins et je salue à nouveau
la qualité des travaux menés ici dans
des conditions difficiles sous leségide
de la rapporteur Corine
Himbert vous savez que la négociation
conventionnelle avec les médecins
libéraux reprendra formellement
après-demain ces démarches produiront
autant que le que le PLFSS ou que la
LFSS plutôt des effets concrets sur
l'organisation de l'offre de soins
partout en France qui seront soutenu par
l'augmentation structurelle des
effectifs médicaux et soignants permise
par la suppression du numérus closus et
les efforts mené avec les régions dont
je salue l'implication pour augmenter
les places en formation
paramédicale j'ai eu l'occasion d'y
revenir longuement devant votre
commission des affaires sociales que je
remercie de la sagacité fut-elle parfois
un peu difficile de ces questions mais
il faut également se rappeler qu'un
budget est indissociable de son contexte
ce contexte ici chacun le connaît il est
difficile il est réellement difficile
loin de moi l'idée de le nier mais il
est également contrasté je me je mesure
les obstacles parfois désespérant
auxquels sont encore confrontés de très
nombreux de nos concitoyens en matière
d'accès aux soins je connais je crois
les difficultés des soignants mobilisés
au quotidien pour accompagner les
Françaises et les Français mais il faut
reconnaître que le cadre d'action que
j'ai décrit est soutenu par les moyens
très importants déployés depuis
plusieurs années consentis par les
assurés sociaux et cotisants eux-mêmes
et qui commencent par certains aspects à
porter leurs fruits sans évidemment que
je veuille ici repeindre tout en rose
tant l'hétérogénéité est grande sur nos
territoires on le voit par exemple à la
reprise de l'activité hospitalière mais
surtout à la reprise des recrutements
hospitalier qui nous permettront d'ici
la fin de l'année de rouvrir plusieurs
milliers de lits hospitaliers c'est l'un
des effets des investissements massifs
qui ont été consentis dans le Ségure de
la santé qui continuent à être alloué
pour construire ou rénover nos
établissements de santé dans un contexte
il faut le reconnaître là aussi où ation
est telle qu'elle nous oblige parfois à
revoir certains de ces projets dans
chacune de ces démarches nous sommes
guidés par l'idée de renforcer notre
système de santé afin qu'il protège
toujours mieux les Français et répondent
aux difficultés auxquelles il est
confronté car oui les difficultés
existent et des fragilités redoutables
persistent le contexte macro-économique
sera marqué cette année encore par la
pression inflationniste et par une
dégradation des comptes de la sécurité
sociale notamment ceux de la branche
maladie même si nous sommes passés de
l'an dernier de 22 milliards d'euros de
déficit à un peu moins de 9 milliards en
2023 cette inflation touche notamment
les établissements de santé plusieurs
d'entre vous ont pu me faire part des
inquiétudes concernant les hôpitaux de
vos départements et évidemment toutes
les fédérations hospitalières ont eu
l'occasion de s'exprimer sur ce sujet
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dire et je
vous assure que le gouvernement y est
part particulièrement attentif et y
compris d'ici la fin de l'année c'est
qu'il ne doivra pas laisser ses
établissements dans l'impasse je m'en
suis ouvert très directement auprès de
la totalité des fédérations
d'établissement de santé qui sur cette
question évidemment tire la sonnette
d'alarme et surtout grâce à un travail
conjoint partage aujourd'hui
l'estimation des coûts et de l'impact de
l'inflation je le disais le déficit de
la branche maladie s'élève cette année à
environ 9 milliards d'euros en baisse
par rapport à celui constaté en 2022
mais ces chiffres restent importants et
sont tirés par le fort le très fort
dynamisme des dépenses de santé
notamment en ville qui rendent urgente
la recherche de soutenabilité c'est la
condition incontournable de la pérennité
et de l'ambition de notre modèle social
fondé sur la solidarité sur un modèle
assuranciel c'est pour répondre à cette
C double exigence d'ambition et de
soutenabilité que le gouvernement vous
présente dans ce projet de loi d'une
part et en premier lieu une
rectification de longame de 2023 à
hauteur de 2,8 milliards d'euros cette
rectification permet principalement
d'intégrer la les revalorisations
salariales et la dynamique des soins de
ville je connais vos préoccupation à ce
sujet et je souhaite
progressivement que nous puissions
refaire de longame un outil de pilotage
et non un outil de constatation de la
dépense et il nous revient en effet de
mieux la suivre de mieux la conduire et
la
maîtriser d'autre part le Gouvernement
présente un Nam pour 2024 en hausse de
3,2 % hors dépenses liées à la crise
sanitaire un chiffre qui est bien
supérieur contrairement à ce que je peux
entendre dire parfois à l'inflation
prévisionnelle soit une progression
globale des moyens de 8 milliards
d'euros en 2024 hors covid 8 milliards
d'euros j'ai eu l'occasion de le
rappeler c'était encore le budget du
ministère de la Justice il y a 2
ans cette progression elle est par
nature du coup totalement incohérente
avec ce qu'on peut entendre parfois
autour de la présentation de nom d'âme
d'austérité en particulier cette
progression importante de l'ONDAM permet
de compléter de près de 1,5 milliards
d'euros les revalorisations engagées par
le le segégur afin de mieux reconnaître
et de mieux rémunérer de manière pérenne
l'engagement des professionnels des des
établissements sanitaires et
médicos-sociaux mais Aurore berger y
reviendra qui travaille la nuit le
weekend et les jours fériers le
gouvernement continue ainsi d'investir
avec ambition dans l'avenir du système
de santé et dans les ressources humaines
mais cette augmentation des moyens doit
être gagée en partie par de nouvelles
mesures de maîtrise de la tendance de
progression de la dépense publique
l'objectif est de l'ordre de 3,5
milliards d'euros de maîtrise sur le
tendentiel de dépenses et le terme
déficience ne doit pas être tabou la
ligne de crête est ÉU elle n'est pas
facile à tenir mais je dois aussi dire
ici que la seconde idée que porte ce
gouvernement et enfin plus exactement
contre laquelle je m'élève en faux parce
que elle elle n'est pas l'engagement du
gouvernement ce serait qu'on laisse
filer les dépenses et qu'on a' pas
d'objectif de maîtrise de la de finance
de la dépense publ j'ai entendu
plusieurs déclarations à ce sujet cet
objectif important nous l'atteindrons
grâce à des efforts de modération des
volumes et des baisses de prix des
produits de santé pour freiner la hausse
de ce poste de dépenses et que le débat
parlementaire permettra j'en suis sûr
d'enrichir avec notamment euh un
amendement que le gouvernement
présentera mais il y en aura il d'autres
sur la substitution des médicaments
biosimilaires par le pharmacien cet
objectif de maîtrise de la dépense il
sera aussi tenu par des efforts
d'efficience et de pertinence prévu dans
ce texte et ces efforts seront également
au cœur de la négociation conventionnel
la lettre de cadrage que j'ai adressé au
directeur général de la CNAM le
mentionné très explicitement et enfin
des efforts de responsabilisation des
assurés avec vous le savez des mesures
en matière de régulation des arrêts de
travail ou de plus grandes association
des mutuels notamment sur les soins
dentaires la question des franchises de
la participation forfaitaire a déjà pu
être évoquée à l'Assemblée nationale et
nous poursuivrons ensemble ici cette
réflexion le texte comporte enfin des
mesures relatives à la lutte contre la
fraude qui est autant un enjeu de
soutenabilité que de justice sociale et
qui ont un point d'attention prioritaire
pour le Sénat le sénateur van Berg a eu
l'occasion de le redire avec force lors
de la commission et Thomas kaznav y
reviendra j'en suis sûr dans un instant
je tiens à souligner que dans toutes ces
démarches une attention particulière a
été portée au plus fragiles qui ne
doivent pas être pénalisé c'est
notamment pour cela qu'en matière
d'arrêt de travail le gouvernement vous
présentera un amendement apportant des
garanties supplémentaires pour les
patients en al et je veux qu'il soit
bien clair que quand j'évoque la
responsabilisation il ne s'agit pas de
pointer la responsabilité de tel ou tel
des patients des médecins des
entreprises mais bien de dire que la
soutenabilité globale de notre système
de ce patrimoine inouï qui est notre
système de protection sociale appartient
à tous bien évidemment ces efforts
indispensables à fournir ne nous empêche
pas collectivement de continuer à faire
avancer notre système de santé vers une
modernisation indispensable vers
davantage de prévention et vers un accès
facilité aux soins je ne serai pas
exhaustif dans ce propos liiminaire mais
souhaite revenir rapidement sur certains
éléments tout d'abord la modernisation
du fonctionnement du système de santé
pour améliorer l'accès aux soins et pour
répondre au mieux aux besoins de santé
de nos concitoyens moderniser notre
système de santé implique tout d'abord
de faire évoluer le financement des
établissements de santé pierre angulaire
de notre
organisation le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
traduit ainsi l'ambition fixée par le
Président de la République de mettre fin
au caractère centrale de la tarification
à l'activité la réforme proposée met
ainsi en place une rémunération
partiellement structurée selon des
objectifs de santé public négocié à
l'échelle des territoires qui permettra
de réribuer de manière effective les
missions réalisées par chacun organisé
en trois compartiments la nouvelle
tarification se déploiera entre 2004
2024 et 2026 en articulation avec les
nouveaux protocoles pluriannuels de
financement des établissements de santé
auxquels le gouvernement travaillera Ave
avec les acteurs dans le courant de
l'année 2024 j'entends parfois dire que
cette évolution n'est pas assez
substantielle mais nombre d'entre vous
ici j'en suis sûr ont été présidents de
conseil d'administration de conseil de
surveillance d'établissement et vous
savez ce que représente quelque
évolution de la tarification que ce soit
moderniser notre système de santé c'est
aussi s'appuyer sur les expérimentations
et les initiativ locales le texte
prévoit ainsi de généraliser certaines
expérimentations en créant un forfait
fait qui permettra de financer
solidairement des équipes de soins sans
être tenu à la rémunération à l'activité
ces mesures sont autant d'outils que
nous mettons dans les mains des acteurs
de santé qui pourront s'en saisir pour
appuyer les solutions les mieux adaptées
aux réalités locales je sais combien
vous êtes dans vos différentes fonctions
investis pour faire vivre ces collectifs
dans chacun de vos territoires y compris
et j'allais dire surtout dans ceux où la
tension en matière de démographie
médicale est la plus forte je salue à ce
titre l'engagement de la rapporteur
générale ellisabeth douanau à la fois
sur la Commission en général mais aussi
sur son territoire de maenne je ne le
dirai redirai jamais assez il faut
continuer faire confiance aux acteurs de
terrain et leur donner tous les moyens
pour libérer les énergies c'est à nous
la puissance publique de nous adapter à
la situation et ne pas forcer les
différents acteurs à rentrer dans dans
les cases c'est c'est au nom d'ailleurs
de ces multiples initiatives que je vois
dans tous mes déplacements que je me
permets de dire que la réalité est
contrastée je repense ainsi
régulièrement à ma visite au tout début
de ma prise de fonction à lanoille en
Dordogne où la sénatrice varayas qui
n'est pas là aujourd'hui
m'accompagn et où nous avons vu à quel
point la compétence conjuguée des
différents professionnel de santé peut
être une réponse extrêmement puissante à
la situation difficile dans notre
nombreux départements dans la continuité
des travaux menés au Parlement ces
dernières années nous avançons par
exemple sur l'extension des compétences
des pharmaciens en matière de
prescription d'antibiotiques sur les
parcours de prise en charge de la
dépression postpartom ou encore sur
l'élargissement à laassend à la médecine
scolaire des possibilités d'adressage
vers le dispositif monstien
PSI le second pilier de ce PLFSS est
d'accélérer le virage de la prévention
de manière à ce que le tournant prix
soit irréversible je dis souvent que la
PR prvention ce n'est pas un supplément
d'ame ce n'est pas ce que l'on fera
quand on aura réglé tous les autres
problèmes non j'envisage le fait de
rompre dans les pratiques comme dans les
mentalités avec un système
historiquement tourné vers le tout
curatif comme une transformation
absolument essentielle sans une
politique de prévention suffisamment
exhaustive et développée aucun pays j'en
suis convaincu ne peut faire durablement
face aux défis sanitaires et sociaux que
sont notamment le vieillissement
démographique et le poids croissant des
maladies chroniques quel que soit la
quelle que soit la qualité de son
système de soins telle sera notre grande
ambition pour les prochaines années qui
prend déjà corp grâce aux opérations de
dépistage et de santé publique en cours
elle devra s'incarner plus largement
dans toutes nos politiques publiques
comme l'ont souligné plusieurs travaux
et rapports de votre commission des
affaires sociales ces dernières années
et je souhaite vous dire ici que je
considère que le travail pour le PLFSS
pour 2025 devra commencer très
rapidement y compris avec les deux
assemblées qu'on ne peut pas se
contenter de faire j'allais dire un tour
de de de de dialogue à quelques semaines
du PLFSS et je pense notamment à
plusieurs sujets qui qui me tiennent à
cœur et dont je pense qu'on on n'est pas
allé jusqu'au bout dans le plsss qu'on
présente aujourd'hui je pense notamment
à la santé des femmes ou je pense au
sujet de la prise en compte des
spécificités
outreemè la campagne de vaccination
contre contre les les infections liées
au PAP papiom virirus est un bon exemple
nous avons lancé une dynamique qui était
inédite mais le l'Assemblée nationale
nous a invité à élargir cette
vaccination aux établissements
accueillant des enfants en situation de
handicap et c'était très justifié et
donc nous le ferons et de la même
manière que nous devrons euh regarder
après avis de la HS comment mettre en
place un dépistage précoce systématique
des situations de handicap pouvant être
induites par la la contraction de
comégalovirus pendant le premier
trimestre de grossesse enfin le texte
contient plusieurs mesures importantes
relatives à l'accès aux médicaments qui
constitue alors que nous entrons dans la
période hivernale un sujet de
préoccupation pour nos concitoyens et un
un enjeu auquel je sais le Sénat très
attentif en effet loin de se limiter à
des enjeux techniques la politique du
médicament fait partie de ces politiques
publ qui ont une traditiontion concrète
et presque quotidienne dans la vie de
nos concitoyens la R regulation et le
financement des produits de santé sont
également au croisement des enjeux
majeurs d'attractivité d'innovation et
de souveraineté c'est pour cela qu'une
partie significative de ce projet de loi
est consacrée à des questions à ces
questions avec notamment une une réforme
du mode de calcul de la clause de
sauvegarde clause par ailleurs réduite
pour 2023 et 2024 afin de donner plus de
visibilité au secteurs en contrepartie
d'engagement pour donner plus de
visibilité à la puissance publique la
question de la lutte contre les pénuries
fa également l'objet de travaux
approfondis de nombreux acteurs ces
dernières années s'y sont s'y sont
penchés et je salue et ça n'est pas
qu'un mot de tribune la contribution
essentielle j'ai eu l'occasion
d'échanger avec Sonia de la provoté sur
le sujet et j'avais vu également
Laurence couen avec avec elle parce que
leur rapport a été très précieux
notamment pour la réunion que j'ai tenu
la semaine dernière avec tous les
professionnels du secteur le
gouvernement est mobilisé au quotidien
pour assurer le suivi des stocks des
médicaments les plus cruciaux je disais
j'ai réuni pas plus tard que vendredi
dernier l'ensemble des professionnels
pour faire le point une charte de bonne
pratique sera établis sous 10 jours pour
mieux réguler un système qui ne fait
plus pass face à une pénurie comme l'an
dernier mais plutôt à une complète
dérégulation entre les différents
acteurs industriels grossistes
répartiteurs et pharmaciens les patients
les assurés sociaux ne peuvent pas être
la variable d'ajustement de jeu entre
les différents acteurs du secteur du
médicament cette charte sera d'ailleurs
coordonnée à ma demande sous l'égide de
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament et de la présidente de
l'Ordre National des pharmacien qui a
accepté cette mission par ailleurs et
pour et pour faire face aux difficultés
d'approvisionnement plus structurel je
présenterai au début du mois de novembre
avec Roland lescur le ministre chargé de
l'Industrie une feuille de route
actualisée de lutte contre les pénuries
de médicaments sans attendre le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale complète nos outils de gestion
des tensions avec par exemple la
limitation des prescriptions par
téléconsultation lors des situations les
plus tendues ou encore la dispensation à
l'unité au sujet de laquelle je sais que
des questions se pose mais dont je suis
convaincu qu'elle est une réponse une
partie de la réponse indispensable aux
difficultés observées les débats nous
permettront d'y revenir comme pour
approfondir ce point comme tous les
autres notamment sur les mesures que
nous prévoyons pour au-delà de la
gestion des situations de tension
améliorer structurellement l'accès aux
médicaments et aux actes de diagnostic
innovant je sais que c'est un sujet qui
tient à cœur à nombre d'entre vous
notamment à monsieur le sénateur Alen
Milon le PLFSS instaore par exemple une
procédure d'inscription directe des
actes de diagnostic inovant afin de
faciliter l'accès au marché et d'en
réduire les délais vous le voyez nous
nous efforçons de répondre par ce texte
à des besoins urgents grâce à des
mesures d'application directe tout en
préparant et en consolidant l'avenir du
système de santé le cadrage général du
PLFSS répond à la double exigence
d'ambition et de soutenabilité qui doit
irriguer l'ensemble de l'action publique
je crois profondément qu'il consistera
un socle solide sur lequel nous pourrons
continuer de construire avec réalisme et
détermination nous allons bien évid nous
n'avons nous n'allons bien évidemment
pas tout régler avec ce texte et ce
n'est d'ailleurs en aucun cas ce que je
prêtends faire ici les sujets sont
vastes les enjeux immenses pour par
exemple intensifier le combat contre le
cancer continuer de soutenir et de faire
prospérer la recherche française lutter
contre la financiarisation du système de
santé ou encore renforcer notre mal
notre politique en matière de santé
mentale ou de santé des femmes nous y
reviendrons j'en suis sûr au cours des
débats je vous
remercie merci merci monsieur le
ministre dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Madame Aurore
berger ministre des Solidarités et des
[Applaudissements]
familles
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur mesdames
et Messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs le ministère des
solidarités et des familles est au cœur
des besoins essentiels de nos
concitoyens il s'agit des désirs les
plus intimes qui soit fonder une famille
les peurs les plus grandes aussi
soutenir nos parents et nos
grands-parents il s'agit aussi du regard
que nous posons sur la vulnérabilité
dans notre société à nos enfants nous
devons permettre l'épanouissement et le
développement il est de notre
responsabilité de renforcer
l'accompagnement de toutes les familles
en cohérence avec une conception
universelle de la politique familiale
que je sais que nous partageons celle-ci
ne serurait se limiter à une politique
de redistribution ou de correction des
inégalités elle est d'abord une
politique qui appuie et qui soutient
toutes les familles dans le respect de
leurs choix il s'agit ensuite de nos
parents et de nos grands-parents don
nous devons soutenir l'autonomie du
regard que nous portons sur la
vieillesse et de la préparation et de
l'adaptation de notre société au
vieillissement nous faisons ainsi
grandir la branche autonomie pour
relever le défi de ce vieillissement il
s'agit enfin des personnes en situation
de handicap un sujet auquel je vous sais
attentif cher Philippe Mouillet nous
leur devons une vie comme les autres
parmi les autres pour que le droit
commun s'applique à eux et à leur
famillees tout d'abord donc les familles
dont le retour dans la dénomination même
du ministère marque notre détermination
à réaffirmer cette priorité politique
aider toutes les familles et s'en donner
les moyens cette ambition est d'autant
plus essentielle dans le contexte de
baisse continue de la natalité depuis 10
ans une baisse accrue ces deux dernières
années nous devons inverser cette
tendance et ainsi renouer
progressivement avec une politique
familiale universelle qui répond aux
besoins de toutes les familles et je
sais chère Élisabeth douano que nous
partageons cet attachement la branche
famille consacre déjà plus de 50
milliards d'euros chaque année à cet
objectif ces moyens augmenteront de 2
milliards d'euros supplémentaires en
2024 notamment pour mettre en œuvre le
chantier du service public de la petite
enfance nous le savons la question du
mode de garde est aujourd'hui le premier
frein à la réalisation du désir d'enfant
au sein des famille 6 milliards d'euros
seront consacrés à ce service public
jusqu'en 2027 pour revaloriser et
accompagner nos professionnels de la
petite enfance et je remercie le Sénat
en particulier la rapporteur Pascal
grunny d'avoir permis une commission
mixte paritaire conclusive sur le projet
de loi plein emploi il s'agit d'un
investissement indispensable si nous
voulons créer les de000 200000 solutions
manquantes
aujourd'hui soutenir toutes les familles
c'est aussi soutenir les maires seuls le
PLFSS intègre des aides monétaires qui
seront revalorisées à hauteur de 4,6 %
en avril comme l'allocation de soutien
familial c'est-à-dire la pension
alimentaire minimal dont nous avons
augmenté de 50 % le montant l'année
dernière total donc la branche famille
représentera 63 milliards d'euros de
dépenses en 2027 soit une augmentation
de 20 % par rapport à
2022 le complément de libre choix du
mode de garde l'aide individuelle à la
garde d'enfants fera l'objet d'une
double réforme vous le savez étendue à
toutes les familles monoparentales
jusqu'aux 11 ans révolus de l'enfant et
modifi encore en 2025 pour que le reste
à charge soit enfin le même pour toutes
les familles qu'elles choisissent de
faire garder leurs enfants en crèche ou
auprès d'une assistante maternelle je
m'assurerai que ces moyens soient
dépensés effectivement et efficacement
pour garantir la qualité de la prise en
charge et la sécurité de nos enfants pas
un seul euro des 200 millions dédiés
chaque année à la revalorisation des
professionns de la petite enfance n'ira
aux structures qui n'amélioreraient pas
les conditions de travail de ces
derniers enfin quand on parle de
natalité nous ne pouvons pas accepter et
nous résigner devant l'écart grand entre
le désir d'enfant des Français et le
nombre d'enfants mis au monde le service
public de la petite- enfance est un
premier élément de réponse nous devons
aller au-delà en levant les tabous je
pense notamment à la question de
l'infertilité travaillant avec le
ministre de la Santé une famille sur
quatre aujourd'hui un couple sur qu dans
notre pays est confronté à la difficulté
d'avoir un enfant c'est pour cela aussi
que j'ai annoncé que nous mettrons en
place dès 2025 un nouveau droit un congé
familial un congé mieux rémunéré après
les congés maternité et paternité un
congé pour garantir à toutes les
familles un véritable accès à une option
pour s'arrêter s'occuper de leur
nouveauné dans les premiers mois s'il le
souhait évidemment à temps plein ou à
temps complet je pose aussi la question
de la capacité transitoire de maintenir
le congé parental existant en parallèle
de ce nouveau droit c'est une question
que nous devrons trancher dans le cadre
de la concertation avec les
organisations syndicales et patronal les
solidarités et la famille c'est aussi
évidemment tout au long de la vie c'est
pourquoi plus que jamais la question de
l'autonomie doit être au cœur de nos
engagements et de ce PLFSS nous allons
faire face nous le savons à un choc
démographique deux chiffres en 2030 un
Français sur 3 aura plus de 60 ans et
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
notre pays les plus de 65 ans seront
plus nombreux que les moins de 15 ans et
c'est une chance pour notre pays une
chance pour nos familles et nos
solidarités une chance pour la
participation de tous à la vie citoyenne
et collective mais cela suppose que nous
devions nous y préparer et ce dès
aujourd'hui l'objectif global de
dépenses qui finance nos établissements
aussi bien pour personnes âgées que pour
personnes en situation de handicap
augmentera de 4 % en 2024 soit davantage
que l'inflation anticipée cette hausse
des moyens traduit nos engagements
envers les familles et les
professionnels du secteur quelques
engagements importants d'abord répondre
aux demandes des personnes directement
concernées nous le savons leur première
demande leur première volonté c'est de
vieillir chez elles à leur domicile
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
entrepris le virage domiciliaire que
nous déployons dès janvier 24 ma prime
adapte une nouvelle aide financière pour
prévenir la perte d'autonomie des moyens
sont ensuite consacrés à la poursuite du
développement de nouveaux centres de
ressources territoriaux afin enfin de
décloisonner les interventions auprès
des personnes âgées à domicile et de
simplifier leur démarchees ces centres
s'inscrivent dans la dynamique du
service public départemental de
l'autonomie qui doit mettre fin à une
forme d'irance de parcours du combattant
de nos aînés des personnes en situation
de handicap et de leur famille il s'agit
d'un projet d'humanisation et de
simplification de nos services publics
l'appel à manifestation d'intérêt vous
le savez a été émis en septembre dernier
auprès de l'ensemble des conseils
départementaux parmi les réformes
structurelles il y a évidemment la
question de l'aide à domicile tarif
planché vous le savez avait été fixé 22
€ en 2022 23 en 2023 et sera indir
directement indexé sur l'inflation en
2024 la dotation complémentaire
autrement appelé la dotation qualité a
été portée à 3 € nous prévoyons
également d'ici 2030 la création de
25000 nouvelles places de CAD et enfin
les 2 heures supplémentaires dédiées à
l'accompagnement et à la lutte contre
l'isolement social qui s'appliqueront à
partir de janvier 2024 nous irons plus
loin dès la semaine prochaine à
l'Assemblée nationale puisque nous
reprendrons l'examen de la proposition à
bien vieillir qui sera je l'espère
examiné dans les meilleurs meilleur
délai évidemment ici au Sénat elle
contient déjà des éléments de réponse
concret la carte professionnelle pour
les aides à domicile le fond de soutien
à la mobilité la lutte contre les
maltraitances et aussi la question du
droit de visite des familles en éepad je
souhaite que nous proposions enfin un
véritable parcours résidentiel adapteré
au besoins et surtout au respect des
envies et des volontés de nos
concitoyens pour consolider l'offre
d'accompagnement des personnes âgées en
établissement des recrutements doivent
palier la pénurie de professionnelle
50000 postes supplémentaires vous le
savez en éepad et le respect d'une
trajectoire que nous avons fixé 3000
postes en 2023 nous doublons avec 6000
postes ouverts en 2024 mais l'enjeu est
d'abord de rendre ces postes évidemment
attractifs c'est pour cela que j'ai
obtenu que les infirmiers et les
aides-signants en éepad public
bénéficient de la même mesure de
revalorisation pour le travail de nuit
que leurs collègues en établissement
public sanitaire cette revalorisation
qui concerne également le secteur privé
non lucratif est tout simplement une
question d'égalité de justice il n'y a
pas d'un côté le secteur sanitaire et de
l'autre le secteur médico-social les
deux font face aux mêmes difficultés et
doivent par conséquent travailler dans
les mêmes conditions sans hiérarchie
enfin je n'ignore évidemment rien des
difficultés financières d'un grand
nombre si ce n'est la quasi totalité des
epads et des services d'aide à domicile
nous avons déjà débloqué un premier fond
d'urgence de 100 millions d'euros avec
la première ministre dès cet été nous
avons surtout créé et installé et des
commissions départementales afin de
réussir à mettre autour de la table les
créanciers et financeurs pour établir
une cartographie précise de la situation
des 7500 éepad de notre pays entre ce
qui relève des difficultés
conjoncturelles inflation prix de
l'énergie revalorisation et des
difficultés structurelles le PLFSS
apporte une première réponse
structurelle justement avec la
possibilité pour les département qui le
souhaite de fusionner vous le savez les
sections soins et dépendan c'est une
mesure importante ente en terme de
financement qui une fois le PLFSS adopté
pourra donc être testé dans des
départements pilotes qui auront
manifesté leur intérêt j'ai souhaité dès
le départ que nous respections le libre
choix des départements dans les
politiques publiques qu'ils mènent en
faveur de l'autonomie je compte
également sur la réforme des concours de
la CNSA pour mieux soutenir les
départements dans leurs efforts et
rendre véritablement lisible la
politique publique que nous menons en
matière d'autonomie j'ai l'occasion de
le rappeler la semaine dernière aux SIS
les départements de France et je le
redis donc ici rien ne se décidera sans
ou contre les départements je crois à
l'échelon départemental et à la
nécessité d'avoir des politiques
décentralisées au plus près des
concitoyens tout comme je crois aussi à
la nécessité de l'équité territoriale la
réforme des concours que nous souhaitons
mener avec les départements en 2025 doit
permettre de mettre en place une
compensation forte lisible et qui était
je crois attendue la prise en charge à
50 % de toutes les dépenses nouvelles
réalisées par les départements dans le
champ de l'autonomie cette ambition que
nous avons souhaité avec la première
ministre elle prendra forme dès 2024
vous le savez un amendement au PLFSS
intégrera ainsi une enveloppe de 150
millions d'euros supplémentaires qui
s'ajoute à la progression des concours
historiques en ciblant l'effort
volontairement pour atteindre un taux de
compensation de 40 % par département et
en finir avec cette inéquité de
compensation de certains qui étaient à
22 % et d'autres bien au-delà des 40
c'est aussi cela la question de la
justice et de l'équité territoriale
comme je l'ai indiqué devant vous en
commission je souhaite que les moyens
nouveaux bénéficient aussi en priorité
au département qui agissent le plus en
faveur du Bien Vieillir je pense
notamment à nos départements ruraux
particulièrement engagés sur la question
du domicile l'enveloppe sera donc
utilisée aussi en contrepartie de
l'effort poursuivi pour mettre
effectivement en œuvre la dotation
qualité dans les services
d'accompagnement et d'aide à domicile ce
PLFSS enfin est un texte de mise en
œuvre de nos engagements concernant le
handicap notamment les engagements pris
dans la Conférence nationale du handicap
le président de la République a annoncé
le déploiement de 50000 nouvelles
solutions pour les personnes en
situation de handicap et volontairement
c'est bien une multiplicité de solutions
qui doit être mise en œuvre parce que
nous avons d'un côté le droit à la
scolarité y compris en institut
médicauéducatifs pour en cesser avec ces
demi matinées de cours qui parfois
continue à exister ou au droit à une
prise en charge adaptée notamment au
sein de l'aide sociale à l'enfance qui
compte aujourd'hui 20 % d'enfants en
situation de handicap ces 50000
solutions favoriseront en priorité c'est
en tout cas ce que j'ai édicté la sortie
des 10000 adultes maintenus dans les
établissements pour enfants au titre de
l'amendement d' crreton ils ont eux
aussi droit à une prise en charge qui
corresponde à leurs besoins et qui
respecte leur dignité cela permettra
aussi de libérer des places qui
devraient être dévolu depuis longtemps à
des enfants en accord avec les annonces
de la CNH ces solutions supplémentaires
seront parilleur par ailleurs complétés
par le déploiement de facilitateurs pour
encourager l'orientation et donc la
sortie des jeunes entre 15 et 20 ans en
structure pour enfants une autre mesure
clé pour 2025 concerne la création d'un
véritable service de repérage et
d'orientation des situations de handicap
chez nos tout jeunes enfants de 0 à 6
ans enfin nous facilitons également la
vie des personnes en situation de
handicap sur la question de leur pouvoir
d'achat aujourd'hui 60000 familles des
Bours en moyenne plus de 5000 € pour
avoir un fauteuil adapté à leurs besoins
et pour certains modèles spécifiques
c'est bien au-delà c'est parfois
plusieurs dizaines de milliers d'euros
et certains de nos concitoyens qui en
sont réduits à faire des cagnottes sur
Internet nous supprimons donc à 100 % le
reste à charge lors de l'achat d'un
fauteuil c'est une petite révolution qui
concrètement va changer la vie des
familles et permettra à tous tout
simplement d'accéder au modèle dont il a
besoin et quel que soit son niveau de
revenu les progrès que j'ai évoqué pour
accompagner les personnes âgées et les
personnes en situation de handicap ne
sont possibles que grâce à la création
vous le savez de la 5è branche relative
à l'autonomie et la part supplémentaire
de 015 points de CSG soit 2,6 milliards
d'euros qui lui est dévolue à partir de
2024 nous consommons désormais plus de
la moitié de ce surplu dè 2024 et la
trajectoire de dépenses prévu nous
parlons d'une augmentation de près de 30
% sur ce quinquena l'utilisera donc
intégralement les réformes à venir des
concours de la CNSA de la stratégie de
l'adaptation de notre société au
vieillissement pouront donc amener des
évolution que nous devrons travailler
évidemment ensemble avec vous enfin le
texte qui vous sera présenté reprendra
plusieurs amendements auquel le
gouvernement a donné un avis favorable
d'ors et déjà à l'Assemblée je pense à
ceux qui s'inscrivent dans le Pr
prongement de la Stratégie nationale
pour les aidans pour mieux les
accompagner et mieux les soutenir le
renouvellement par exemple des droits à
laallocation journalière du prédent pour
chaque personne aidée parce que oui on
peut dans sa vie aider plusieurs
personnes on peut aider un enfant en
situation de handicap comme on peut
aider un parent en perte d'autonomie
nous prolongerons également 2024 la le
pardon l'expérimentation du dispositif
de relayage au domicile des personnes en
attendant une généralisation dont je
sais que vous souhaitez qu'elle arrive
vite et moi aussi le passage au Sénat
fera naturellement encore évoluer ce
PLFSS vous êtes notamment nombreux à
proposer de décaler de quelques mois la
date limite de candidature à la fusion
des sections l'année prochaine et je
pense que nous pourrons ainsi mieux
travailler avec chacun d'entre eux les
modalités précises et leur assurer ainsi
un choix éclairé qui serait donc
favorable je suis par ailleurs favorable
cher anque Pétrus à la création d'un
véritable maison territoriale pour les
personnes handicapées à Saint-Martin
elle permettra d'assurer au territoire
le plein soutien plein soutien de l'État
et du de la CNSA y compris donc
financièrement enfin comme annoncé en
commission cher Chantal de scinene je
suis favorable à la transformation de la
fusion des sections en une
expérimentation afin de s'assurer que
cette nouvelle modalité fonctionne
effectivement avant toute mise en place
définitive c'était je crois le sens de
nos échanges lors de mon audition à la
commission des affaires sociales étant
donné les enjeux il est normal de
fournir au département un rapport
d'évaluation précis au bout d'un certain
nombre d'années de permettre si besoin
était un retour en arrière je ne
l'espère pas ni ne le crois pas mais je
crois que c'est le bon esprit dans
lequel nous devons travailler non
seulement avec le Sénat mais aussi avec
les départements je seraai également
attentive à la proposition d'une
expérimentation de fusion des sections
dites miroir permettant de transférer la
responsabilité de la nouvelle section
intégralement au département je n'ai
aucun tabout sur cet enjeu je l'ai déjà
dit et nous aurons donc l'occasion d'en
discuter puisque vous avez déposé des
amendements en ce sens je n'ai donc
aucun doute sur le fait que d'autres
échanges interviendront cette semaine
dans le cadre de nos débats et vous
pourrez compter sur ma pleine attention
sur vos propositions je vous
remercie merci madame la ministre dans
la suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à Monsieur Thomas CASNAV
ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics à vous monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
ministre monsieur le Président Madame
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur générale
Mesdames et Messieurs les les sénateurs
je suis heureux de vous présenter
aujourd'hui le projet loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale au côté
d'Aurélien Rousseau et et d'uror berger
tout au long de l'élaboration du texte
jusqu'à son examen à l'Assemblée
nationale et aujourd'hui au Sénat nous
avons eu comme pour seul boussole
prolonger et d'amplifier
l'investissement dans notre système de
protection sociale et de santé tout en
recher cherchant à maîtriser nos
dépenses vous le savez la maîtrise de
nos dépenses et notamment celle de santé
est une condition indispensable pour
préserver notre système à court et moyen
terme nous ne pouvons pas fermer les
yeux sur la question financière car nous
risquerions d'hypothéquer notre capacité
à faire face aux crises de demain si
nous avons réussi à mettre en œuvre le
quoi qu'il en coûte et à protéger les
Français face à la crise sanitaire c'est
parce que nous avions des marges de
manœuvre suffisante il faut les
retrouver cette logique est valable pour
la sécurité sociale comme pour les
finances publiques dans leur ensemble
nous avons pour objectif de réduire le
déficit public sous la barre des 3 % à
horizon 2027 nous pouvons revenir à ce
niveau que nous avions atteint avant les
crises 2,9 % en 2017 2,3 % en 2018 3 %
en 2019 il faut que l'effort soit par
partager état collectivité locale et et
sécurité sociale en parallèle
l'évolution de la démographie du
vieillissement mais aussi le
renchérissement associé au progrès
médical réusse constamment et
spontanément nos dépenses les mesures de
maîtrise sont donc absolument
nécessaires pour ne pas voir le système
dérivé pour redresser nos comptes ce
PLFSS prévoit 3,5 milliards d'euros
d'économie dans le champ de long d'â ces
économie réside dans un effort partagé
demandé à tous les acteurs en premier
lieu nos dépenses de médicaments
augmentent de 4 % par an en moyenne ces
dernières années au total elles ont
atteint 35 milliards d'euros en 2022 des
marges d'amélioration soit sont par
conséquent possibles en ce qui concerne
par exemple les antibiotiques pour
lesquels notre consommation est 20 %
supérieur à la moyenne européenne ainsi
en 2024 1,3 milliard d'euros économie
seront attendu spécifiquement sur les
dépenses de médicaments et dispositifs
médicaux pour y parvenir nous nous
assurerons de la baisse des prix des
médicaments et dispositifs médicaux dans
le cadre des négociations entre les
industriels et le comité économique des
produits de santé pour un montant de 1
milliard d'euros nous allons également
travailler à la maîtrise des quantités
consomm pour 300 millions d'euros nous
permettrons grâce à ce PLFSS d'activer
des mesures épargne dont le
conditionnement à l'unité en cas de
risque de pénurie sur les médicaments
sur ce sujet j'aimerais que nous allions
plus loin l'avenir pour permettre la
mise en place de ce conditionnement
chaque fois que cela est possible et pas
seulement en période de pénurie 1,3
milliards d'euros d'économie
correspondent à des efforts et
participations des complémentaires et
des assurés ces économies ne proviennent
pas nécessairement de dispositions
législatives nous souhaitons continuer
de travailler avec tous les acteurs
concernés et avec les parlementaires qui
souhaitent nous aider dans ce sens parmi
les mesures déjà décidées figure le
recours au transport sanitaire partagé
c'est une mesure de bon sens les
patients qui n'ont aucune
contreindication médicale se verront
proposer un transport collectif dans le
cadre de leur soin cela permettra de
réduire les dépenses en matière de
transport et de contribuer à nos
objectifs en matière de transition
écologique nous favoriserons aussi le
recours au médicaments génériques et au
biosimilaire chaque fois que cela est
possible enfin concernant longondame 900
millions d'euros de mesures de maîtrise
proviendront des soins de ville et de
l'hôpital nous allons notamment
continuer à diminuer nos dépenses sur
les tarifs de biologie et d'imagerie
médicale grâce à la réforme de leur
financement à moyen terme les
amendements adoptés à l'Assemblée
nationale concernant la dialyse et la
radiothérapie à l'hôpital permettront de
réajuster leur financement ce travail
autour des économies nécessaires la
soutenabilité de notre système doit se
poursuivre au-delà de ce PLFSS je
rappelle que la loi de programmation des
finances publiques prévoit à partir de
2025 un objectif de 12 milliards d'euros
dont 6 milliards d'euros dans le champ
des administrations de sécurité sociale
en matière d'économie pour atteindre cet
objectif nous nous appuyons sur un
nouveau cycle de revue de dépenses qui
vise à évaluer la qualité de l'action
publique et en amélior
l'efficience nous engagerons aussi des
réformes structurelles sur certains
postes de dépenses comme l'a annoncé la
première ministre cet été nous
souhaitons par exemple engager une
concertation sur les indemnités
journalières je souhaite que ce chantier
puisse aboutir en 2025 enfin nous
renforcerons nos outils de pilotage de
la dépense en particulier nous
engagerons un travail sur longâ pour
qu'il permett de mieux réguler la
dépense et de garantir le respect des
objectifs fixés chaque ch année avec les
parlementaires dans le cadre de la loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
au-delà de l'assurance maladie la
maîtrise et dépense sociale sera permise
par la lutte contre le chômage et nos
actions en faveur du plein emploi nous
bénéficions là des réformes structurel
engagé par le gouvernement et porté en
particulier par Olivier dusopt les
réformes de l'assurance chômage et la
réforme des retraites permettent de
limiter nos dépenses et d'augmenter les
recettes des administrations de sécurité
sociale cette année nous avons atteint
un niveau de chômage historiquement bas
avec 7,2 %. 2 millions d'emplois ont été
créés depuis 2017 pour atteindre le
plein emploi et l'objectif des 5 % nous
devons poursuivre dans ce sens nous
assurons ainsi la pérennité de notre
système le bénéfice de ces réformes doit
être préservé je sais que les derniers
débats sur l'agir Carco ont beaucoup
préoccupé le le Sénat je me réjouis de
constater que les partenaires sociaux se
sont accordés pour discuter du
financement des dispositifs de
solidarité je souhaite que ce dialogue
aboutisse et qu'il puisse s'engager dans
cette voie il y a néanmoins deux mesures
dans le texte concernant ce régime de
retraite complémentaire sur lesquels je
souhaiterais apporter des clarifications
l'article 8 du PLFSS revient sur le
transfert aux URSAF du recouvrement des
cotisations de retraite complémentairire
qui devait avoir lieu en 2024 vous en
aviez souligné les risques dans un
rapport de la mission d'évaluation et de
contrôle des lois de financement de la
sécurité sociale de 2022 et après le
report que vous aviez préconisé et que
nous avons mis en œuvre en 2023 nous
avons désormais fait le choix du
maintien d'un circuit spécifique pour
autant je le dis nous demeurons et nous
demeurons convaincus de l'importance que
l'agir Carco et l'URSAF travaillent
ensemble pour faciliter la vie des
entreprises s'agissant de l'article 9 il
prévit voit un transfert pour le
financement des régimes spéciaux en
extinction en effet le régime va
bénéficier de nombreux nouveaux cotisons
sans devoir effectuer de paiement de
pension avant de longues années la
priorité dem demeure bien sûr donné à la
voie conventionnelle des dispositions
tout à fait similaires ont été examinées
déjà par deux fois par le Parlement
notamment pour la SNCF dans la loi de
finances pour la sécurité sociale pour
2020 sans être contesté alors je
comprends que le sujet est sensible mais
j'espère que vous vous inscrirez dans
ces précédents et ne remettrez pas en
cause le texte du Gouvernement au-delà
des économies nous augmentons aussi les
recettes de la sécurité sociale
l'Assemblée nationale a adopté un
amendement visant à contenir
l'augmentation des allègements de
charges patronales nous avons acté la
stabilisation des barem à leur niveau de
2023 s'agissant des bornes à 2,5 SMIC et
3 5 SMIC ce qui évitera une perte de
recette de l'ordre de 600 millions
d'euros cette mesure ne modifie pas les
exonérations déjà perçues par les
différents secteurs économiques ce qui
permet de les sécuriser je tiens à
saluer le travail de la rapporteur
générale en commission des affaires
sociales qui a introduit un plancher
supplémentaire pour empêcher que
plusieurs gels successifs n'aboutissent
à des seuils inférieurs ou égaux à de
Smic nous y sommes favores
cette mesure apporte là aussi de la
visibilité à tous ce qui correspond
pleinement à nos objectifs en la matière
les économies que je vous présente
renforcent donc la pérennité de notre
système c'est ce qui nous permet de
continuer à investir dans les priorités
des Français l'ONDAM 2023 intègre ainsi
100 millions d'euros annoncés par la
première ministre cet été dans le cadre
d'un nouveau fond d'urgence pour
accompagner les épades et les services à
domicile rencontrant des difficultés
financière en 2024 l'ONDAM franchira les
30 milliards d'euros en direction du
grand âge et du handicap en 2024 nous
poursuivons l'évolution du financement
des éepades pour les départements
volontaires nous poursuivons également
les revalorisations des professionnels
déjà actés à l'hôpital comme dans les
établissements médicaux-saux par exemple
pour les professionnels soignants nous
augmentons la rémunération du travail de
nuit de manière à ce qu'elle soit
supérieure à 25 % au travail de jour
concrètement un infirmier en milieu de
carrière qui travaille 10 à 12 nuits
verra sa rémunération brute augmentée de
300 € par rapport à 2022 ainsi les
dépenses en faveur de l'hôpital
atteindront en 2024 un niveau inédit et
dépasseront 100 milliards d'euros pour
la 2e année consécutive nous avons aussi
amélioré nos mesures sur proposition des
députés nous étendons le champ de la
vaccination contre le papioma virus aux
jeunes accueillis dans des
établissements médicaux-sociaux et nous
généralisons le dépistage du
sitomégalovirus pendant la grossesse
nous avons également acté la prise en
charge aurant berger le rappeler à 100 %
des fauteuils roulants et la suppression
du délai de carence pour les arrêts de
travail qui font suite à une
interruption médicale de grossesse nous
expérimenterons également un nouveau
parcours de soins pour les dépressions
post-partom au total l'ondame 2024
progressera donc de 3,2 % soit un niveau
supérieur à celui de l'inflation qui
s'établira quant à elle à 2,5 %. ce sera
également le cas dans les prochaines
années en dehors de longondame je
souhaite rappeler que le gouvernement
maintient un système protecteur
d'indexation des prestations sur
l'inflation qui pour les retraites
représente 14 milliards d'euros et pour
les prestations familial plus d'un
milliard d'euros supplémentaires en
matière de pension le texte adopté à
l'Assemblée nationale comporte également
une réforme de l'assiette du prélèvement
pour les travailleurs indépendants cette
mesure a vocation à l'UR ouvrir des
droits nouveaux pour la retraite
notamment via les complémentaires tout
en étant neutre au plan des finances
publiques fruit d'une longue
concertation je suis heureux que ce
texte a abouti à temps pour ce PLFSS et
qu'il puisse être examiner avec vous ce
PLFSS acte donc une trajectoire Ambit
pour notre système de santé et de
solidarité il s'agit de maîtriser les
dépenses tout en investissant c'est la
position d'équilibre à laquelle nous
sommes aboutis et que nous souhaitons
conforter lors de nos travaux toutefois
cet équilibre fait preuve d'une autre
menace la fraude notre objectif de
tolérance zéro reste inchangé le
gouvernement est résolu à tout mettre en
œuvre pour détecter poursuivre et
sanctionner chacune de ces fraudes c'est
un impératif financier mais aussi un
impératif d'qu
et de justice sociale pour l'ensemble
des assurés il n'est pas admissible il
n'est pas admissible que certains élus
de leur cotisation perçoivent indument
des prestations abusent de leur
expertise ou comme nous l'avons vu dans
l'actualité la plus récente facilite la
fraude je sais que c'est un sujet que la
commission des affaires sociales et le
Sénat tout entier porte avec force au
travers notamment de rapports comme de
proposition de loi je pense notamment
aux travaux de mesdames les sénatrices
Gruny et haribé ce PLFSS renforce donc
notre arsenal de lutte contre la fraude
nous sécurisons le circuit de paiement
des cotisations des travailleurs de
plateforme garantissant leurs paiement
mais aussi l'acquisition de nouveaux
droits sociaux pour ces travailleurs
nous renforçons les sanctions contre les
professionnels de santé fraudeur ces
professionnels devront rembourser les
cotisations prises en charge par
l'assurance maladie sur 316 millions
d'euros de frotte détecté en 2022 68 %
sont le fait de professionnel de santé
un amendement adopté à l'Assemblée
nationale précise que les informations
sur les professionnels de santé fraudeur
sont transmis aux ordres
professionnels nous sécurisons le
dispositif d'avance immédiate au crédit
d'impôt service à la personne qui
simplifie l'accès à ce service à ces
services mais qui est de manière
démontrée à l'origine de nouveaux
schémas de fraude nous échangeons encore
avec les acteurs en ce moment même pour
faire évoluer le dispositif dans les
prochaines semaines afin de trouver le
bon équilibre entre la prévention
efficace de la frotte d'une part et le
soutien à ce dispositif qui rend service
à plus de 800000 français nous
simplifions le circuit de contrôle des
arrêts maladies et rendons ce contrôle
plus effectif tout en préservant le
droit des assurés un amendement a
d'ailleurs été déposé pour prévoir un
schéma spécifique pour les assurés en
affection de longue durée la lutte
contre la fraude doit également
permettre de traduire en justice et de
sanctionner ceux qui ont en font la
promotion ou mettent des outils à
disposition nous créons un dél de
facilitation de la fraude assorti d'une
peine de 3 ans d'emprisonnement et
250000 € d'amende lorsque les faits sont
commis en ligne les peines seront
aggravées nous proposerons également un
amendement pour augmenter les peines
lorsque les faits sont commis en bande
organisé nous avons la même ambition en
matière de frudte sociale et de frotte
fiscal ce PLFSS s'inscrit ainsi dans la
mise en œuvre du plan de lutte contre
toutes les fraudes par ailleurs doté de
moyens humains renforcés au total 1000
agents supplémentaires participeront à
la lutte contre la fraude au sein des
caises de sécurité sociale d'ici
2027 enfin pour mieux comattre ces
fraudes nous devons mieux les connaître
c'est pourquoi j'ai lancé en octobre le
Conseil d'évaluation de la fraude avec
la participation de plusieurs
parlementaires il travaillera à mieux
évaluer les fraudes dans le champ de
l'assurance maladie et affiner
l'évaluation de la fraude aux
cotisations le projet de loi de finance
de la sécurité
sociale est donc un texte de sérieux et
de responsabilité nous continuons
d'investir massivement dans notre
système de santé et de solidarité nous
amorçons une stratégie de maîtrise et
dépenses afin de retrouver les marges de
manœuvre nécessaire pour faire face aux
crises nous pérénisons un système qui ne
saurait toléré d'être mis à mal par la
fraude je vous
remercie merci monsieur le ministre dans
la suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à Madame Élisabeth douanau
rapporteur général de la commission des
affaires sociales pour 10
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur le Président madamees
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur pour
avis de la commission des finances
Mesdames et Messieurs le rapporteurs de
branche mes chers collègues nous nous
apprêtons donc à examiner le 2e projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale de la la législature ces
conditions d'examen sont étonnamment
proches de celles d'il y a 1 an tout
d'abord comme l'année dernière ces
conditions d'examen par l'Assemblée
nationale ont amené le gouvernement à
recourir à l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution pour faire adopter les deux
parties relatives à l'exercice suivant
et comme l'année dernière pour ne pas
prolonger excessivement la durée
d'examen du texte à l'Assemblée le
gouvernement n'a pas engagé sa
responsabilité sur les autres
dispositions du texte qui nous arrivent
donc cette fois encore dépourvu de
certaines dispositions pourtant
obligatoires dont l'absence pourrait
entraîner la censure de l'ensemble du
texte l'année dernière encore il
manquait le tableau d'équilibre rectifié
et longame rectifié pour l'exercice en
cours cette année c'est à peu près la
même chose sauf qu'il manque également
l'article liminire relatif à l'ensemble
des administrations de sécurité
sociale le Sénat fera bien sûr preuve de
responsabilité et comme l'année dernière
rétablira les dispositions obligatoires
manquant le PLFSS pour 2024 nous arrive
donc tronqué surtout le débat
parlementaire lui-même jusqu'à présent
était tronqué au vu des enjeux
financiers et politiques très importants
des projets de lois de financement de la
sécurité sociale et madamees et
messieurs les ministres vous les avez
rappelé nous avons donc la
responsabilité de faire vivre au Sénat
des débats complets sur le PLFSS pour
2024 soyez sûr que ces débats seront à
l'image du Sénat c'est-à-dire sérieux et
respectueux mais aussi exigeant et
parfois en contradiction avec votre
approche un autre point commun avec la
situation d'il y a un an est que
paradoxalement l'examen du PLFSS pour
2024 coïncide cette fois encore avec
celui d'un projet de loi de
programmation des finances publ en effet
le projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques rejeté par
l'Assemblée nationale et adopté
profondément modifié par le Sénat à
l'automne de l'année dernière nous est
revenu cet automne de l'Assemblée le
gouvernement ayant cette fois eu recours
à l'article 493 et le Sénat l'a adopté
en nouvelle lecture le 16 octobre c'est
le cadre des dispositions essentielles
du PLFSS 2024 sont donc la déclinaison
de dispos figurant dans le projet de loi
de programmation des finances publiques
comme le montant annuel jusqu'en 2027
des dépenses des régime obligatoire de
base de sécurité sociale ou de
l'objectif national de dépense
d'assurance maladie
longame la situation a toutefois évolué
depuis le 16 octobre par exemple compte
tenu en particulier des perspectives
d'exécution de 2023 l'ONDAM pour 2024
peut désormais sembler optimiste et
c'est pour cette raison que nous vous
proposerons de supprimer l'article
43 ces similitudes institutionnelles par
rapport à il y a 1 an ne doivent pas
masquer deux profondes évolutions qui
font de ce PLFSS un PLFSS de rupture la
première rupture c'est l'abandon affiché
non seulement de l'objectif de retour de
la sécurité sociale à l'équilibre mais
même d'un simple objectif de
stabilisation du déficit le déficit a
atteint 40 milliards d'EUR en 2020 du
fait de la crise sanitaire ce qui était
inévitable et parfaitement normal la
France ayant eu recours ayant connu la
pire récession économique depuis la
Seconde Guerre mondiale alors qu'il
fallait en plus assumer le coût direct
de la crise sanitaire et vous l'avez
rappelé monsieur le ministre de la santé
et de la prévention on peut aussi
considérer que le point de départ actuel
c'est-à-dire de 8,8 milliards d'euros en
2023 est aussi pour les
normal le produit intérieur brut ayant
été réduit par la crise de manière
durable voire pérenne ce qui explique
l'essentiel de ce
déficit ce qui est sans doute moins
normal c'est qu'à partir de ce point de
départ de 8,8 milliard d'euros la
situation se dégrade fortement
l'augmentation du déficit se poursuivant
pour atteindre 17,5 milliard d'euros en
2027 c'est une différence majeure par
rapport à la situation des années 2010
où après la crise des dettes souveraines
le déficit était passé de plus de 25
milliards d'euros un quasi équilibre
avant la crise sanitaire il y a là comme
un aveu d'impuissance l'idée assumée que
l'on transmet aux générations futures la
dette
sociale schématiquement la branche
maladie actuellement déficitaire
d'environ 10 milliards d'euros le
resterait jusqu'en
2027 la branche vieillesse verrait quant
à elle son défic C explosé passant de 2
milliards d'euros en 2023 à 14 milliards
d'euros en
2027 évidemment il ne faut pas se
tromper sur le sens de ces chiffres
relatifs aux retraites la loi de
financement de sécurité sociale pour
2023 qui supposait déjà dans sa
programmation un report de l'âge légal
de la retraite prévoyait un déficit de
la branche vieillesse de 15,7 milliards
d'e Ros en 2026 déficit qui a été ramené
à 14,2 milliards d'euros lors de la la
loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale en début d'année
réformant les retraites ce qui n'est pas
significativement différent des 14
milliards d'euros actuellement prévus
pour
2027 cette augmentation du déficit de la
branche vs n'est donc pas une nouveauté
elle était prévue lors de la récente
réforme des retraites qui selon le
gouvernement réduit le déficit de 6,3
milliards d'euros en
2027 ce qui est nouveau en revanche
c'est que contrairement à ce qui était
le le cas dans les précédentes lois de
financement de sécurité sociale on ne
prévoit plus d'amélioration du solde de
la branche maladie le gouvernement
assume de financer durablement la santé
par le déficit c'est ça qui est
véritablement contestable dans ce
PLFSS la seconde rupture c'est que l'on
assiste à une déconnexion historique en
2023 entre le déficit de la Sécurité
social d'un côté de 8,8 milliards
d'euros et l'excédent je dis bien
l'excédent hein déficit de l'ensemble
des administrations de sécurité sociale
qui comprennent en plus de la sécurité
sociale des entités comme la cadesse
l'unédi ou les régimes complémentaires
de retraite ces administrations de
sécurité sociale qui correspondent donc
à un périmètre nettement plus large que
la sécurité sociale aurait cette année
un excédent très important ce qui est un
phénomène nouveau apparu l'année
dernière le gouvernement suppose que ce
phénomène historiquement atypique loin
de se résorber va s'accentuer d'ici 2027
où l'excédent des administrations de
sécurité sociale atteindrait un point de
PIB c'est-à-dire 30 milliards d'euros
d'où ces plus de 30 milliards d'euros
d'excédent global
viendrai-il d'un côté on aurait 17,5
milliards d'euros le déficit de la
Sécurité sociale stricto sensu et de
l'autre on aurait une cinquantaine de
milliards d'euros d'excédents divers
correspondant essentiellement à la cadèe
à l'Unedic au régime complémentaire de
retraite et à 6 milliards d'euros
d'économie restant à documenter monsieur
le ministre et dont on ne sait pas
encore comment elles se répartiront
entre la sécurité sociale et justement
les administrations de sécurité sociale
au sens strict et donc les autres
administrations cette programmation
amène à se poser donc quatre questions
la première question est de savoir si
cette programmation d'excédent des
administrations de sécurité sociale à
l'échéance 2027 est réaliste la
Commission des affaires sociale la juge
optimiste elle estime que du fait
notamment d'une hypothèse de croissance
déjà optimiste de 1,3 % par an plutôt
que de 1,7 par an comme le prévoit le
gouvernement et d'un n d'âme plus
dynamique le déficit de la Sécurité
social strict auinsus sera en 2027
nettement supérieur à ce que prévoit la
loi de financement de sécurité sociale
elle considère en outre que les
prévisions d'excédents de l'Unedic et
des régimes complémentaires de retraite
sont optimistes au total en 2027
l'excédent des administrations de
sécurité sociale considéré dans leur
ensemble ne serait pas de plus de 30
milliards d'euros mais à notre avis de
seulement quelques milliards d'euros la
deuxième question est de savoir comment
gérer une situation de décalage entre
une sécurité sociale strict au censu en
fort déficit et d'autres administrations
de sécurité sociale en fort excédent
même s'il nous semble que cet excédent
sera moins fort que ce que pense le
gouvernement le gouvernement choisit de
prendre de l'argent aux administrations
de sécurité sociale en fort excédent
pour le transférer à la branche
vieillesse dans le cas de l'agir Carco
ou à l'état dans le cas de l'Unedic la
commission des affaires sociales juge
ces deux mesures inappropriées elle vous
proposera de supprimer les dispositions
correspondantes aux articles 9 et
articles 10 la Commission considère
qu'il ne faut pas réaliser
subreptissement une nouvelle réforme des
retraites en contraignant financièrement
l'agir Carco et que la priorité pour
l'unedi comme d'ailleurs pour l'ensemble
des administrations publiques est de se
désendetter si l'État veut financer de
nouvelles dépenses il doit le financer
par des économies la troisème question
est celle du financement d'une dette de
la sécurité sociale strict au sensu qui
va continuer à croître en 2020 la loi
autorisé à transférer 136 milliards
d'euros de la dette à la cadè
actuellement c'est seulement 8,8
milliards d'euros qui reste disponible
et c'est justement le déficit de cette
année ça tombe assez bien et donc à
droit un changer les déficits annuels
vont s'accumuler à à l'URSAF caisse
nationale si on ne fait rien dans 10 ans
la somme pourrait atteindre 200
milliards d'euros l'URSAF caisse
nationale se finançant à court terme sur
les marchés cela serait dangereux en
particulier si la France devait
connaître une nouvelle crise
économique je vais aller à la 4è
question et celle de ce qu'il faut faire
pour réduire le déficit de la Sécurité
sociale strict au sensu comme les années
précédentes la commission des affaires
sociales a abordé chacun des articles de
ce testte de façon constructive en
particulier elle propose de réétablir
donc je l'ai dit l'article liminaire
l'article 1 et l'article 2 un peu
modifié et puis
elle a toutefois adopté un amendement
tendant à modifier la répartition de
longame 2023 entre ces différentes
composantes elle a exprimé son désaccord
avec la trajectoire financière et
l'abstance de stratégie du gouvernement
en proposant de rejeter l'article 16 et
annexe a ainsi que l'article 42 je sais
que je dépasse voilà très très fortement
mon temps de parole donc vous l'aurez
compris nous serons tout au long de ce
dialogue que nous espérons riches des
interlocuteurs à la fois exigeants et
constructifs merci Madame la rapporteur
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à Madame Corine
[Applaudissements]
ber
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
Président de la Commission madame la
rapporteur générale monsieur le
rapporteur pour avis mes chers collègues
les projets de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale se suivent et se
ressemblent malheureusement l'assurance
maladie poursuivra en 2024 une
trajectoire de dépenses particulièrement
dynamique à la crise sanitaire et aux
dépenses exceptionnelles qu'elle a
provoqué à succéder depuis 2023 un
contexte inflationniste poursuivant la
hausse rapide de longondam l'objectif
national de dépenses d'assurance maladie
a ainsi augmenté de 27 % en 5 ans
passant de 200 millions milliards pardon
d'euros en 2019 à près de 255 milliards
d'euros en 2024 un montant vertigineux
donc peut ose prétendre qu'il permet de
répondre aujourd'hui aux besoins du
système de santé et de financer
justement l'accès aux soins dans les
territoires une enveloppe considérable
que le gouvernement ne prend encore la
peine ni de justifier ni d'affiner pour
la soumettre de manière lisible à la
représentation nationale le sujet des
franchises et participations forfaitaire
en est devenu tristement
caricaturale sans enthousiasme devant un
manque de transparence qui n'est pas
admissible la Commission n'a d'autre
choix que de proposer de rejeter
l'ondame 2024 des dépenses
substantielles je je disait que ce PLFSS
ne permet pourtant pas de couvrir
laissant cette année encore l'assurance
maladie en déficit le gouvernement nous
annonçait l'en passé un spectaculaire
redraressement des comptes de
l'Assurance maladie sans raison aucune
nous l'avions jugé peu crédible il a
fallu moins de 12 mois pour nous donner
raison et l'annexe A ne tente désormais
même plus d'apporter
d'explication croyez-le monsieur le
ministre nous ne demandions qu'à avoir
tort qui peut se réjouir de voir un
horizon de déficit durable à plus de 9,5
milliards d'euros par an
surtout que finance-t-on aujourd'hui par
la dette de nos enfants le gouvernement
se refuse aujourd'hui à assumer des
choix difficiles pourtant devenus
incontournables au risque d'hypothéquer
définitivement notre offre de
soins près d'une 40antaine d'articles
sont rattachés à la branche maladie et
je retiendrai plusieurs dispositions
emblématiques le soutien à la
vaccination contre les papilloma virus
humains par exemple face au retard
préjudiciable qu'accuse notre pays est
bienvenu mais constitue un volet
prévention réduit à la portion congrue
quand la prescription par les
pharmaciens des antibiotiques pour
angine et cystite incarne la principale
mesure d'accès aux soins face à la
pénurie des
soignants le gouvernement s'attaque
cette année encore aux arrêts de travail
injustifiés par un renforcement des
contrôles et un strict encadrement des
prescriptions en téléconsultation nous y
avons souscrit en matière de financement
le PLFSS prévoit la généralisation
d'expérimentation dite de l'article 51
avec à la clé des modes de financement
nouveaux pour favoriser l'organisation
de parcours coordonnés en ville
particulièrement et là ce gouvernement
n'a pas retenu la méthode prudente des
expérimentations pour un sujet bien plus
ambitieux qui est la réforme du
financement de l'hôpital sur le cœur de
son activité l'activité MCO qui
représente pas moins que 75 milliards
d'euros la Commission ne s'oppose pas
sur le principe à un modèle établi sur
les trois piliers nous l'avons soutenu
l'an passé mais nous ne pouvons
applaudir la méthode gouvernementale qui
propose une réforme sans s champ réel
défini sans étude d'impact et sans
financement
complémentaire on aurait pourtant pu
croire le gouvernement vacciné depuis la
mise en œuvre ératique des réformes de
la psychiatrie et des soins médicaux de
suite et de
réadaptation nous refusons de jouer avec
l'hôpital pour répondre à un effet
d'annonce saisissez monsieur le ministre
la main tendue par la commission enfin
concernant les produits de santé la
Commission a veillé à soutenir l'accès à
l'innovation dans le cadre de l'accès
précoce et assurer une construction
cohérente et utile de la clause de
sauvegarde elle a également travaillé à
consolider les dispositions visant à
prévenir les ruptures
d'approvisionnement en
médicaments pourtant malgré ces quelques
mesures intéressantes et que la
Commission a souhaité accompagner ce
PLFSS laisse un goût à ma quant au texte
sur lequel le gouvernement a engagé sa
responsabilité on peine avoir des
engagements majeurs quand seul des
disposition cosmétique ou relevant de
bons sentiment ont été retenu monsieur
le ministre vous nous disiez a quelques
semaines que nous pouvions nous passer
d'un projet de loi santé dans la mesure
où le Parlement est saisi chaque année
du PLFSS ce PLFSS ne revit pourtant ni
la forme ni l'apparence d'une loi santé
et cela va s'ans dire il n'a pas
d'avantage la cohérence d'une telle loi
cela devrait d'une certaine manière nous
réjouir la vocation du plan Jup de 1996
n'était pas d'en faire un texte portant
diverses mesures d'ordre sociale à trop
confondre le PLFSS avec un grand
Fourtout annuel et à s'en satisfaire le
gouvernement en même temps le Parlement
d'un débat financier et d'un débat sur
la politique de santé j'espère que
l'examen de ce PLFSS apportera des
réponses claires quant aux solutions que
le gouvernement entend défendre pour
retrouver une trajectoire de financement
saine pour l'assurance maladie lui
donnant la capacité d'affronter les
défis de santè actuels nous sommes prêts
à en débattre je vous
remercie merci merci cher collègues dans
la suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à Madame Pascale gruni
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales pour l'assurance
[Applaudissements]
vieillesse monsieur le Président
madamees et Messieurs les ministre
monsieur le Président de la Commission
madame le rapporteur général monsieur le
rapporteur pour avis 2023 était marqué
par l'adoption d'une réforme des
retraites portée depuis plusieurs années
par notre assemblée très tardivement
trop tardivement sans doute mais mieux
vaut tard que jamais la trajectoire
financière de la branche vieillesse
démontre d'ailleurs s'il était encore
nécessaire que cette réforme était non
seulement indispensable mais même encore
insuffisante 2023 devrait en effet être
la dernière année de réduction du
déficit de la branche sous l'effet du
rebond économique post covid dès 2024 en
raison du vieillissement démographique
du ralentissement de la croissance de la
masse salariale du secteur privé et des
difficultés financières de la cnrcll la
courbe s'inversera brutalement le
déficit qui s'approche du milliard
d'euros aujourd'hui serait ainsi décuplé
à l'horizon de
2027 sans cette réforme tant décriée à
ma gauche ce ne sont pas 11 milliards de
déficit que nous aurions alors à gérer
mais plus de 17 milliards quels efforts
aurions-nous alors demander aux Français
à ceux qui considèrent encore et
toujours que c'est au pied du mur que
l'on voit le maçon je réponds avec
fermeté la réforme était nécessaire et
nous sommes fiers de l'avoir demandé et
assumé venons-en maintenant à ce PLFSS
s'il contient quelques propositions
intéressantes permettant de corriger les
effets de bord ou les oublis de la
réforme des retraites je voudrais
surtout insister ici sur deux mesures
d'ampleur la première prévue à l'article
9 consiste en l'adossement des des
régimes spéciaux fermés au régime
général qui sera désormais chargé
d'assurer leur équilibre en lieu et
place de l'État lequel lui attribuera en
compensation des recettes correspondant
au crédits actuels de la mission régimes
sociaux et de retraite en parallèle
l'agir Carco versera au régime général
une contribution correspondant aux
cotisations perçues de ces nouvelles
affiliations liées à la mesure des
régimes spéciaux ce qui me paraît tout à
fait légitime dans la mesure où ces
derniers demeurent responsable du P des
pensions des assurés affiliés avant le
1er septembre ce qui l' beaucoup moins
en revanche c'est la seconde
contribution demandée à l'agir Carco au
titre des gains que le régime
complémentaire tire de la réforme des
retraites de fait le gouvernement lui
demande une contribution correspondant
au gain brut générés par la réforme
alors que les partenaires sociaux ont
décidé de financer à partir de ces gains
la suppression du bonus malus la
création de droits en cumul emploi et
retraite et la revalorisation des pens à
un niveau proche de l'inflation en outre
après l'abandon du système universel de
retraite et de l'unification du
recouvrement social il n'est pas
acceptable que le gouvernement tente une
troisième fois de s'imposer aux
partenaires sociaux dont les décisions
courageuses ont permis de redresser la
trajectoire financière de l'agir Carco
au prix des efforts importants consentis
par les travailleurs la commission vous
propose donc mes chers collègues de
témoigner une fois de plus de notre
attachement au paritarisme en lui
confiant et à lui seul la responsabilité
de décider de contribuer ou non au
financement des déficits du régime
général la confiance envers les
partenaires sociaux tel est également la
position que je vous proposerai
d'adopter sur la réforme de l'assiette
sociale des travailleurs indépendants
prévu à l'article 10 le gouvernement
souhaite en effet assurer la neutralité
financière de cette réforme très
attendue des professionnels dans la
mesure où elle leur permettra à niveau
global de prélèvement constant de
cotiser davantage et donc de s'ouvrir
des droits supplémentaires pour ce faire
il demande notamment être habilité à
modifier lui-même les taux et les barèes
des cotisations de retraite
complémentaires des professionnels
libéraux là encore la commission vous
invitera à refuser d'accorder une telle
autorisation qui non seulement n'a pas
sa place dans une loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale mais constituerait
également un dangereux précédent j'en
profite pour déplorer le choix
d'intégrer au texte une réforme d'une
telle ampleur dont le coût brut
s'éleverit à 1,4 milliard d'euros par
voie d'amendement sans é d'impact dans
la précipitation la plus totale alors
qu'elle n'a pas vocation à s'appliquer
avant
2026 aucune information ne m'a par
ailleurs été communiquée au sujet des
professions qui perdrai au niveau du
mode de calcul il n'est pas acceptable
monsieur le ministre que la la
représentation nationale soit contrainte
à travailler dans de telles
conditions enfin notre commission a
souhaité aller au-delà de quelques
mesures proposées par le gouvernement
pour lutter contre la fraude aux
prestations sociales c'est la raison
pour pour laquelle elle vous soumettra
un amendement tendant à rendre
obligatoire le contrôle biométrique de
l'existence des bénéficiaires de pension
de retraite résidant à l'étranger d'ici
à 3 ans afin de mettre un terme aux
pratiques scandaleuses observées dans un
certain nombre de pays où les ayant
droit de retraité décédés depuis
longtemps Contin continuent de percevoir
leur pension il s'agit d'assurer
ensemble mes chers collègues l'équité et
la justice de notre système de retraite
je vous
remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est maintenant dans
la suite de la discussion générale à
Monsieur Olivier ho rapporteur de la
commission des affaires sociales pour la
famille Mons
h monsieur le Président madame messieurs
les les ministres madame la rapporteur
général monsieur le président de
commission monsieur le rapporteur pour
avis chers collègues alors sur cette
branche famille et sur cette politique
familiale on est en quelque sorte
partagé parce qu'on entend bien votre je
l'ai dit en commission votre votre
allant votre désir d'agir madame la la
ministre votre discours aussi sur la la
natalité sur la démographie qui sonne à
nos
oreilles puisque nous avons aujourd'hui
dans notre pays 700000 naissances et
nous en avions auparavant 850000 et donc
bien évidemment il y a pour la politique
familiale une forme de priorité d'autant
plus que nous comptons parmi la majorité
sénatorial et le groupe UC ceux qui
pensent que la politique familiale a un
rôle majeur à jouer dans notre pays pour
faire en sorte que la la démographie se
se
redresse mais si je regarde et si nous
regardons actuellement la politique
familiale dans ce PLFSS on est tenté de
se dire que c'est quand même la grande
oubliée puisque sur l'état des lieux les
allocations familiales ne sont pas
universelles elles ne le sont plus
depuis 2015 malheureusement il y a la
question du complément de mode de garde
et du tiers payant qui est encore
repoussé il y a la question de la
réforme du congé parental j'ai bien vu
que vous annonciez un nouveau congé et
donc on va regarder ça avec attention
mais pour ce PLFSS ça n'y est pas il y a
la question de l'attractivité des des
métiers il y a la question aussi j'en
fais une parenthèse mais la médecine
scolaire la médecine de PMI comme la
médecine du travail qui est qui est en
crise et puis il y a cette nébuleuse
même si nous partageons l'objectif de du
service public de la petit enfance et du
du création de la création de place et
de en crèche et pour ce qui concerne les
modes de garde donc voilà on est mis en
appétit mais sur ce PLFSS il y a pas
grand-chose en quelque sorte et donc
donc maintenant sur le texte lui-même
selon les prévisions du gouvernement
vous l'avez dit les dépenses devraient
s'élever à 5 58 milliards d'euros elles
sont donc en hausse c'est juste par
rapport à 2022 mais cette dynamique est
le résultat de l'indexation des
prestations légales et des quelques
mesures votées les années précédentes
elle intègre aussi également les efforts
financiers de la CNAF quant aux
prestations extra légal en faveur des
Accueils Collectifs le Fond national de
d'action sociale de la branche
augmentera ainsi ses dépenses de 10,4 %
2023 enfin et surtout la hausse des
dépenses traduit le transfert en LFSS
pour 2023 des 60 % des charges de congé
maternité à la CNAF depuis la branche
maladie et donc c'est une amputation de
2 milliards d'euros la sécurité sociale
parvient de moins en moins à soutenir
tous les ménages à l'arrivée d'un enfant
je pense notamment aux familles de la
classe moyenne exclus par des barêes de
prestation sans pour autant disposer de
revenus nécessaires pour réaliser leurs
désirs d'enfant pire euh le sol de la
branche ne permet pas les marges de
manœuvre suffisantes pour les rénéformes
annoncé par le gouvernement ni encore
moins pour les autres réformes
nécessaires et c'est une préoccupation
pour nous c'est pourquoi un amendement
de la rapporteur général que nous
saluons vous proposera d'amonder les
recettes de la branche famille de 2
milliards d'euros provenant de
l'assurance maladie ainsi on ne pourra
pas nous faire le coup on n' pas les
ambitions on a les ambitions mais euh on
n' pas l'argent s'agissant des des
mesures de de politique familiale ce
PLFSS et je le dis une forme d'anné
d'année blanche l'article 46 bis propose
un assouplissement de la prise de congé
paternité d'accueil de l'enfant pour les
non salariés agricoles la commission a
adopté cet article l'article 46 TER
propose divers ajustements marginaux à
la réforme du complément mode de garde
la la Commission a valité la plupart de
ces paramètres mais nous souhaitons
maintenir les dispositifs qui avaient
été supprimés notamment pour ce qui
concerne les les horaires atypiques
cependant la Commission a juger que la
réforme à venir du CMG devait répondre à
l'ensemble des situations familiales et
c'est pour ça que nous proposons un
amendement l'article 46 TER propose
également de reporter à 2026 vous l'avez
dit l'entrée de la réforme du tiers
payant du CMG nous souhaitons que ce
soit applicable le plus rapidement
possible vous l'avez évoqué dans votre
intervention voilà il s'agit pas pour
nous de de reporter cette réforme et
puis vous dire que l'universalité de la
politique familiale ça ne se décrète pas
c'est comme l'amour hein il faut des
preuves d'amour c'est c'est encore ce
qu'il y a de mieux et ça s'incarne donc
par des mesures concrètes et tant que
les allocations familiales pour des
raisons budgétaires ne soutiendront pas
toutes les familles de la même manière
il n'y aura pas de politique universelle
pour nous sachons donc répondre aux
angoisses des familles pas seulement par
des mots mais aussi par des réformes
courageuses et et ambitieuse je vous
remercie merci Monsieur
ho la parole dans la suite de la
discussion générale est maintenant à
Madame Marie-Pierre Richet rapporteur de
la commission des affaires sociales pour
les accidents du travail et les maladies
professionnel pour 5
minutes mesdames et messieurs les
ministres monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président de la Commission madame la
rapporteur générale monsieur le
rapporteur pour avis mes chers collègues
après une année 2023 marquée par un
excédent record de 1,9 milliards d'euros
la branche ATMP maintiendra sa situation
excédentaire en 2024 malgré la baisse
des taux de cotisation pour la branche
acté lors de la réforme des retraites
afin de garantir la neutralité
financière pour les employurs d'une Neha
symétrique pour la branche vieillesse
les 17,1 milliard d'euros de recettes
prévisionnelles pour 2024 seront
suffisants pour couvrir l'objectif de
dépense de la branche fixé à 16
milliards d'euros que je vous inviterai
à adopter l'excédent structurelle de la
branche ATMP peut paraître confortable
voir enviable au regard de la situation
financière d'autres branches je l'entend
mais il méconnaît en fait un principe
essentiel une branche n'a pas davantage
vocation à être excédentaire qu'à être
déficitaire cette Excédence structurelle
est en fait le signe d'une déconnexion à
long terme entre les besoins de
financement de la branche et ses
recettes illustré par l'excédent cumulé
toujours croissant de la branche qui
atteindra rendez-vous compte 12,5
milliards d'euros à horizon 2027 autant
de contributions réclamé à l'employeur
sans qu'ell ne serve leur destination
originelle lutter contre les risques
professionnels et indemniser les
victimes et pourtant malgré cette
situation structurellement excédentaire
force de constater que ce projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
est une fois de plus indigeent pour la
branche ATMP alors que l'accentuation de
la prévention est au cœur de toutes les
revendications tant chez les
organisations patronales que syndicales
le gouvernement n'a pas et bon d'inclure
la moindre mesure en la matière dans le
texte initial nous attendions et nous
continuerons malheureusement d'attendre
un changement de paradigme sur la
manière dont la prévention est envisagée
par la branche croyez-vous monsieur le
ministre que les spots télévisuels
déployés depuis un mois soi suffisant
alors que près d'un million de sinistres
restent à déplorer chaque année et que
les dépenses de prévention dépassent
péniblement 2 % des dépenses de la
branche que faut-il attendre pour que
soit mis en œuvre un véritable
accompagnement des entreprises en
matière de prévention
le succès indéniable des programmes
s'inscrivant dans une démarche d'All les
ver comme TMS pro devrait pourtant
conduire à encourager étendre et
développer de telles initiatives pas de
prévention donc mais à la place des
prélèvements pesant toujours plus lourd
sur la branche ATMP il semblerait que la
branche parce qu'elle est excédentaire
doit avoir ses ressources Siphonées la
commission s'y oppose naturellement et a
revu à la baisse le transfert à la
branche maladie au titre de la
sous-déclaration
elle a également déploré que le
gouvernement qui bien que l'État soit
responsable du scandale de l'amante
laisse la branche àmp augmenter de 50 %
sa dotation au fond d'indemnisation des
victimes de la miante en 2024 sans
avancer un centime de plus dans ce pfss
c'est toutefois une autre mesure qui a
concentré tous les débats mais aussi
surtout toutes les critiques le
gouvernement était très attendu pour cet
article 39 qui devait engager une
réforme ambitieuse de la rente ATMP et
transposer un accord national
interprofessionnel signé à l'unanimité
des partenaires sociaux le résultat est
décevant puisque les partenaires sociaux
ne se reconnaissent pas dans les
modalités de transcription retenu en
courtcircuitant le dialogue social en
réclamant un chèque en blanc au
Parlement sur une réforme dont tout
reste à déterminé en ignorant les
associations le résultat est là un
article qui en définitive ne satisfait
quasiment personne mal compris et
inapplicable en l'état il a exacerbé les
tensions entre partenaires sociaux en
l'absence de consensus l'article est
supprimé du texte transmis et je vous
inviterai naturellement vous prononcer
pour la confirmation de sa suppression
la ni doit maintenant faire l'objet si
un consensus venait être trouvé d'une
transcription intégrale dans un projet
de loi ad hoc il est possible de
retravailler le texte et d'adopter une
réforme plus équilibrée sans retarder
excessivement le calendrier de mise en
œuvre initialement prévu pour l'article
39 fixé à fin 2024 répondant ainsi aux
inquiétudes des organisations
patronnales auditionnées il devra
convenir à toutes les parties y compris
les associations de défense des victimes
les trois autres articles pent des
mesures utiles à n'en pas douter mais
dont les répercussions financières sur
l'équilibre de la branche devrai être
modestes je vous inviterai à les adopter
modifi par les amendements de la
commission l'article 26 prévoit que les
médecins du travail puissent déléguer à
des infirmiers qualifiés en santé au
travail dans la limite de leurs
compétences et dans un cadre sécurisé
par la commission certains actes de
renouvellement périodique de l'examen
médical d'aptitude des salariés
agricoles bénéficiaire du suivi
individuel renforcé en ce sens il
accroit a l'accessibilité au médecins du
travail et renforcera l'attractivité des
services santé sécurité au travail des
caisses de mutualité sociale agricole
l'article 39 bis sécurisera pour le
passé pour l'avenir le versement de deux
prestations relevant du régime des
marins tandis que l'article 39 TER
offrira de nouveaux outils au fond
d'indemnisation des victimes de la
miante pour lutter contre un nonreours
alarmant qui avoisinerit les 50 % pour
les cas de mésotélium je vous
remercie
merci Madame rich maintenant la parole
est à Madame Chantal de Seine rapporteur
de la commission des affaires sociales
pour
[Applaudissements]
l'autonomie monsieur le Président Madame
et messieurs les ministres chers
collègues l'objectif de dépense de la
branche autonomie pour 2024 fixé par le
PLFSS à
39,9 milliards d'euros en augmentation
de 5,3 %. les perspectives financières
de la branche sont temporairement
améliorées par l'apport de 0,15 points
de CSG supplémentaire en provenance de
la cadè cela représente un surcroix de
recette de 2 2,6 milliards d'euros ainsi
la branche passerait d'un déficit de 1,1
milliard d'euros en 2023 à un excédent
de de 1 3 milliards en
2024 toutefois cet excédent devrait
s'éroder rapidement sous l'effet du
dynamisme tendanciel des dépenses en
l'absence de mesures nouvelles il ne
serait plus que de 0,4 milliards d'euros
en 2027 la question des ressources de la
branche va donc de nouveau se poser dans
un avenir proche dans un contexte de
vieillissement de la population et des
besoins encore
insatisfait ce contexte exige une
croissance du secteur médicau ocial qui
sera difficile à soutenir alors que le
gouvernement avait annoncé le
recrutement de 50000 équivalents temps
plein dans les épad sur le quinquena cet
objectif a vu son horizon repoussé à
2030 après les 3000 ETP prévus cette
année 6000 recrutements seraient
financés pour 2024 ce nombre permettra
d'améliorer le taux d'encadrement des
épades mais reste bien endessà des
besoins quant au virage domiciliaire il
peinene encore à se dessiner malgré les
réformes engagées en 2022 et les efforts
financiers qui en ont résulté des
créations massives de places seraient
nécessaire au cours des prochaines
années pour répondre à la demande de
service à domicile l'objectif de créer
25000 places en CAD se heur toutefois à
une profonde difficulté de recrutement
que connaît le secteur dans le champ du
handicap les 50000 solutions nouvelles
annoncées lors de la dernière conférence
nationale du handicap reste flou et
agrège des niveaux de prise en charge
très divers pour 2024 ils incluent des
moyens renforcés pour les centres
d'action
sociaux les centres d'action
médico-social précoce pour faire face au
défis que représente pour la branche
PLFSS propose des mesures en demi-teinte
la situation financière des
établissements et services sociaux et
médicau-sociaux est singulièrement des
épades et préoccupantes alors qu'une
majorité d'établissements sont en
déficit le fond d'urgence de 100
millions d'euros prévus pour cette année
par le PLFSS qui concernera les épades
et les services à domicile de tout
statut et nécessaire et bienvenu mais
rapportter au nombre de structures il
s'apparente à un saupoudrage le texte
pourrait néanmoins marquer en tournant
en matière de financement des épades en
amorçant la fusion entre la section
soins actuellement financée par la
Sécurité sociale et la section
dépendance financé par les départements
cette répartition des ressources et des
dépenses des établissements apparaît de
moins en moins pertinente cont tenu de
l'évolution du profil des personnes
accueillies l'article 37 introduit donc
un régime adapté de financement des
épades dans lequel une section soins et
entretien de l'autonomie serait
subventionnée par un forfait global
unique attribué par la RS et financé par
la branche autonomie ce régime créé de
manière pérenne serait toutefois à la
carte au choix des département la
Commission a considéré que cette réforme
pourrait à rebours des objectifs
affichés se traduire par des complexités
supplémentaires elle propose donc de
transformer ce régime adapté de
financement en une expérimentation avant
toute généralisation et pérennisation du
dispositif mais madame la ministre lors
de votre prise de parole j'ai entendu
votre réponse favorable à cette
proposition plus largement la commission
appelle à rationnaliser les concours
financiers de l' CNSA au département
pour les rendre plus lisibles et
équitabl
l'article 38 crée un nouveau service de
repérage de diagnostic et d'intervention
précoce pour les enfants de moins de 6
ans susceptible de présenter un handicap
la Commission s'est interrogé sur la
valeur ajoutée de ce dispositif et sur
son articulation avec les plateformes
déjà déployées pour prendre en charge
les troubles du neurodéveloppement en
revanche mais vous en avez parlé
également madame la ministre aucune
solution n'est proposée pour les jeunes
adultes maintenus dans les
établissements pour enfants au titre de
l'amendement Creton afin de répondre à
leur situation la Commission a prévu un
dispositif expérimental de transition
pour accompagner ces jeunes dès l'âge de
16 ans j'évoquerai pour finir l'article
38 B s garantir le remboursement
intégral des fauteuils roulants mais
dont la portée est très incertaine
madame la ministre pourriez-vous nous
donner des précisions sur les conditions
d'application de cette mesure et sur son
coût financier sous ces réserves la
commission vous invite à approuver
l'objectif de dépense de la pche pour
2024 je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est maintenant à Monsieur Vincent delaer
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des
finances monsieur le Président Madame et
Messieurs les ministre monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur générale
chers
collègues la des finances saisie pour
avis a donneré à ce texte un avis
favorable non parce qu'elle a pensé que
la politique menée est la bonne ni parce
qu'elle a jugé la trajectoire financière
suivie
convaincante mais pour que le Sénat
discute ce texte et
l'améliore depuis la crise sanitaire la
situation des régimes obligatoires de
base de la sécurité sociale et du fond
de solidarité vieillesse se sont
redressé un déficit de seulement 8,8
milliards d'euros est attendu en
2023 si l'on peut jouir que le déficit
se réduise il est toutefois inquiétant
qu'il diminue moins
qu'attendu la résorption du déficit
résulte principalement du dynamisme des
recettes tié à la progression de
l'emploi et de la masse salariale en
dépense toutefois le fameux hondâ
connaîtrait un dépassement de 2,8
milliards d'euros en 2023 porté par
l'évolution des soins de
ville ce dépassement intervient alors
que les surcout imputable à la crise
sanitaire se sont considérablement et
logiquement réduits il ne représente
plus que 900 million d'euros en 2023
toutefois la crise a durablement affecté
la trajectoire de long d'AM qui
s'établit en 2023 à un niveau de 14,2
milliards d'euros supérieur à un
scénario sans crise et surtout sans
Ségure s'agissant de 2024 la dynamique
des recettes ralentirait contrairement à
celle des dépenses qui s'accroitrai en
clair tout ce qu'il ne faut pas faire en
ce qui concerne les recettes le
ralentissement de la masse salariale du
secteur privé ne serait que
partiellement compensé par le transfert
de la branche à la branche autonomie de
015 points de CSG auparavant affecté à
la caisse d'amortissement de la dette
sociale la
cadèe l'objectif de dépenses pour 2024
quant à lui connaîtrait un véritable
rebond si la hausse des dépenses de la
branche maladie serait en principe
modéré longam n'augmentant que de 2,95 %
par rapport à
2023 les dépenses de la branche
vieillesse devraient être soigneusement
surveillé et j'étéis surpris madame et
messieurs les ministres que dans vos
interventions vous n'abordiez quasiment
pas ce sujet des
retraites par Monsieur casazenav un tout
petit peu mais pour le
reste on remarque que le report de l'âge
d'ouverture des droits n'aura en effet
d'impact que progressivement alors que
les mesures d'accompagnement ont un
effet immédiat le sold de la branche se
dégraderait ainsi de 4 milliards d'euros
en 2024 le déficit global repartirait à
la hausse en 2024 pour s'établir à 11,1
milliards d'euros il s'agit là d'une
situation inquiétante dans dans la
mesure où chacun le sait le déficit cède
la dette et que les conditions de
remboursement de la dette sociale se
sont sérieusement dégradées ces
dernières années en effet le taux moyen
de refinancement de la cadèe a connu une
hausse inquiétante de 0,62 % début 2022
à 1,3 % aujourd'hui certains taux
tutoyant même les 3 %. dans le même
temps les ressources dont dispose la
cadesse pour amortir la dette sociale
ont diminué 015 points de CSG lui sont
retirés en 2024 et le versement du fond
de réserve pour les retraites baissera à
partir de 2025 de 2,1 milliards à 14 400
1illard 450 million d'euros j'en viens
aux prévisions
pluriannuelles le déficit de la Sécurité
sociale continuera à se dégrader pour
s'établir à 17,5 milliards d'euros en
2027 pire ce scénario défavorable repose
sur des hypothèses macroéconomiques de
croissance qui ont été jugé optimiste
par le Haut Conseil des finances
publiques donc on peut s'attendre à une
dégradation encore plus
importante concernant la branche maladie
la progression continue des dépenses et
des dépensements réguliers de longam de
ville devrait faire l'objet d'une
réflexion
approfondie le gouvernement se refuse en
effet comme cela a été patant lors de
l'examen du projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques à
envisagé sérieusement une régulation des
soins de ville l'avenir de la maîtrise
des dépenses d'assurance maladie fait
donc l'objet d'un impensé de la part du
gouvernement concernant la branche
vieillesse il est inquiétant de
constater que l'impact de la réforme des
retraites sera vraisemblablement moindre
qu'aiss compté en particulier et ça n'a
pas été abordé la situation de la Caisse
nationale de retraite des agents des
collectivité local la CNR ACL est de
plus en plus préoccupante son déficit ne
cesse de s'aggraver et atteindrait
presque 6,5 milliards d'euros en
2030 plus globalement les déficits
cumulés du budget de la Sécurité sociale
de 2024 à 2027 représenterait environ 60
milliards d'euros il pourrait conduire à
une nouvelle reprise de dette par la
cadèe ce qui repousserait la perspective
de son extinction au-delà de
2033 cont tenu de l'ensemble de ces
éléments vous aurez compris que ma
position sur l'équilibre général du
texte est
réservée si la commission des finances a
donner un avis favorable à titre
personnel je nous appelle collectivement
à rechercher toutes les sources
d'économie possibles et à ne pas voter
de nouvelles dépenses qui ne seraiit pas
financé à défaut nous continuerons
d'être une génération d'égoïstes qui
fait financer ses prestations par les
générations futures vous comprendrez que
cette façon de faire ne m'apparaisse ni
normale ni morale je vous
remercie merci Monsieur de La chers
collègues la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Philippe Mouillet président de
la commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le
[Applaudissements]
Président Monsieur le Président madamees
et messieurs les ministres madame la
rapporteur générale Mesdames et
Messieurs les raorteurs mes chers
collègues comme l'année dernière le
gouvernement a dû utiliser les
dispositions du 3e alinéa de l'article
49 de la Constitution afin que le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale soit adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale comme l'année dernière il en
résulte paradoxalement des délais
d'examen dégradés pour le Sénat je tiens
à cet égard à saluer nos rapporteurs qui
n'ont pas ménagé leurs efforts pour
présenter à la commission puis au Sénat
une position cohérente sur ce texte ils
ont d'autant plus de mérite que de
nombreuses réponses à leurs
interrogations leur sont parvenu très
tardivement voire ne leur sont jamais
parvenu je pense en particulier aux
éléments communiqués au président de
laamex de l'Assemblée nationale sur les
franchises médicales dont notre
rapporteur de la branche maladie n'a
jamais obtenu la transmission cela ne me
semble pas acceptable et contraire la
lettre comme à l'esprit de la loi
organique enfin comme l'année dernière
on aurait pu imaginer que l'engagement
de sa responsab ilité aurait permis au
gouvernement de présenter au Sénat un
texte resserré sur l'essentiel et
présentant des priorités claires mais
c'est une nouvelle fois un texte confus
et bavard qui nous parvient enrichi
certes de dispositions diverses mais
souvent de faible portée sans parler des
nombreuses demandes de rapport émanant
de tous les groupes
politiques sur le fond les rapporteurs
ont déjà bien exprimé la position de la
Commission vous l'arez compris madames
et mieurs les ministres nous souhaitons
un débat complet sur le PLFSS d'autant
que l'Assemblée nationale en a été
privée nous souhaitons exprimer notre
scepticisme face à l'ONDAM que vous
proposez pour 2024 et notre vive
inquiétude face à la dette perpétuelle à
laquelle vous semblez condamner la
sécurité sociale selon vos propres
projections financière mais nous
souhaitons aussi formuler nos
propositions pour renforcer le contrôle
du Parlement sur les comptes sociaux par
exemple en cas de dépassement de long
d'â ou pour ce qui concerne les crédits
des agences pour responsabiliser les
différentes parties prenantes dans le
domaine de la santé qu'il s'agisse des
patients ou des professionnels ou encore
pour mieux lutter contre la fraude tant
pour les bénéficiaires de pension de
retraite établie hors de France que sur
la question récurrente de la carte
Vitale biométrique que nous ne voyons
pas
avancer nous souhaitons également aider
le gouvernement et oui aider le
gouvernement à ne pas transformer des
idées intéressantes en échec programmé
faute de préparation adéquate je je
pense bien sûr à la réforme du
financement des hôpitaux mais aussi à la
fusion des sections soins et dépendan
des épades dans un cas comme dans
l'autre une expérimentation solide nous
semble un préalable indispensable à une
généralisation nous sommes prêts à vous
accompagn dans ce sens mais avec cette
phase préalable et nous souhaitons bien
sûr exprimer nos priorités en
particulier en en faveur des familles
peu présent dans ce pfss le discours est
là madame la ministre mais traductions
budgétaires sont plutôt absentes mais
également des collectivités
territoriales nous avons entendu
l'assoation des maires de France des
département de France pardon ces
derniers jours qui s'inquiète de leur
situation financière nous devons donc
gérer être présent et faire en sorte que
leurs dépenses notamment en matière de
dépendance soit soutenu nous marquerons
aussi notre respect du paritarisme en ne
permettant pas que le gouvernement se
servent dans les caisses de l'Unedic et
de l'agic Arco enfin Madame et monsieurs
ministre comme l' voqué notre rapporteur
général la Commission proposera à la
haute assemblée de rétablir les articles
obligatoires de ce pfss que l'Assemblée
nationale a supprimé et dont la
supprpression conforme aurait posé un
problème constitutionnel manifeste
elle le fera en proposant néanmoins une
révision de longam 2023 dont le volet
hospitalier nous sommes encore
sous-financés j'espère que vous serez y
voir une main tendue et que vous serez
la saisir notamment lors de la nouvelle
le à l'Assemblée nationale je conclurai
en rappelant que nos propositions
s'inscrivent dans un cadre strictement
budgétaire c'est un texte financier elle
ne serait donc remplacé de grandes lois
structurantes seules à même de remettre
à PL des secteurs comme la santé ou le
grand âge pour lesquells la confiance
des professionnels et des Français dans
leur ensemble s'étiolle année après
année malgré une augmentation des moyens
financiers on l'a vu et donc il y a un
débat de responsabilité vis-à-vis des
générations futures vous l'avez évoqué
également monsieur le rapporteur donc
nous pensons qu'aujourd'hui il
nécessaire de remettre à plat de
proposer quelque part un projet
structurant de réforme et on peut
simplement se limiter à quelques
propositions de loi quel que soit leur
intérêt le gouvernement doit prendre ses
responsabilité l'assumer et par la suite
le traduire dans le pfssel est notre
état d'esprit aujourd'hui je
remercie merci monsieur le
Président nous passons à la discussion
de la motion tendante à la question
préalable mesame
cathyoursopoli Céline Brulin syvana
syvani et les membres du groupe
communiste républicain citoyens et
écologiste kanaki ont déposé une motion
distribuée sous le numéro 944 tendant à
opposer la question préalable au texte
en discussion la parole est à Madame
Cathy apursopoli pour la motion pendant
minutes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues alors
que nous entamons l'examen du projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2024 un budget de 640
milliards d'euros nous avons une pensée
pour nos collègues députés qui n'ont pas
pu débattre une fois de plus vous avez
préféré un passage en en force en ayant
eu recours à votre 5ro 493 de la
Constitution sur la partie recette et
sur la partie dépense au final seul 9U
articles sur 50 du texte ont été
discutés par les députés l'absence de
majorité parlementaire du gouvernement
ne doit pas ne doit masquer la gravité
de la situation de la sécurité sociale
victime de 20 ans de privation
d'étatisation de désinvestissements et
de réduction des personnels le débat que
nous entamons sur le budget de la
Sécurité sociale pour 2024 sera
l'occasion d'affronter nos visions de
notre modèle social lors de la réunion
de la commission des Affaires social
nous avons entendu l'ensemble des
groupes politiques dans leur diversité
dire que nous ne pouvions plus continuer
comme ça sans réforme structurelle de la
sécurité sociale l'hôpital public va mal
la médecine de ville est en crise les
difficultés d'accès aux soins
progressent pourtant les dépenses
augmente se sont étonnés naïvement
certains de nos
collègues au final nous pensons qu'ils
vautront certainement tout de même le
PLFSS les gouvernements successifs qui
ont tenté de compresser les dépenses
pour satisfaire aux exigences de
Bruxelles ont sous-estimé les
conséquences de l'austérité sur notre
protection sociale les personnels du
secteur sanitaire médico-social social
qui a accepté des conditions de travail
dégradé et des rémunérations
insuffisantes depuis des années ont
craqué et lorsque les personnels n'en
peuvent plus c'est tout un système qui
s'effondre ils ont craqué car leur
attachement au service public et le sens
de l'intérêt général qui les faisait se
lever chaque matin ne suffisait plus
face à la mise en danger des patients la
violence institutionnel des personnels
qui refusent de continuer de subir la
surcharge et leurs conditions de travail
entraînent des démissions massives on
parle aujourd'hui de 15000 postes
vacants de praticiens hospitaliers et de
15000 postes vacants d'infirmières selon
la Fédération hospitalière de France
pour améliorer le recrutement il
faudrait augmenter les capacités de
formation de 20 % pour les médecins et
de 25 % pour les paramédicaux quand
allez-vous prendre de véritables mesures
pour Pier à ces manques nous le savons
il faut améliorer les rémunérations la
qualité de vie l'évolution des
conditions de travail entre autres sans
cela c'est peinees perdu seule véritable
condition pour retenir celles et ceux
qui exercent aujourd'hui je pense par
exemple à Marie-Pierre 27 ans infirmière
qui a quitté les urgences pédiatriques
de l'hôpital Necker car elle était
arrivée à saturation et ne supportait
plus la manière dont les patients
étaient traités ce témoignage à
l'hôpital je l'ai également entendu dans
les services médicauxsociaux dans les
épades et dans l'ensemble des services
sociaux mais comment faire pour
améliorer les conditions de travail sans
moyens supplémentaires est-ce sérieux de
laisser miroiter qu'avec pas de moyens
supplémentaires ça ira mieux demain les
personnels n'en peuvent plus et le
gouvernement agite d'un côté le séure de
l'investissement mais de l'autre réduit
500 millions d'euros les dépenses des h
hitaux si on ajoute le coût de l'énergie
et l'inflation les hpitaux sont au bord
de l'implosion le en même temps n'est
pas une manière de gouverné l'une
l'entre deux en matière de santé n'est
plus possible l'austérité ou
l'investissement il faut choisir le
président de la République qui s'est
exprimé en faveur de l'organisation de
référendum dans notre pays devait poser
la question directement à nos
concitoyennes et concitoyens devons-nous
poursuivre les politiques d'austérité et
de compression des dépenses de santé en
acceptant de patienter des jours et
parfois des semaines avant d'avoir un
rendez-vous chez un médecin en acceptant
les fermetures des services des urgences
les weekends et en acceptant d'attendre
des heures entières sur des brancards
ou devons-nous financer les dépenses de
santé à la hauteur des besoins en
revalorisant de 10 milliards d'euros
nets longam c'est-à-dire déduction faite
de l'inflation cette politique n'est pas
utopiste c'est un choix de société qui
repose sur des choix de solidarité et de
financement pour financer notre système
de sécurité sociale à la hauteur des
besoins nous proposons de revenir sur
les exonérations de cotisation en 2024
le gouvernement prévoit d'exonérer les
entreprises de
87,9 milliards d'euros
87,9 milliards d'euros c'est deux fois
plus qu'il y a 10 ans 87,9 milliards
d'euros c'est autant d'argent public
perdu pour les recettes de l'État 87,9
milliards d'euros enfin c'est autant
d'argent supplémentaire pour les patrons
et les actionnaires qui ne vont ni dans
les recrutement supplémentaire ni dans
l'augmentation des salaires le directeur
de recherche du CNR Bruno palier n'a pas
de mot plus dur sur les politique
d'exonération de cotisation sociale et
d'aide aux entreprises selon lui les
politiques de baisse du coût du travail
se sont avéré inefficaces en matière
d'emploi et délétaire pour le travail
depuis 1993
les plans généraux de baisse des
cotisations sociales les allègements
Fillon le crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité et l'emploi de François
Hollande ont eu pour effet de
dévaloriser d'intensifier et d'abîmer le
travail en France auquel évidemment il
faut ajouter un transfert de financement
des cotisations patronales par des
cotisation des compensations partielles
de l'État VO via des fractions de
recettes de TVA ainsi les entreprises ne
participent plus au cement de la
sécurité sociale en dessous de
3,5 SMIC tandis que nos concitoyennes et
concitoyens qui achètent leur baguette
de pain finance leur retraite et leur
hôpital cette incongruité pourrait nous
amener à en sourire si en creux elle ne
remettait pas en cause le pacte social
de la nation les besoins augmentent et
les dépenses vont inexorablement
continuer à progresser avec le
vieillissement de la société pour
réussir à financer notre système de
sécurité sociale il faut mettre à cont
distribution les revenus financiers des
entreprises et moduler les cotisations
selon les politiques sociales et
environnementales des entreprises plutôt
que de chercher de nouvelles recettes le
gouvernement réduit les dépenses en
faisant les poches aux malades avec le
projet de doublement des franchises
médicales en selon un sondage hlab du 2
novembre 63 % des Français estiment que
ce n'est pas acceptable que le
doublement de la franchise sur les
médicaments contribue à détériorer
l'accès à la santé son risque politique
le gouvernement recule mais ne renonce
pas à augmenter le reste à charge des
malades par la publication d'un décret
dans quelques semaine et ainsi éviter un
débat devant le Parlement
cet cet été le ministre de l'économie
avait annoncé l'augmentation des
dépenses d'indemnité journalière maladie
ces dernières années si la proposition
d'augmenter les délais de carence en cas
d'arré maladie ne se retrouve pas dans
le PLFSS 2024 le débat pourrait revenir
par par voie d'amendement cette année ou
l'an prochain ce PLFSS prévoit plusieurs
mesures de culpabilisation et de
stigmatisation des patients je pense à
la limitation à 3 jours des arrêts de
travail prescrit lors d'une
téléconsultation alors que 6 millions de
Français n'ont pas de médecins traitant
mais surtout à la suspension du
versement des indemnités journalières
après un rapport du médecin contrôleur
jugeant un arrêt injustifié cette
suspension automatique des indemnité
journalière versé par la Sécurité
Sociale suite au contrôle mandaté par
l'employeur est complètement scandaleuse
elle reprend l'idée que la hausse des
dépenses d'indemnité journalière serait
le fait de médecins trop généreux ou de
travailleurs abuseurs en réalité
l'augmentation des indemnités
journalières s'explique par le
vieillissement de la population active
cette progression va durer après le
recul de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite à 64 ans le contrôle des arrêts
maladies ind isé par l'assurance maladie
doit rester l' panage de l'assurance
maladie avec des garanties de débat et
de recours le risque de dérive vers une
privatisation du contrôle de l'assurée
sociale et de
l'instrumentalisation par l'employeur de
cette procédure vis-à-vis des salariés
en position de fragilité est
intolérable pour financer la réforme de
France travail le gouvernement prévoit
effectuer une ponction de 2,7 milliards
d'euros sur les excédents de l'Unedic
ainsi les économies réalisées sur le dos
des chômeurs en réduisant leurs droits
permettra de financer la case de Pôle
emploi c'est l'effet qui seoule de la
réforme de l'assurance chômage tu joues
et de toute façon dans tous les cas tu
perds le gouvernement prévoyait la
ponction de 3 milliards sur les comptes
agir Carco après la levée de bouclier
des organisations syndicales vous avez
été obligé de reculer mais nous savons
pertinemment que vous n'avez pas
abandonné votre projet définitivement
vous préférez présenter au Sénat a un
budget insincère le gouvernement
renforce les contrôles sur les arrêts de
travail au lieu de s'attaquer aux 8
milliards de frotes patronales et de
réfléchir aux conditions de travail dans
les entreprises en conclusion le mépris
du gouvernement à l'égard du Parlement
le 493 à l'Assemblée nationale et au
Sénat l'article 40 qui fait voler en
éclat nos amendements l'absence de
refonte du financement de notre système
de sécurité sociale avec un namme bien
en dessous des besoins alors qu'il
aurait fallu indexer celui-ci sur
l'inflation le manque de mesures
concrètes la stigmatisation des assurés
sociaux toutes ces raisons ne permettent
pas de réunir les conditions d'un
véritable débat politique pour
l'ensemble de ces raisons le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologiste kanaki appelle à voter notre
mention tendant à opposer la question
préalable je vous remercie merci madame
la
[Applaudissements]
sénatrice quel est l'avis de la
commission monsieur le ministre
l'avis de la commission d'abord
oui merci chers collègues pour votre
plédoyer dans les premiers mots vous
dites on a été finalement privé du débat
à l'Assemblée nationale mais en quelque
sorte ce que vous proposez si nous
acceptions cette question préalable
c'est de nous priver des nombreux débats
qui auront lieu je n'en doute pas
surtout à votre initiative parce que je
sais que vous avez déposé beaucoup
d'amendements donc donc ce serait
vraiment nous priver de de moments
enrichissant pour les uns et les autres
d'après ce que j'ai compris parce qu'il
y a des ponctions supplémentaires de
proposer en tout cas c'est un avis
défavorable de la commission
merci merci Madame la rapporteur
monsieur le ministre pour le
gouvernement monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice le le le vous avez
évoqué vous avez eu des mots très forts
pour évoquer notamment le le mépr pr du
Parlement qui serait celui du du
gouvernement mais je je je suis toujours
surpris quand on évoque le mépris du
Parlement en choisissant les articles de
la Constitution qui conviennent et ceux
qui ne conviennent pas vous présentez
aujourd'hui une motion préalable vos
collègues parlementaires à l'Assemblée
nationale avait pr présenté une motion
de rejet du reste voter aux deux
extrêmes de de de l'hémicycle qui aurait
prévu qui aurait privé d'absolument tout
débat l'assemblée national euh ce si les
deux extrêmes les deux extrêmes ont voté
cette cette motion de rejet les deux
extrêmes de l'hémicycle monsieur le le
sénateur ont voté cette motion de rejet
que que que que vous le vouliez ou non
et cette motion de rejet n'a pas été
adoptée à quelques voix euh vous évoquez
l'article 40 il se trouve ça
fait le vous évoquez l'article mon
minist je trouve que c'est un des
principes de la Constitution mais même
si celui-ci est mis en cause aujourd'hui
évidemment on aura du mal à trouver un
terrain d'entente sur le le le champ
constitutionnel dont on parle au-delà de
ça je voulais faire quatre remarques la
première c'est que ça n'est pas pour
satisfaire aux besoins de Bruxelles que
le Gouvernement présente ce PLFSS moi ma
préoccupation et je pense que certains
orateurs avec exactement le le la la la
préoccupation inverse à la vôtre c'est
que si nous n'arrivons pas à revenir
vers l'équilibre de de l'assurance
maladie en particulier mais de la
sécurité sociale en général nous allons
faire exploser l'idée que l'assurance
sociale l'assurance sociale qui est un
des acquis de 1945 et bien le système le
plus efficace pour prendre en charge la
santé et la vieillesse
l'autonomie de nos concitoyens
aujourd'hui 80 2 % de la dépense
d'assurance maladie est prise en charge
par l'assurance maladie obligatoire plus
14 % par les complémentaires ça n'est
pas pour satisfaire Bruxelles c'est pour
que face à un déficit qui s'accroîrait
chaque année nous n'ayons pas des bons
esprits qui qui mettent en avant le fait
que l'assurance maladie obligatoire
serait moins performante que des
assurances maladies complémentaires qui
aujourd'hui malheureusement ne sont pas
simplement les mutuels maintenir un
système d'assurance sociale viable et
robuste c'est ça l'objectif prioritaire
du gouvernement quand madame la
sénatrice vous évoquez le fait qu'il n'y
a pas de moyens supplémentaires je suis
au regret de vous dire que je je suis en
désaccord voilà juste sur les chiffres
l'ondame de cette année est 8 milliards
de plus plus élevé que l'ondame de l'an
dernier et effectivement nous demandons
à l'hôpital et je vous en donne acte un
effort sur les achats de l'ordre de 500
millions d'euros alors que nous
finançons et notamment
je prends juste l'exemple des dernières
mesures annoncées sur le travail de nuit
ou le travail le samedi et le dimanche
qui sont des mesures qui coûtent plus
d'un milliard d'euros et que nous
finançons sur l'ONDAM et donc oui le le
l'hôpital et ses et ses soignants ont
connu les augmentations de rémunération
les plus importantes depuis 30 ans qui
font qu'aujourd'hui du reste elles sont
revenu au niveau de de la rémunération
dans le privé je parle notamment des
professionnels paraméd et des praticiens
hospitaliers je ne parle pas évidemment
de certaines activités qui sont beaucoup
plus lucratives dans dans dans
l'activité libérale et oui vous avez
raison mais ce TR mais ce travail nous
l'avons engagé c'est le sujet de la
qualité de vie des perspectives
professionnel mais aujourd'hui les
mesures que nous avons prises notamment
en terme d'attractivité nous permettent
de rouvrir des lits rouvrir des lits ça
veut dire permettre les remplacements
permettre les remplacements ça veut dire
permettre les départs en formation
permettre les départs en formation ça
veut veut dire évoluer
professionnellement et pour moi tout ça
ça s'appelle le progrès vous avez on a
sans doute un désaccord très profond euh
et je je je je je il faut le le formuler
tel quel vous avez évoqué euh les
exonérations les exonérations de charges
que vous chiffrez à 87 milliards d'euros
euh aujourd'hui le système de sécurité
sociale en France il est euh viable
parce que nous sommes à 7 % de de
chômage et nous étions très loin de cela
il y a quelques années nous avons une
partie d'entre nous vécu pendant des
dizaines d'années dans une idée de
chômage de masse d'ailleurs on n'a pas
fini de se rendre compte à quel point ça
change y compris le rapport au travail
et la meilleure le meilleur moyen de
garantir un système de sécurité sociale
tel qu'il est solidaire et qui repose
sur le le la contribution des salariés
et des employeur c'est le plein emploi
et c'est le plein emploi qui est la la
ligne que le gouvernement ne cesse de
tenir ligne sur laquelle en quelques
décisions on peut tout faire s'effondrer
euh et oui nous tenons la la nous tenons
sur cette ligne même si et le ministre
des des comptes l'a évoqué il y a des
mesures en recette notamment sur le
fameux bandeau famille qui qui rapporte
aujourd'hui qui vont rapporter 600
millions de plus que ce c'était l'an
dernier moi j'ai nous avons j'ai pour ma
part grandi dans cette idée que le
chômage de masse était irréversible
serions-nous à deux points de chômage de
moins que nous n'aurions aucun déficit
aujourd'hui de la sécurité sociale sur
aucune des branches enfin vous vous
associez responsabilisation à
culpabilisation et stigmatisation je
vais vous le dire Madame La la la
sénatrice aujourd'hui quand un médecin
prescrit quatre fois plus de d'arrêt
d'arrêt de travail que qu'un de ses
confrères à patientelle égal je ne
considère pas qu'il est fautif je
considère par contre que l'assurance
maladie elle est en droit d'aller voir
et d'aller lui demander et d'aller
comprendre pourquoi il en est ainsi mais
de la même manière madame la sénatrice
les j'ai demandé à l'Assurance Maladie
de repérer les 200 les repérer les
entreprises dans lesquelles les les
arrêts maladies explosent c'est 200
entreprises qui ont été repérées et nous
allons avoir ce dialogue pour comprendre
aussi donc il y a pas de stigmatisation
sur les médecins ou les assurés sociaux
ou les entreprises c'est une
responsabilisation c'est une
responsabilisation collective mais moi
il ne me semble pas choquant que
l'assurance maladie euh aille voir ce
qui se passe et je suis étonné de ce que
vous dites sur notamment la prescription
en des des arrêts par téléconsultation
puisque le texte si vous l'avez lu dans
son entier et je n'en doute pas prévoit
bien que ça c'est cette limitation à tro
jour ne s'applique pas si on a pas de
médecin traitant enfin si on a oui c'est
ça ne s'applique pas si on a pas de
médecin traitant a si on a pu apporter
la preuve qu'on n pas réussi à trouver
de médecin mais par contre effectivement
il y a un business qui se développe en
matière de téléconsultation je pense que
ce business il faut qu'on soit capable
de le gérer donc Madame madame la la
sénatrice ce budget n'est pas n'est pas
un budget insincère on aura l'occasion
je pense tout à l'heure dans la réponse
globale le ministre des comptes aura
l'occasion d'y revenir beaucoup des
prévisions de croissance nous étent
promises comme étant totalement
insincère dans le même débat dans les
mêmes termes l'an dernier et se sont
pourtant révélés les bonnes il faut
aussi quelquefois pour qu'un système
fonctionne lui faire confiance je vous
remercie et donc je donne l'avis
évidemment défavorable à cette
motion merci Monsieur le Ministre y
a-t-il des explications de
vote madame madame
sui monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre pénurie médicaments
revalorisation salariale des
professionnels de santé désers médicaux
ces dangers nécessitent d'investir
dumement dans la santé des Françaises et
des Français ce texte n'entame pas le
virage écique écologique pourtant
nécessaire en matière de prévention et
d'adaptation au changement climatique et
ne garantit pas un financement
soutenable à long terme de la sécurité
sociale l'heure aurait été un
investissement massif pour notre
sécurité sociale ce n'est pas le cas
c'est pourquoi le groupe écologiste
solidarité territoire votera cette
motion merci beaucoup merci madame la
sénatrice y y a-t-il d'autres
explications de vote il ne peut y en
avoir qu'une seule par groupe c'est
ainsi il n'y en a pas d'autres je vais
maintenant consulter le Sénat sur la
motion tendante à opposer la question
préalable avec un double avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement je rappelle que l'adoption
de cette motion entraînerait le rejet du
texte en discussion en application de
l'article 59 du règlement le scrutin
public ordinaire et de droit le scrutin
sera ouvert dans quelques
instants le scrutin est
ouvert pas demander istance de nos
huissiers qui sont là pour vous aider si
vous le
souhaitez personne ne demande à voter il
y a
encore plus personne ne demande à
voter le RDPI n'a pas encore voté
c'est fait le scrutin est clos
alors
votant
342 exprimé
278 pour 35 contre
243 la motion n'est pas
adoptée dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Madame Anne
Souiri pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire et ce pour 7
minutes
monsieur le Président madames et
messieurs les ministres madame la
rapporteur générale Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs monsieur le
président de commission mes chers
collègues assurer à toutes et à tous et
les citoyennes les moyens d'existence
dans tous les cas où ils sont incapables
de se les procurer voilà l'objectif de
la Sécurité sociale énoncé par le
Conseil National de la Résistance cette
protection majeure est plus large encore
dans le préambule de la Constitution de
1946 cette dernière garantissant à tous
notamment à l'enfant à la mère et au
vieux travailleurs la protection de la
santé notre sécurité sociale s'est
construite à l'ône de ce fronton
républicain aujourd'hui nous voyons ce
dispositif un des plus protecteurs du
monde se fissurer il suffit de regarder
pour cela les pronostiqu établies par le
gouvernement lui-même des déficites
attendus de notre assurance maladie
d'ici 2027 face à ces chiffres bien
entendu il faudrait un grand
bouleversement parce que vous et moi
messieurs et madame la ministre je sais
que nous souhaitons le sauvetage de ce
formidable outil du droit fondamental
qui est notre santé il il y a bien des
avancées en terme de prévention je pense
aux campagnes de vaccination HPV de la
santé scolaire en terme de financement
aussi avec un meilleur combat contre la
financiarisation de notre système de
santé notamment avec une remise en cause
la cert mais c'est un premier pas de la
tarification à l'acte de l'hôpital mais
la logique reste la même avec qui plus
est une inadéquation majeure entre
l'augmentation de l' d'â et l'inflation
cela signifie une véritable mise en
danger des établissements de santé de
ville mais aussi de notre hôpital et
lorsque les services publics ou
associatifs en secteur 1 voient leur
budget diminuer les plus précaire
d'entre nous de plus en plus nombreux
n'ont d'autre choix que de se tourner
vers les dispositifs publics d'aide
sociale et sanitaire autant dire que
nous sommes inquiets chacun sait que
l'hôpital public ne tient que par
l'engagement remarquable des soignantes
et des soignant que nous propose le
gouvernement à vrai dire messieurs les
ministres une non trajectoire des
dépenses réalistes et soutena et ce
n'est pas la fraude individuelle
monsieur kaznav qui sauvera notre
solidarité ce n'est pas la lutte contre
la fraude individuelle pardon monsieur
kaznav qui sauvera évidemment notre
solidarité vos propositions sont des
ches misère je ne peux qu'insister
l'ondame 2024 qui évolue de 3,2 % par
rapport à l'objectif rectifié 2023 ne
prend pas en compte l'inflation située
entre 4 et 5 %. il manquerait à ce PLFSS
plus d'un milliard d'euros pour financer
les établissements de santé et 400
millions d'euros pour financer
intégralement les mesures de
revalorisation du segéure de la santé il
y a quelques semaines dans ce même
hémicycle avant la triste loi
immigration nous débattions de la
démocratie sanitaire sur notre sur nos
territoirees j'ai salué l'attitude
d'ouverture du gouvernement lors de ce
débat mais quel dommage qu'elle n''est
pas été au rendez-vous pour l'examen de
ce PLFSS rejeté par les organisations
syndicales et critiqué par les grandes
structures
associatives non mais suis-je surprise
ce PLFSS n'entame aucun virage majeur
pour faire face aux transformations
planétaires et pour renouveler notre
sécurité sociale vers le mieuxdant rien
ne pourra avoir lieu en terme de
transition écologique et de justice
sociale sans investissement majeur vous
le savez monsieur casaznav mais vous
regardez ailleurs et pour pourant il me
semble bien que nous vivons dans la même
planète sur la même planète décidément
et pourtant vous auriez pu faire le
choix de l'action et relever le défi
pour améliorer la santé dans notre pays
pour retrouver les jours heureux et
faire face au défis contemporains il été
possible d'aligner à nouveau nos liens
de dépendance en matière de santé et nos
conditions d'existence dans ce système
de sécurité sociale autrement dit de
proposer avec nous que lesons ble de nos
maladies des pollutions du changement
climatique deviennent les contributeurs
de la transformation de la sécurité
sociale pour paraphraser une chanson
bien entendue lors des manifestations
contre la réforme des retraites oui nous
devons mieux répartir les richesse oui
nous devons trouver de nouvelles
recettes mais pour cela il faut cesser
de faire payer les plus pauvres qui
rappelons-le sont les moins
bénéficiaaires de nos droits sociaux et
permettre enfin l'équité taxons les
dividendes les super profits les
sociétés pétrolières et oui tax son ceux
et celles qui polluent le plus et qui
profite le plus des crises non pas parce
que nous voulons les sanctionner mais
parce qu'une démocratie digne de ce nom
implique qu'il et elle doivent
participer réparer préparer notre avenir
à tous et toutes à la mesure de moyens
qu'il et elles ont à leur disposition
nous y sommes mettons enfin à
contribution les plus riches et les
grands poluire pour respecter notre
égalité républicaine à laquelle j'ose
espérer nous aspirons tous et toutes
heureusement quelques maigres certaines
certes mais existantes mesures de santé
maille ce projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale
euh la gratuité des
préservatifs des contraceptivs des
protections périodiques une campagne de
vaccination dans les établissements
scolaires au papiobérus bravo mais là
encore monsieur Rousseau pourquoi
restreindre ces deux premiers points au
moins de 26 ans et ne pas assumer un
objectif vaccinal au-delà des
établissements publics je suis sûre que
vous saurez m'entendre au moins sur ces
points-là vous connaissance sensible aux
inégalités femmes hommes et à la grande
précarité si nous disons mieux vaut tard
que jamais nous disons aussi pe mieux
faire c'est dans un esprit démocratique
de responsabilité et de dialogue que le
groupe écologist solidarité et
territoire a proposé d'améliorer ses
dispositifs je regrette que trop de nos
amendement en ce sens est été jugé
irrecevable au titre de l'article 40 de
la Constitution et j'appelle le
gouvernement à s'en emparer en
particulier nous proposons d'améliorer
l'information autour du vaccin HPV de
rendre gratuit les contraceptif et les
protections périodiques pour les plus
précaires en dehors des critères d'âge
pareil ailleurs le projet de loi
s'attache à préciser des modalités de
rendez-vous de prévention annoncé
l'année dernière nous vous proposerons
d'affiner ces dispositif et d'y intégrer
clairement la santé environnementale
d'une part les besoins de santé des plus
précaires et plus loin du soin pour des
raisons de discrimination comme les des
minorités de genre d'orientation
sexuelle des travailleuses et
travailleurs du sexe d'autre part
ensuite la lutte contre les addictions
manque à ce PLFSS il nous faut revenir à
la loi et interdire la publicité pour
l'alcool vous le savez tous et tout ici
l'alcool tue plus de 100 personnes par
jour en
France pour aider nos enfants ne pas
sombrés nous devons savoir réguler ah
j'ai j'ai presque fini
ça je
m'arrête en ce sens j'invite le
gouvernement solennellement qui malgré
pardon j'ai j'ai terminé je peux juste
finir une phrase s'il vous plaît allez
finissez votre phrase alle juste euh je
vous remercie après cette séquence de
l'ame de revoir aussi Monsieur le
Ministre messieur le ministre si des
mesures que nous proposons pour les plus
précaair et notamment les les personnes
qui sont les bénéficiaires de laame de
pouvoir réintégrer le dispositif merci
merci chers collègues alors je vous
invite les uns et les autres à essayer
de rester dans l'espace temporel qu'il
vous est donné et a signé madame Céline
Brulin maintenant pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste
canaki monsieur le Président madames
messieurs les ministres mesdames
Messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues notre hôpital est en urgence
absolue et la moitié de nos épades
publiques en déficit la médecine de
ville continue de reculer dans nos
territoires et les indicateurs de santé
de la France se dégradent cette
situation devrait conduire à élaborer
une stratégie nationale de santé une loi
de programmation un grand effort de
formation de revalorisation des métiers
de l'accompagnement et de la santé
priorité de nos concitoyens loin de cela
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2024 poursuit les
précédents avec la réduction des
dépenses comme cap comme si ce qui n'a
pas fonctionné hier devait
miraculeusement résoudre les problèmes
demain quand la Commission des comptes
de la Sécurité sociale estime à 4 %
l'évolution des dépenses de santé ce
PLFSS ne prévoit que 3,2 %. quand pour
répondre au besoins et sans rattrapage
du retard accumulé l'ONDAM devrait
augmenter de 9 milliards et demi d'euros
il évolue de 8 milliards avec une
inflation estimée par la Banque de
France à 2,6 % la progression réelle des
dépenses de santé risque donc d'être
quasi nulle selon la Fédération
hospitalière de France il manque 2
milliards d'euros en 2023 et 2 milliards
à nouveau en 2024 pour que les hôpitaux
puissent faire face à l'inflation et à
l'augmentation des coûts de l'énergie en
guise de quoi vous leur infligeer 500
millions d'euros d'économie nous allons
vers la morlante du service public de la
santé déclare le président de la FHF qui
alerte sur le fait que le sure de la
santé la hausse du point d'indice des
fonctionnaires et les mesures
d'attractivité sur le travail de nuit ne
sont pas entièrement compensé
contraignant les hôpitaux à les payer
avec de l'argent qu'ils n'ont pas
pourtant quand selon une étude récente 5
pour 50 % pardon des soignants ne
recommanderaient pas leur métier on voit
bien que les mesures visant à améliorer
l'attractivité de ces professions ne
sont pas derrière nous les jeunes sont
attirés par les études de santé mais
parcours sub brise des volontés et
masque des réalités l'abandon de 30 %
des infirmiers au cours de leur
formation doit nous interroger une autre
étude mené par des équipes de la PHP de
l'incerme estime qu'une nuit passée sur
un brancard augmente de 40 % le risque
de mortalité des patients âgés oui
l'hôpital va mal et obtenir un
rendez-vous chez un généraliste est
devenu un parcours du combattant depuis
la fin du numirus closus nous formerions
15 % de médecins supplémentaires mais
les besoin nécessite d'en former 30 % de
plus cela veut dire des moyens pour nos
universités notamment le développement
des centres de santé constitue un levier
pour lutter contre les déserts médicaux
et leur création devrait être favorisé
les collectivités qui de plus en plus
nombreuses s'orient dans cette voie
mieux soutenu et pourquoi refuser de
rétablir l'obligation de garde pour les
médecins libéraux et de contraindre les
médecins en secteur 2 les les
établissements privés à participer
davantage à la permanence des soins un
bon tiers des Français est confronté à
des pénuries de médicaments les
préconisations formulées par la
commission d'enquête porté par nos
collègues Laurence Cohen et Sonia de la
provoté devrait être prise en compte
mais vous préférez réduire la
contribution de l'industrie
pharmaceutique à l'Assurance Maladie y
compris pour les industriels qui
délocalisent leur production l'urgenence
et pourtant à retrouver des capacités
publiques de production de médicaments
essentiels qui sont aujourd'hui en
rupture de stock vous stigmatisez les
malades en autorisant des médecins payés
par les employeurs à contrôl et
sanctionné en refusant d'analyser avec
discernement les raisons de
l'augmentation des indemnités
journalières si l'objectif du
gouvernement était véritablement de
lutter contre la fraude il s'attaquerait
au 8 milliards d'euros de fraude
patronale avec l'amendement du député
ferci retenu par le gouvernement après
le 493 utilisé à l'Assemblée nationale
vous souhaitez revenir sur les
exonérations de cotisation sur les
salaires supérieurs à 2,5 SMIC
démonstration est faite en effet
qu'elles ne sont plus tenables ni
économiquement ni socialement mais
vouloir les concentrer sur les plus bas
salaires va accroître encore le
tassement des salaires vers le bas au
moment où de plus en plus de nos
concitoyens ne parviennent plus à
joindre les debouts nous proposons de
conditionner ces exonérations à des
contreparties salariales ou d'égalité
professionnell ou environnemental c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'ont exprimé les
organisations syndicales lors de la
récente conférence sociale ces
exonérations non en effet aucun résultat
positif sur l'emploi et les salaires
elles grèvent les dépenses publiques de
près de 90 milliards d'euros je sais que
ce chiffre vous fait sourciller monsieur
le ministre mais c'est dans l'annexe 4
de votre PLFSS c'est incroyable
d'ailleurs l'énergie que certains
mettent ici à vouloir conditionner par
exemple le RSA à l'AG à
l'accomplissement d'heur d'activité et à
refus usé de solliciter la moindre
compartie contrepartie de la part des
entreprises ce PLFSS devrait aussi être
l'occasion à défaut d'une noi grand âge
d'initier les recrutements massifs dont
ont besoin les éepad pour parvenir à un
encadrement d'un personnel pour un
résident on en est loin on est même loin
des annonces présidentielles de 50000
recrutements d'ici la fin du quinquena
3000 l'an passé 6000 cette année à ce
rythme nous ne sommes même pas sûrs de
les atteindre en 2030 s'agissant de la
branche famille le gouvernement prévoit
d'utiliser les excédents réalisés par
les différentes réductions de
prestations familiales pour financer la
création du service public de la petite
enfance nous pensons que les entreprises
doivent contribuer au financement d'un
tel service et que l'État ne doit pas
une nouvelle fois faire porter l'effort
sur les seules collectivités
territoriales nous aurons l'occasion de
revenir sur la branche ATMP et le coup
de Jarnac imaginer à l'encontre des
victimes d'accidents du travail maladies
professionnell enfin concernant la
branche vieillesse la réforme des
retraites était censée garantir
l'équilibre du système les résultats
financiers pour 2024 montrent en réalité
une aggravation du déficit de 4
milliards d'euros cette réforme est donc
inefficace je crois me souvenir que nous
l'avions dit et les prétendues mesures
d'accompagnement comme la pension à 1200
€ minimum se transforme en une
revalorisation de 30 € mensuel en
moyenne pour les plus faibles Ret
ce PLFSS est finalement à l'image de
cette réforme des retraites demandez
encore et encore des efforts à nos
concitoyens avec la vaine promesse
d'améliorer les comptes publics pour
constater qu'il n'en est rien et
redemander de nouveaux efforts faut-il
vraiment s'entêter dans cette voie qui
ressemble de plus en plus à une impasse
souhaitons que les débats qui s'ouvre
aujourd'hui permettent de montrer que
d'autres logiques peuvent être
développées pour assurer la protection
sociale du 21e siècle que notre que nos
concitoyens sont en droit d'attendre je
vous remercie merci madame la sénatrice
la parole est maintenant à Madame
Guilain Pantel pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et
indépendants je me suis trompé je vous
prie group Rassemblement démocratique et
social européen veuillez m'excuser
chers
collègues monsieur le
Président madames messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président de la
commission des affaires sociales
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
chers
collègues au nom du groupe RDSE j'ai
tout d'abord à remercier monsieur le
Président de la Commission et Mesdames
et Messieurs les rapporteurs en effet
tous nous ont permis d'entamer ces débat
dans la clarté et la tâche n'était pas
simple pour introduire mon propos dans
le cadre de cette discussion générale
sur le projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2024 il me
paraît primordial de rappeler le
contexte politique et social que l'on
observe autour de l'examen de ce texte
en effet le PLFSS pour 2024 est à
appréhender à l'Ô de crise importantes
qui se cumule cette année encore je
crains que ce texte ne soit
véritablement examiné et débattu que par
le Sénat ce qui démontre une fois de
plus tout l'intérêt du travail de notre
haute assemblée quand certains remettent
en cause remettent encore en cause le
bicamérisme par ailleurs nous constatons
des tensions toujours vives au cœur même
du système de santé et de protection
sociale en effet les professionnels des
hôpitaux publics déplorent encore des
situations critiques entraînant des
fermetures de services qui ont un impact
négatif
conséquent sur les usagers côté médecine
libérale le mécontentement est palpable
au sujet des négociations tarifairire
avec l'assurance
maladie aussi à la fin septembre les
discussions du gouvernement avec les
partenaires sociaux au sujet des 68
milliards d'euros de réserve de la
retraite complémentaire à gerérarco
n'ont pas rassurer les syndicats ni le
patronat qui gère ce régime
paritairement or l'apaisement devrait
devait être de rigueur après un début
d'année particulièrement agité autour de
la loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour 2023 portant
réforme des
retraites parallèlement à cela les
difficultés de recrute et de
fidélisation des personnels dans les
établissements sociaux et
médicau-sociaux entame la motivation des
équipes qui gèent des tâches d'exécution
ou de
direction à ce sujet les inéquités de
traitement notamment salariales entre
les corps de métier du public et du
privé sont souvent mis en
cause enfin nous pouvons également
évoquer comme élément de contexte les
diverses enquêtes journalistique au
sujet des dérives autour de la
financiarisation des services essentiels
de la petite enhase au grand âge en
somme un système lucratif basé sur le
profit qui sacrifie souvent
l'accompagnement qualitatif de nos
enfants et de nos
aînés ainsi les défis ne manquent pas
pour 2024 et cela implique notamment un
budget de la sécurité social qui soit à
la hauteur sans pour autant aggraver le
déficit indicateur fondamental de la
soutenabilité du
système or comme l'ont justement évoqué
les différents rapporteurs dans les
prévisions
le déficit des régimes obligatoires de
base de sécurité sociale et du fond de
solidarité
vieillesse pardon repartirait à la
hausse passant de 8 milliards 8 d'euros
en 2023 à 11,2 milliards d'euros en 2024
le groupe RDSE étant profondément
attaché à la pensée etant inspiré la
création du système de sécurité sociale
en France sur le modèle bismarkien en
2000 pardon en 1945 nous nous associons
aux inquiétudes de nos nos collègues
relativ à la trajectoire financière des
régimes dans cet esprit nous regrettons
le manque de réflexion relative à une
réforme structurelle de la sécurité
sociale de même que la faiblesse des
pistes visant à stabiliser les
recettes en revanche au-delà de
l'équilibre financier de la sécurité
sociale sur le sur lequel beaucoup
d'éléments pertinents ont été abordés en
commission notre groupe salue sur le
fond quelques grandes avancées pour la
qualité de vie des Français nous sommes
notamment très satisfaits du volet sur
la prévention qui ériige des politiques
publiques permettant de maintenir nos
concitoyens en bonne santé en leur
donnant les moyens de s'informer et de
suivre leur santé de même que des outils
visant à améliorer leur hygiène de vie
nous pensons à la gratuité des
préservatifs pour les moins de 26 ans
population touché par les infections
sexuellement transmissibles et les
grossesses non désirées ainsi que
l'article 19 qui acte la prise en charge
des protection réutilisable pour les
femmes de moins de 26 ans et les
bénéficiaires de la complémentaire santé
solidaire le lancement de la campagne
nationale de vaccination contre les
papillon virus humains dès la dès la
classe de 5e est également une bonne
mesure un tiers des jeunes hommes de
plus de 15 ans sont porteurs d'un
papillon virirus dans le monde et
environ 20 % sont atteints d'un type HPV
suscep type d'engendrer un cancer il y a
donc urgence à agir et cet article 17
est naturellement le
bienvenu en outre nous saluons le
premier pas sur la réforme de la de la
tarification de l'activité T2A des
hôpitaux pour ce qui concerne les
des activités de médecine de chirurgie
et d'obstétrique il était temps car nous
percevions depuis trop longtemps déjà
les limites de ce mode de financement
l'hôpital a plus que jamais besoin d'un
filet de sécurité budgétaire
diversifié pour se faire nous devons
absolument plafonner la part de la
T2A le temps étant compté je ne
m'éterniserai pas plus bien qu'il me
reste quelques minutes bien qu'il y ait
beaucoup d'à dire sur des sujets
sous-explorés tels que le grand agege
avec une trajectoire démographique de la
France qui soulève de nombreuses
questions pour conclure vous l'aurez
compris nous aurons donc l'occasion mes
collègues du groupe RDSE et moi-même de
défendre nos amendements et de nous
prononcer sur les propositions de nos
collègues au cours des prochains jours
qui s'annonc qui s'annonce riche en
débat je vous remercie merci madame la
sénatrice la parole est maintenant à
Madame song NAD pour ce coupci le groupe
du Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
à vous madame la sénatrice pour 4
minutes
merci monsieur le Président madames et
messieurs les ministres Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteur mes chers
collègues nous nous retrouvons cette
semaine pour un temps fort de notre
année de travaux ex am du budget de la
Sécurité sociale pour
2024 cette année encore notre système de
santé a connu des difficultés et a dû
faire face à un contexte inflationniste
ayant entraîné une augmentation des
coûts de fonctionnement l'enjeu pour le
gouvernement était clair ne pas laisser
cette hausse des couts mettre en péril
les établissements de santé tout en en
permettant au personnel soignant de
gagner dignement leur vie avec risque de
voir s'évaporer les avancées du Ségur du
fait d'une augmentation du coût de la
vie s'ajoute à cela la nécessaire marche
en avant pour la modernisation du
système de santé et la meilleure prise
en charge des patients comme si la liste
des contraintes n'était pas déjà assez
complexe il vous faut bien sûr ne pas
laisser filer les déficites et trouver
des économies dans les différentes
branches dans ce jeu d'équilibriste vous
parvenez à dégager plusieurs avancées
pour nos concitoyens et l'objectif
national de dépenses de l'assurance
maladie pour 2024 en témoigne 3,2 % soit
une haosse supérieure à l'inflation et
un montant de 8 milliards d'euros de de
dépenses
supplémentaires dans le même temps vous
prévoyez 3 milliards 5 d'euros
d'économie en axant votre politique sur
une maîtrise des dépenses de soins de
ville et une responsabilisation de
l'ensemble des acteurs plusieurs mesures
dans le domaine de la santé sont à
saluer tout d'abord un réel renforcement
de la prévention souvent par en pauves
des politiques de santé est amorcée avec
la généralisation de la vaccination
contre les infection à papillon virus
prise en charge intégrale des
protections périodiques et des
préservatifs pour les moins de 26 ans
réorganisation des rendez-vous
prévention aux âges clés cette action
est nécessaire pour amorcer un
changement culturel dans notre pays la
prévention permet une meilleure prise en
charge plus préc C des pathologies pour
un coût plus faible pour l'assurance
maladie la politique c'est prévoir à
long terme et par ce BIA vous engagez un
pas décisif pour la santé de nos
concitoyens pour les prochaines années
de plus nous nous dottons de nouveaux
moyens pour assurer la continuité de
l'accès des patients aux médicaments
dans un contexte de pénurie en 2023 37 %
des Français ont déclaré être touchés
par cette problématique
face à l'augmentation de la demande
mondiale et des tension sur la chaîne
d'approvisionnement nous devons agir
pour ce faire nous soutenons votre
proposition de pouvoir délivrer à
l'unité les antibiotiques en rupture de
stock en lien avec les pharmaciens qui
auront la charge de préparer les
ordonnances mais pour éviter que la
solution de l'urgence se transforme en
principe il faudra dans le même temps
continuer votre travail de
relocalisation de la production sur le
territoire national c'est un véritable
enjeu de souveraineté et une obligation
morale vis-à-vis de la protection de nos
concitoyens sans vouloir être exoctive
dans les mesures que contiennent ce
texte je voudrais enfin mettre en avant
votre proposition d'étendre
l'attribution simplifiée de la
complément complémentaire santé
solidaire pardon la C2S à un certain
nombre de bénéficiaires de minimas
sociaux dont l'allocation adules
handicapé cette simplification est à
saluer car elle réduira le nbreours et
permettra à ces publics un meilleur
accès aux soins dans le cadre de
l'examen de ce texte le groupe RDPI
portera un certain nombre de points au
débat notamment concernant la lutte
contre l'obésité et l'accès aux produits
sucrés mais également sur la question du
financement des politiques de santé dans
les territoires ultramarins sujet sur
lequel nous sommes prêts à avancer de
manière concertée avec le gouvernement
pour finir je voudrais affirmer que nous
viendrons au soutien de votre
proposition de budget que nous trouvons
responsable et ambitieuse et que nous
soutiendrons les mesures qui iront dans
le sens de meilleur accès aux soins pour
les partient je vous remercie merci
madame la sénatrice la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Bernard jaumier
pour le groupe socialiste écologist
républicain pour 7
minutes
monsieur le Président messieurs les
ministres monsieur le Président de la
Commission madame la rapporteur général
mes chers collègues pour la 7e fois
depuis qu'Emmanuel Macron est à l'illisé
nous nous étudions donc le budget de la
Sécurité sociale présenté par son
gouvernement et pour la 7e fois il est
en déficit et lorsque le chef de l'État
quittera l'Élysée il sera encore en
déficite selon la trajectoire prévue par
le gouvernement et il sera encore plus
en déficit qu'aujourd'hui cette
trajectoire est inédite le gouvernement
n'arrive pas à rétablir les comptes et
de fait il fragilise la sécurité sociale
dans ses fondements puisqu'il projette
l'idée que notre système de sécurité
sociale n'est pas soutenable n'est pas
tenable dans la durée nous avons
beaucoup débattu au printemps de la
première masse financière de ce budget
le système de retraite je ne m'y
attarderai pas ma collègue Monique Lubin
y reviendra qu'en est-il du budget santé
du pays il progresse cette année de 3,2
% soit un peu plus que l'inflation
prévue après une année 2023 marqué par
une progression inférieure à l'inflation
mais cette année cette hausse doit
intégrer de nombreux effets de
revalorisation et ils sont tellement
importants qu'ils vont consommer plus de
90 % de cette hausse et qu'il ne restera
quasiment rien pour la progression de
l'inflation nécessités diverses et
variées de d'amélioration du
fonctionnement de notre système de santé
et
donc ce budget s'il était respecté ce
que à peu près personne ne croit et bien
il financerait moins de soins en 2024
qu'en 2023 car le coût de ceci progresse
plus vite que l'enveloppe allouée on
apprend à l'école primaire que si en n +
1 vous avez 12 € alors que en année N
vous avez 10 € pour acheter des tomates
et que le prix du kilo est passé de 5 à
7 € bah vous achetez moins de tomates en
année N + 1 c'est ce qui arrive avec
votre budget vous tracez donc le même
sillon que depuis des années celui de la
contrainte de l'offre pour comprimer la
la dépense c'est une politique qui a
démontré son inefficacité depuis des
années c'est une politique qui crée de
la désespérance chez les personnels du
soin elle induit chez eux le sentiment
qu'il ne peuvent remplir leur mission
dans de bonnees condition et ils s'en
vont nous manquons de médecins
généralistes nous manquons de
professionnels à l'hôpital c'est une
pénurie qui se met en place et la
surcharge de travail chez ce qui reste
accroit de nouveaux départs et une
nouvelle pénurie l'inefficacité elle se
liit d'abord dans les résultats que
demande-t-on un système de santé si ce
n'est de faire progresser l'état de
santé de sa population or nos grands
indicateurs de santé se dégradent après
la mortalité infantile qui progresse
lentement mais sûrement depuis quelques
années et nous relègue à un niveau moyen
au regard des autres pays c'est autour
de l'espérance de vie à la naissance
longtemps une des toutes meilleures au
monde de flancher nous passons de la 6e
à la 13e place des pays de l'OCDE alors
des résultats de santé publique qui se
dégradent des déficits qui se creusent
tout ceci dans la durée que faut-il de
plus pour comprendre que quelque chose
ne fonctionne pas et que l'heure est un
véritable
changement si si vous étiez tenté
messieur les ministres par un simple
rétablissement des comptes vous avez
l'embarras du choix réduire ou mettre
fin aux allègements et aux exonération
non compensée annuler tout ou parti du
transfert de la dette covid de l'État à
la cadèe ou décider de nouvelles
recettees mais nous vous appelons de
toute façon à plus d'ambition et
affronter cette réalité c'est que les
dépenses de santé progressent plus vite
que la richesse nationale sous l'effet
de facteurs structurels que nous
connaissons bien et face auquel nous ne
pouvons rien d'autre que de nous adapter
notre pays n'arrive pas à suivre cette
hausse et d'autant moins qu'il gaspie
trop de ressources et qu'il investit
trop peu dans la prévention le budget
santé du pays est ainsi construit à
partir d'une forme de conservatisme
matiné d'une lecture financière qui est
inefficace l'ONDAM certes n'a jamais été
une construction de santé publique mais
il se révèle maintenant en obstacle à
des démarches de santé et si nous
continuons et bien les indicate de santé
continueront à se dégrader les pénuries
se perpétrer changer messieurs les
ministres c'est construire autrement
notre budget c'est délibérer sur nos
objectifs avant de délibérer sur les
moyens c'est de délibérer dans chaque
département des priorités en fonction
des besoins de santé de la population et
c'est ensuite délibéré au Parlement des
objectifs nationaux de santé que nous
nous assignons et c'est ensuite et
ensuite seulement allouer les moyens en
fonction des choix effectués car oui
nous ne disons pas le cont il y aura
toujours des choix à faire changer
messieurs les ministres c'est beaucoup
beaucoup plus de prévention c'est
l'activité physique et l'activité
physique adaptée qui doit se déployer
c'est une lutte énergique contre les
polluants dont certains je pense au
perturbateurs endocriniens compromet
tout progrès de notre espérance de vie
en bonne santé c'est la réduction de la
consommation d'alcool sur laquelle
Brasseur et viticulteurs ont toujours
une objection et le président une
complaisance c'est la lutte contre le
tabagisme désavoué l'an dernier par le
ministre des des comptes publics de
retour du Congrès des buralistes et
c'est la santé mentale c'est
l'alimentation c'est la santé au travail
changer messieurs les ministres c'est
enfin constaté que le mouvement de
financiarisation qui frappe le secteur
de la santé est un danger pour
l'effendement de notre protection
sociale les ressources provenant des
assurés sociaux sont détournés vers la
rémunération d'actionnaires la
rentabilité prend le pas sur la
pertinence des soins conjugué à un mode
de rémunération trop centré sur les
actes la financiarisation invalide toute
politique visant à l'efficience à la
permanence des soins elle s'impose
certes sur un déficit d'investissement
dans de nombreux secteur du soin mais
elle profite en cela de ce type de
budget trop à courte vue il devient
urgent d'en poser les limite Fautre de
voir notre système solidaire régresser
encore alors vous vous l'avez compris
nous estimons que le budget que vous
nous présentez nous maintient dans une
impasse alors que la crise sanitaire qui
a surgi en 2020 est derrière nous la
promesse présidentielle est oubliée rien
ne change alors qu'il faudrait réunir un
large accord politique pour rénover en
profondeur notre protection sociale et
notre système de santé la faiblesse de
votre base politique empêche le
Parlement de remplir pleinement son rôle
les contournements du type CNR ne
règlent rien le résultat est là
votre gouvernement paraît dépassé par
les enjeux de la protection sociale je
vous
remercie merci monsieur le sénateur
maintenant Monsieur Alain Milon pour les
républicains et ce pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur le Président Mesdames
et messieurs les ministres monsieur
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires sociales Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues le PLFSS 2024 est hélas dans
la triste continuité de ses
prédécesseurs il ne contient aucune
réforme majeure et continue de mélanger
les genres loi de financement et loi
d'organisation de la santé c'est
évidemment la meilleure façon
d'entretenir la confusion or nous sommes
parvenus à la croisée des chemins ce
moment précis où en fonction des
décisions prises nous refonderons notre
modèle en adaptant le modernisant ou au
contraire nous continuerons à le
condamner et à le transformer en un
système américanisé via les assureurs
privés la financiarisation de certains
secteurs et l'ubérisation de la santé
aujourd'hui déjà des sociétés étrangères
achète des cliniques des centres de
santé et se finan ainsi avec l'argent de
l'assurance maladie quelle réponse
apportons-nous depuis des années nous
dénonçons le manque d'ambition de vision
prospective et réformatrice des
différents gouvernements leur approche
comptable leur recours à tout un arsenal
de stratagème qui relève davantage de la
fuite en avant que de la prise en
considération des enjeux des
professionnels des patients et de
l'organisation du système de protection
sociale au travers notamment son
financement je pourrais aujourd'hui au
mot près à la virgule près tenir les
mêmes propos que l'an passé pourquoi ne
pas avoir eu la volonté dès ce PLFSS de
refonder la gouvernance de la santé en
proposant notamment par exemple une loi
de programmation sanitaire pour la durée
du mandat présidentiel pourquoi ne pas
donner ne serait-ce qu'un signe de votre
volonté d'avoir une stratégie de santé
fondée sur l'évaluation territoriale des
besoins de santé et d'objectifs
territoriax de santé pourquoi ne pas
marquer votre volonté de mettre en place
une vraie démocratie locale et sanitaire
au centre du fonctionnement de l'hôpital
et rééquilibrer le management entre la
médecine et l'administration et
développer une gouvernance autonome
pourquoi ne pas permettre la mise en
place des patients experts pourquoi ne
pas assurer aux professionnels libéraux
qu'il soi garant des missions
territoriales de santé pourquoi ne pas
reproposer une restructuration de la
permanence des soins ambulatoires afin
de garantir la pertinence des urgences
hospitalières pourquoi ne pas réviser
les ordonnances de Bray pour permettre
une meilleure ancrage territorial des
hôpitaux le fait de soulever les mêmes
interrogations et de n'avoir pas
davantage de réponse n'est pas de bonne
augure or le temps nous est compté il y
a urgence vous me permettrez d'insister
particulièrement sur le financement
objet de ce texte condition cineéquanon
pour dégager de réelles marges de
manœuvre financière tout en améliorant
notablement la performance de notre
système de santé aujourd'hui la
multiplicité des intervenants entraîne
une hausse des frais de gestion
exponentielle et son évolution démontre
l'ampleur des économies réalisables
grâce à une réforme du financement nous
devons sérieusement non seulement
réfléchir mais mettre en œuvre le plus
rapidement possible un mode de
financement par un assureur unique par
prestation de santé des économies
substantielles seraient ainsi réalisé
qui pourrai être réinjecté au profit
d'une optimisation de l'ensemble de
notre système de santé de ses
bénéficiaires de ses acteurs de ses
financeurs elle permettrait de
développer une vraie politique de
prévention tout en garantissant la
pérenité
de notre système excusez-moi fondé sur
la
solidarité vous enciendrait avec moi
aujourd'hui ce principe est battu en
brèche et les inégalités sont plus
nombreuses et plus flagrantes
vouloir se dépêcher tout s
Reille vous aurez quelques secondes de
plus je vous en prie
j'apprécie
la privatisation accrue de notre système
et le développement des réseaux
participe à une transformation
insidieuse voire
pernicieuse de l'accès au soins un
système à deux vitesses n'est plus un
spectre mais une réalité chaque jour
plus marqué enfin comment ne pas évoquer
la situation des hôpitaux j'aborde ici
le volet financement dont le volet
tarification à l'activité plus connu
sous le terme T2A est souvent stigmatisé
et pourtant dans un récent rapport
la Cour des comptes a rappelé la volonté
du Président de la République puis du
ministre chargé de la santé en janvier
2023 de réformer le financement des
établissement de santé la tarification à
l'activité a été présentée comme
condamnée même s'il est envisagé d'en
conserver une part une fois ce rappel
fait la cour analyse le rôle joué par la
T2A dans la maîtrise d'écoutes d'une
part dans l'amélioration de
l'organisation des soins et le pilatage
des établissements de santé d'autre part
force de constater que que les objectifs
qui lui étaient assignés en terme
d'équité et de transparence des
financements demeurent indispensables et
ont été réalisé bien sûr le système est
perfectible et doit être amélioré
notamment pour les soins non
programmables et pour les soins
critiques mais gardons-nous de retomber
dans les travers que provoque un système
axé essentiellement sur les dotations ce
pfss monsieur le ministre propose peu de
mesures de rénovation les déficits se
creuent se creusent combien de temps
encore allons-nous tout mettre en œuvre
pour conduire notre système de santé
dans le mur nous ne pouvons accepter
plus longemps d'être mes chers collègues
les faussoilleurs de notre pacte
social merci merci monsieur le sénateur
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur
Christopher Zurek pour les
nonincrits
monsieur le Président mesames et
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
Président de la Commission des Affaires
social Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs abîmé par la crise sanitaire
par des décennies de mauvais choix la
sécurité sociale et notre système de
santé auparavant fierté nationale et
réputé parmi les meilleurs au monde ne
sont plus que l'ombre deux même notre
hôpital public et nos urgences sont en
ruine avec une dégradation des
conditions d'accueil et de prise en
charge des patients en dépit du
dévouement de nos soignants à
l'épuisement des professionnel de santé
et le déficit d'évocation se conjugue
une baseineinterrompu des capacités
d'accueil dans les hôpitaux chers
collègues la réalité est édifiante
l'espérance de vie recule désormais dans
notre pays la mortalité infantile l'un
des indicateurs attestant le plus de
l'état d'un système social revient à la
hase avec évidemment autant de drames
familiaux enfin il n'est plus un
territoire rural comme urbain qui ne
connaissent pas une dégradation de
l'accès aux soins et 30 % de la
population française vit désormais dans
un désert médical après ce sombre
constat les solutions portées par ce
PLFSS paraissent toujours
sous-dimensionné avec un optimisme
gouvernemental qui confine à la
déconnexion des mesures efficace pour
financer notre système de santé il en
existe et le rassemblement national
proposera des amendements pour faire
rentrer et économiser un argent qui
manque cruellement à nos soignants et à
nos hôpitaux à ce sujet nous nous
félicitons de la transposition dans ce
PLFSS de mesures portées par Marine Le
Pen lors de l'élection présidentielle
nous accueillons donc favorablement la
réforme de la T2A qui contraignait
l'hôpital public à salign sur les
méthodes du privé le principe de
délivrance à l'unité des médicaments
nous apparaît également comme une mesure
de santé publique et de santé financière
bienvenue néanmoins malgré ces quelques
lueurs les manquements sont légion le
rassemblement national défendra ainsi la
mise en place d'une réelle politique de
souveraineté pharmaceutique par la
réindustrialisation du secteur et une
politique d'État stratège appuyée sur
les grands groupes pharmaceutiques
tricolore il est également temps de
rationaliser la technostructure de la
santé la suppression des ARS et inutile
et coûteux et plus que jamais délégitimé
par leur gestion catastrophique de la
crise sanitaire est une nécessité pour
redéployer les efforts de l'État et
donner aux médecins et aux soignants un
vrai pouvoir de gestion et d'action au
sein de leurs établissements nos
amendements appuont également la
nécessaire lutte contre la fraude
sociale évalué entre 7 et 21 milliards
d'euros selon les services de
l'Assurance Maladie enfin ce PLFSS est
encore une occasion manqué pour définir
de réelles mesures pour accompagner les
Français dans les défis démographiques
de notre temps ainsi on doit l'absence
d'un réel plan grand âge centré sur les
aidans et sur le maintien à domicile des
personnes en situation de dépendance le
contestable article 30 de votre projet
de loi à ce sujet participera à éloigner
ces personnes du soin par par
l'augmentation des coûts de transport
individualisés les personnes handicapées
seront également lourdement impacté par
cette mesure les contraignants d'autant
plus dans un accès aux soins plus
difficile et plus coûteux pour eux comme
pour leur famille à ce titre les acteurs
de la Conférence nationale du handicap
ont alerté sur le déc persistant entre
les moyens alloués et les besoins des
personnes en situation de handicap chers
collègues les sénateurs rassemblement
national soutiendront toutes les mesures
allant dans le bon sens celui de la
protection sociale la plus étendue pour
les Français et celui du pragmatisme
gestionnaire dans cette chambre il n'y a
pas de 493 alors profitons-en pour
débattre ce dont l'Assemblée nationale a
été privé je vous remercie merci
monsieur le sénateur la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Daniel Chassin
pour le groupe Les
Indépendants
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
Président de la Commission madame le
rapporteur général Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs mes chers collègues le
PDF 2024 prévoit 641 milliards d'euros
de dépens et 630 milliards d'euros de
recettes n dame c'est de 255 plus 50
milliards par rapport à 2019 une
augmentation de 3,2 % 8 milliards par
rapport à 2023 mais malgré cette
augmentation conséquence ça risque
d'être difficile pour les hôpitaux pour
leur budget pour le Médico-Social qui
subissent également de plein fouer
l'inflation l'augmentation des salaires
ou des investissements nécessaires il en
est de même pour moi de la prise en
charge de la dépendance néanmoins ce
texte concerne contient plusieurs
avancées que nous encourageons des
mesures de lutte contre la frotte des
cotisations sociales des vaccinations
contre le papimoloir virus humain la
prise en charge de préservatifs et des
protections périodrique la délivrance
possible par les pharmaciens après
réalisation d'un test pour les cystites
et les engines médicaments une
simplification des démarches pour avoir
la C2S un meilleur repérage pour les
enfants et de meilleures conditions
d'accueil
plus de dépistage le fauteuil pour les
handicapés à 100 % c'est également bien
des bilans de
prévention des mesures de pénurie contre
les médicaments sur ce dernier point
monsieur le ministre il est absolument
fondamental de trouver des solutions
pour relocaliser la fabrication des
médicaments en France et en Europe il y
a 20 ans l'Europe était le premier
producteur et exportateur de médicaments
concernant la dépendance je intervenir
plus
longuement vous avez man t l'intention
de créer 25000 places d'ici 2030 de Siad
en effet le nombre de seigors de 85 ans
va doubler entre 2020 et 2040 et celui
des en perme d'autonomie va passer de
1004 à 2 million si vous prévoyez
effectivement on est d'accord le dommage
le virage domiciliaire c'est dès
maintenant d'ici 2027 qu'il faut essayer
de créer ces 25000 places de CAD et de
résidence autonomie dans les épades vous
prévoyez une diminution du taux
d'institututionnalisation des personnes
dépendantes de 40 à 37 %. cela va
entraîner une augmentation très
importante de la dépendance avec un GMP
qui va être entre 750 et
800 nous avons voté la loi du 7 août
2020 créant une 5è branche de la
sécurité sociale qui indique que la
perte d'autonomie est un risque assuré
par la nation à chacun le pnfss 2022 et
2023 on cré avec 200 et 300 millions
d'euros euh sur 2 ans 1, 10000 10000
emplois mais c'est 1, emplois par EPAD
puisqu'il y en a 7500 madame monsieur le
ministre en 2025-2026 les annonces du
président de la République devrait à mon
sens être appliqué je comprends les
difficultés budgétaires 50000 emplois
sur le quinquena avec 10000 déjà créé
dès 2024 et il est nécessaire d'en créer
20000 en 2025 et 20000 en 2026 ou sur 3
ans c'est le minimum indispensable qui
permettra d'offrir en moyenne CIN
emplois supplémentaire par épad pour
augmenter de 15 minutes le temps passé
auprès de chaque résident j'ai compté
nous devons avoir cette ambition comme
le propose l'article 37 il est aussi
nécessaire que les sections des budgets
soins déépendan des épades soient pour
moi fusionner l'article ne le propose
que sur une base de volontariat cela
pourra entraîner des disparités entre
les départements et n'est pas pour moi
dans l'esprit de la loi il est
nécessaire parallèlement que les
départements ne rétrocèd pas
l'intégralité de ce qu'ils perçoivent au
titre des Gires 5 et 6 à la C CNSA il
faut les leur donner les moyens pour
renforcer le maintien à domicile j'avais
déposé un amendement euh pour ne pas
obliger comme prévu la fusion entre les
siades et les saades afin de tenir
compte de ce qui fonctionne bien dans
les territoires il faut être pragmatique
pour ce qui concerne l'hôpital la
diminution de la tarification l'activité
T2A la sécurisation de l'Établissement
français du sang l'augmentation des
primes de nuit et de dimanche également
en épade ainsi que les gardes des
médecins vont tout à fait dans le bon
sens la création de servicees de
médecine polyvalente en aval des
urgences est demandé pour les les
désengorger ça me semble également
monsieur le ministre être une nécessité
tout comme bien sûr la renégociation
avec les les professionnels et
l'augmentation du personnel médical et
paramédical je signale également les
problèmes avec 250 pharmacies qui
ferment par an en rural j'avais souhaité
également un amendement d'appel pour un
renforcement de soins piatif dans chaque
département afin de pouvoir mieux
prendre en charge les malades en famille
en épad à domicile je regrette qu'il a
été déclaré restable de même que
concernant la 4e année d'intern euh cet
amendement permettant les les 6 derniers
mois qui puissent être effectués avec
seulement un médecin référent parce
qu'il y a pas des médecins maîes de
stage partout est recevable aussi de
même que la pharmacienne d'officine qui
pourrait être pharmacien référent en
éepad également est recevable
ou mon amendement au lit de
pédopsychiatrie dans tous les
départements dont le manque représente
une difficulté majeure pour les centres
départementaux de l'enfance qui se
trouve à gérer des Sit situation
extrêmement difficile avec des enfants
présentant des troubles du comportement
enfin la branche
vieillesse le retour à l'âge de départ à
64 ans va permettre une évolution vers
un équilibre dans les années 2032 comme
le Sénat l'avait proposé il est
important d'adapter ce texte avec les
partenaires sociaux pour tenir compte
des carrières longues de la pénibilité
ou encore de la maternité et la
revalisation des petites pensions et
agir effectivement contre la frone en
conclusion la sécurité sociale
représente la colonne vertébrale de
notre République et ce pfss propose des
avancées indéiables que nous avons
souligné le rééquilibrage du budget par
une meilleure maîtrise des dépenses et
plus d'emplois cotisant avec des
entreprises compétitives comme vous
l'avez dit Monsieur le Ministre 5 %
comme en Allemagne de chômage il n'y
aurait plus de déficit et bien cela doit
rester un objectif
afin de ne pas mettre en péril notre
système de protection sociale je vous
remcie
merci monsieur le sénateur la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Jean-Marie
vanberg
vanenberg de l'Union
centriste
collègue monsieur le président madamees
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur général
messieurs mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs et mes chers collègu en
exerg de mon propos je voudrais citer
deux chiffres 509 milliards 647
milliards ce sont les dépenses réalisées
en 2019 et celles qui sont prévues en
2024 pour les régimes obligatoires de
sécurité sociale soit 130 milliards de
dépenses supplémentaires en 5 ans
durant ces années de crise sanitaire
nous avons en effet déployé des moyens
inédits pour protéger les Français qu'il
s'agisse de leur pouvoir d'achat ou
surtout de leur santé quoi qu'il en
coûte mais cette politique a belelle et
bien un cou que je viens de rappeler
brutalement or notre responsabilité est
d'assurer la pérénité de notre modèle
social c'est ce que vous avez dit
Monsieur le Ministre et vous avez raison
l'examen de ce PLFSS me laisse néanmoins
perplexe celui-ci traduit certes un
effort d'amélioration des rémunérations
des personnels de santé en établissement
ou en ville il renforce aussi les
effectifs des épades et de l'aide à
domicile que nous saluons ainsi que
votre volonté de mettre fin au tout DEA
à l'hôpital et de lutter contre les
pénuries de médicaments
ce PLFSS amorce également un virage
encore peut-être timide en faveur de la
prévention ma collègue juseline guidz
analysera commentera plus précisément
toutes l'ensemble de ces mesures qui
sont nécessaires mais n'efface pas nos
doutes quant à la soutenabilité à long
terme du système je m'attacherai donc à
vous proposer des solutions à hauteur
des déficit récurrents des branches
maladie et vieillesse plus ambitieuses
donc que celle qui figure dans ce projet
de loi prenons le cas de l'Assurance
Maladie vous comptez bien économiser 3
milliards et demi notamment sur les
médicaments et produits de santé les
soins dentaires la biologie et même les
indemnités journalières qui ont fort
progressé nous sommes favorables à
revenir aussi sur certaines exonérations
de cotisation pour les salaires compris
entre 2 et demi et 3 et demi du
SMIC mais le le pilotage des comptes
sociaux ne serait se limiter à augmenter
ou réduire les dépenses alors vous
faites de la lutte contre la fraude
sociale et je m'en réjouis un chantier
prioritaire nous vous approuvons sur ce
point mais néanmoins les objectifs me
paraissent
insuffisant ainsi pour l'assurance
maladie la fraude se situe entre 5 et 10
milliards selon les estimation
d'ailleurs toujours incomplète de
laacnam et que nous attendons
impatiemment avec 500 millions détectés
nous sommes là aussi très loin du compte
en matière de cotisation et de
contribution la cour des compte l'estime
entre 6 à 8 milliards votre objectif
c'est d'atteindre 5 milliards d'ici
2027 quant aux fraudes aux prestations
familiales et vieillesses les clichés
ont la vie dure mais rappelons qu'elles
ont les mieux connus et aussi les mieux
combatus mais la la vigilance reste de
mise car euh les fraudes aux méthodes
les fraudeurs plutôt aux méthodes de
plus en plus sophistiquées profitent
souvent de nos outils lacunaires
Nathalie Goulet l'a souvent démontré la
lutte contre la fraude sociale ne
l'oublions pas est aussi un puissant
levier de réduction de ces déficits sur
le même thème difficile de ne pas
évoquer
l'indispensable travail à poursuivre sur
la pertinence des
soins là aussi pas de chasse aux
sorcières mais un chiffre l'OCDE évalue
à 20 % soit 50 milliards le montant des
dépenses d'assurance maladie pour des
actes inutiles et
redondants ces actes nous en bénéficions
en tant que
patient souvent en radiologie ou en
biologie mais il n'en constitue pas
moins des pratiques abusives voire
inutile et surtout délétaire pour les
comptes
sociaux la contrainte et la fermeté ne
semble pas caractériser cette la
démarche de votre Gouvernement sur ce
point les guides de bonnes pratique ne
suffiront pas sauf à s'appuyer
réellement sur le DMP qu'il faut
généraliser sans
tarder un mot également pour la sur la
trésorerie de la cosse qui sans
transfert vers la cadesse de ces
déficits cumulés se trouv en tension
extrême la cadesse ne pouvant recevoir
que 8 milliards de dates
supplémentairire il faut revoir son
plafond et le calendrier de
remboursement alors abordons maintenant
la branche vieillesse vous avez tenté de
récupérer un milliard à laagir Carco au
titre de la réforme je pense que la
méthode n'était pas bonne je vous
suggère plutôt de négocier avec les
partenaires sociaux un swap d'un montant
à déterminer entre les cotisations
employeurs de la complémentaire et les
cotisation knaave de ces mêmes
employeurs et pourquoi pas ne confier
d'ailleurs au partenair sociaux
excellent gestionnaire d'une agir Carco
au 68 milliards de réserves la
gouvernance et la gestion de la cave
c'est-à-dire un retour aux sources en
fait en quelque sorte avant de conclure
je voudrais vous alerter alerter madame
la ministre sur la 5e branche la
trajectoire financière est bonne nous
sommes à mi-chemin avec le transfert de
015 points de CSG de la cadesse vers
celle-ci mais la quasittalité des
éepades et tous les SAD des Siad sont
vous le savez au bord du gouffre alors
le fond de 100 millions est insuffisant
il en faut au moins 5 à 10 fois plus et
immédiatement madame la ministre pour
conclure last but list une
proposition je voudrais à l'instar du
professeur bizarre et de quelquesuns de
mes collègues dont Alain Bilon vous
proposer de mettre fin au double étage
assuranciel en passant à un assureur
unique par prestation de santé ou pour
l'ensemble des prestations il s'agit là
de basculer monsieur le ministre dans un
un modèle vertueux de maîtrise des
dépenses de santé réinjectant plusieurs
milliards d'euros dans les caisses
permettant ainsi d'améliorer la santé
des Français au fond assurer la mission
essentielle de la sécurité sociale je
vous
remercie merci monsieur le sénateur
vanberg maintenant Monsieur
Xavier Vell pour le groupe du
Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et
indépendants pour 4
minutes monsieur le Président madames et
messieurs les ministres Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues ce PLFSS est un texte de
responsabilité si l'on considère les
engagements pris en matière de
prévention et en santé et d'accès aux
soins comme l'a rappelé ma collègue
Solange nadil en effet pour 2024 le
choix de l'efficience a été fait et ce
budget apporte des réponses concrètes
pour consolider notre système de santé
tout en assurant un équilibre financier
pérenne comme les précédents ce budget
2024 prévoit également des moyens
importants en terme de solidarité et
notamment en terme de soutien à notre
politique familiale l'objectif de
dépenses de la branche famille est ainsi
fixé à 58 milliards d'euros en hausse de
2,7 milliards d'euros par rapport à 2023
ces moyens significatifs doivent nous
permettre de financer les mesures et les
travaux engagés au cours des dernières
années je pense au chantier des 1000
premiers jours de l'enfant à
l'allongement du congé paternité à la
réforme du complément de mode de garde
au le soutien aux familles
monoparentales ou encore la
revalorisation de laallocation de
soutien familial ainsi les moyens
alloués à la politique familiale
augmenteront en 2024 notamment pour
lancer le chantier du service public de
la petite enfance auquel 6 milliards
d'euros seront consacrés jusqu'en 2027
et qui visent à garantir à tous à tous
les parents l'accès à une solution
d'accueil sûre de qualité
géographiquement proche et
financièrement accessible pour son
enfant que ce soit en crèche ou auprès
d'une assistante
familiale l'objectif est donc à la fois
de revaloriser les professionnel de la
petite enfance mais aussi de soutenir
l'investissement dans les crèches
d'assurer leur fonctionnement et
d'engager la dynamique d'ouverture des
200000 solutions d'accueil manquantes
tout en accueil tant en accueil pardon
collectif qu'individuel je citerai
également la réforme du congé familial
qui nous est particulièrement qui nous
tient particulièrement à cœur Madame la
Ministre ce sont autant d'avancées dont
nous sommes fiers de soutenir au côté du
gouvernement nous saluons aussi la
traduction dans le PLFSS des engagement
pris en matière de handicap en
particulier ceux annoncés par le
Président de la République lors de la
dernière conférence nationale du
handicap et du déploiement des 50000
solutions d'accompagnement je pense
notamment aux enfants en situation de
handicap placé à l'aide sociale l'
enfance afin de leur garantir une prise
en charge adaptée les 10000 adultes
aujourd'hui maintenus dans les
établissements pour enfants grâce à
l'amendement Creton doivent pouvoir en
sortir c'est une question de dignité et
d'autonomie c'est pourquoi nous devrons
trouver des solutions avec les
départements afin de respecter la
volonté des adultes en situation de
handicap et de leur famille et permettre
de libérer près de 15 % des places
existantes dans les IME enfin notre
groupe portera un certain nombre
d'amendements pour nos concitoyens et
pour nos territoires je pense en
particulier à nos compatrimotes
ultramarins que nous souhaitons soutenir
par un véritable politique de famille et
de soutien à la parentalité la forte
prévalence de familles monoparentales
dans les territoires ultramarins en
situation de précarité doit donc nous
interpeller collectivement je pense
aussi aux pensions de reversion et nous
porterons de la possibilité au couples
paxé d'y accéder et plus largement nous
souhaitons lancer une réflexion afin de
prendre en compte la diversité des
unions dans notre pays la question de la
reversion des pensions également pour
les adultes orphelins et handicapés est
tout aussi importante pour leur
autonomie une fois leurs parents disparu
nous défendrons donc des amendements en
ce sens enfin pour lutter contre le
surpoids et l'obésité et les maladies
associés notamment chez les enfants nous
porterons un certain nombre
d'amendements contre les produits
transformés issus de l'industrie
agroalimentaire mais aussi pour limiter
le taux de sucre qui empoisonne nos
enfants en créant des dépenses
supplémentaires pour l'assurance maladie
par la suite le groupe RDPI soutiendra
pleinement les mesures de d'orientation
de ce budget et auquel le débat
parlementaire apportera son lot d'avancé
positif pour nos compatriotes un sujet
et un budget sérieux qui répond au
double objectif de réduction du déficit
et de protection des Français un budget
ambitieux qui apporte des réponses
concrètes aux familles et aux personnes
en situation de handicap enfin un budget
de justice sociale qui finance des
progrès nouveaux et fait le choix de
renforcer le volet prévention de notre
système de santé je vous remercie merci
monsieur le sénateur la parole est
maintenant à Madame Corine Ferret pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain monsieur le Président
madames et messieurs les ministres
monsieur le Président de la Commission
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues
je souhaite aujourd'hui être le
porte-voix des élus des maires en
premier chef qui partout pas seulement
dans mon département le Calvados tire la
sonnette d'alarme et vous exhorte à agir
madamees et messieurs les ministres pour
sauver leur épad il demande comme nous
en vain PLFSS après PLFSS des
financements pérennes à hauteur des
besoins et le vote d'une loin grand âge
annoncé depuis 2018 est sans ce repoussé
ce n'est certainement pas la proposition
de loi porteur mesure pour bâtir la
société du Bien vieillir en France qui
permettra de faire face à l'ensemble des
conséquences de vie du vieillissement de
nos concitoyens aux questions liées à la
perte d'autonomie à la dépendance au
manque d'attractivité aussi des métiers
du secteur social et médico-social c'est
un véritable enjeu de société un défi
que nous devons relever dès aujourd'hui
à peine dès demain quand allez-vous
prendre la mesure du constat d'urgence
que font les épades et les services
d'aide et d' accompagnement à domicile
partout en France comprenez-vous que
l'annonce cet été d'un soutien de 100
millions d'euros pour soulager les
structure est en totale déconnexion avec
la réalité des besoins les Français
aspirent légitimement à bien vieillir
chez eux et pour se faire le
gouvernement dit déployer un virage
domiciliaire la réalité nous la
connaissons tous ici des associations
d'aide à domicile qui sont en souffrance
contraintte de refuser des prises en
charge par manque de personnel aussi
durant la dernière sa dernière campagne
présidentielle Emmanuel Macron avait
fait la promesse de créer 50000 postes
supplémentaires en épagne en 5 ans alors
que la Fédération hospitalière de France
estimait les besoins à au moins 100000
le PLFSS de l'an dernier au lieu de
créer 10000 postes comme on pouvait
légitimement s'y attendre n'en avait
budgeté que 3000 cette année vous n'en
prévoyez que 6000 ce qui n'est
certainement pas de nature améliorer les
conditions d'accompagnement de nos aînés
et puis nouveau rebond issement la
première ministre ne parle plus de 2027
mais de 50000 postes à échéance 2030
repousser cette promesse présidentielle
n'est pas sérieux et c'est une anème
preuve si besoin était que l'engagement
de l'engagement pardon insuffisant de ce
gouvernement sur le grand âge que de
temps perdu depuis 2020 est la création
officielle de la 5e branche relative à
l'autonomie de la sécurité sociale vous
aurez beau dire que cette prche est
excédentaire personne n'est DUP de la de
la situation et d'urgence à agir déjà en
2019 année de remise du rapport Libau il
était préconisé d'augmenter l'effort en
faveur du grand âge de 9 milliards par
an on en est loin s'agissant maintenant
de la branche accident du travail
maladie professionnelle je dirais
simplement que les choses ne peuvent pas
bien se passer quand vous encouragez
l'ubirisation du travail la
sous-protection sociale et les
sous-revenus associés quand vous
repoussez à 60 44 ans l'âge de départ à
la retraite de travailleurs usés qui
aspire légitimement au repos et quand
vous refusez de réintégrer les quatre
critères de pénibilité que vous avez
supprimé les seules mesures que prévoit
votre budget visent à traquer les arrêts
de maladiie traite traiter les malades
comme des fraudeurs et les médecins
comme des complices c'est dire je
conclurai par la branche famille en
rappelant que les chiffres sur la
natalité publiés par l'INC en septembre
dernier sont alarmants seul à renforce
significatif des moyens allués à la
politique familiale pourra permettre
d'inverser la dynamique déclinante de la
démographie française l'ouverture d'au
moins 200000 places en crèche est
toujours nécessaire alors que des
milliers de foyers voient leur désir de
parentalité menacé par le manque de
solution de garde en somme ce budget de
la Sécurité sociale n'est pas à la
hauteur des enjeux et des décisions que
nous devrions prendre sans sans attendre
davantage répondre aux besoins des
assurés sociaux des patients des ayants
droit voilà ce qui manque cruellement
dans ce
PLFSS merci madame la sénatrice la
parole est maintenant à Madame Florence
la sarad pour le groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains monsieur le Président
madamees messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues adopté par 493 à
l'Assemblée nationale le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
2024 prévoit plus de 640 milliards
d'euros de
dépenses soit une hausse de 30 milliards
d'euros par rapport à 2023 ça donne le
vertige il fixe un objectif national des
dépenses de l'assurance maladie à 254,9
milliard d'euros soit une hausse de 3,2
% par rapport à l'ONDAM 2023 alors que
l'inflation est à près de 5 %. cette
trajectoire peu crédible et une
couverture lacunaire du contexte
inflationniste on compte cond la
commission des affaires sociales à
rejeter l'ondame 2024 il est regrettable
de constater que ce texte abandonne tout
objectif de retour à l'équilibre des
régimes obligatoires de base et à une
stabilisation du déficit avec un Onam à
plus de 250 milliards d'euros les
Français sont en droit d'attendre un
système de santé plus performant la
hausse des dépenses en
2024 concernera essentiellement le
secteur hospitalier et pourtant l'ONDAM
ne permettra pas de répondre à la crise
de l'hôpital public ni à celle des
épades autre constat un N d'AM de plus
de 250 milliards d'euros ne suffit pas à
enrayer la dégradation de certains
indicateurs de santé ainsi la mortalité
infantile progresse en France depuis une
dizaine d'années alors qu'elle continue
de diminuer en Europe le taux de
mortalité infantile devrait être une
priorité du gouvernement un certain
nombre de solutions ont été mises en
place dans les pays d'Europe du Nord
notamment une augmentation des effectifs
dans les
maternités lors de votre audition par la
commission des affaires sociales vous
avez parlé de virage structurel de la
prévention seulement ce virage
structurel on ne le voit pas
transparaître dans le PLFSS je salue
néanmoins quelques mesures prévues dans
le domaine de la prévention t que le
lancement d'une campagne de vaccination
contre le papyoma virus la gratuité des
préservatifs pour les assurés de moins
de 26 ans mais il n'a rien il n'y a rien
de véritablement structurel pour
reprendre votre terme monsieur le
ministre le comptez pas ce PLFSS est
très insuffisant il manque une véritable
ambition d'autre part je suis réservé
quant à l'intégration de certains
dispositifs de contrôle prévus par ce
PLFSS qui pourrait s'avérer pénalisant
pour les malades de cancer du cancer par
exemple concernant la fraude l'article
27 du PLFSS vise à réguler les dépenses
d'indemnité journalière maladie
je souhaite attirer votre attention sur
deux difficultés quant à l'application
de cette mesure tout d'abord les
médecins libéraux considèrent que la
suspension automatique des indemnités
journalières après contreevisite médical
des médecins contrôleurs est une remise
en cause de leurs compétences de
prescription d'autre part avec le
dispositif que vous proposez comment
pourra-t-on protéger les personnes
atteintes de cancer en les préservant
d'une potentielle instrumentalisation de
cette procédure par
l'employeur de même l'article le 28
propose de limiter à 3 jours la durée
des arrêts de travail prescrits en
téléconsultation c'est une mesure
bienvenue contenue des abus avérés
toutefois ce dispositif risque de
creuser les inégalités pour les
personnes atteintes d' cancer dans les
zones sous-dotées en médecin généraliste
comment imposer un déplacement à une
personne en plein traitement danst les
effets secondaires peuvent être sévères
nous proposeront des amendements pour
corriger ces injustices enfin les
médecins libéraux ne se retrouvent pas
dans le PLFSS sans eux pourtant comment
envisager le virage ambulatoire et le
virage
domiciliaire the last but not the list
est-ce que les économies prévues
permettront enfin d'envisager une hausse
du prix de la
consultation le vieillissement de la
population la prise en charge des
maladies chroniques les progrès de la
médecine et la mise en place du virage
structurel de la prévention que vous
appelez de vos vœux nécessite des
réformes ambitieuses
et une plus grande rigueur ce PLFSS qui
se fonde sur des prévisions économiques
particulièrement optimistes a été
largement revu et corrigé par la
commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat nous allons débattre et dans le
cadre de nos prérogatives qui restent
limité améliorer ce PLFSS je vous
remercie de votre attention merci madame
la sénatrice la parole est maintenant à
Madame j GUID pour l'Union
centriste pour 6 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
messieurs les ministres madame la
rapporteur générale mes chers collègues
ce projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2024 qui nous est
soumis à l'examen repose sur des
préscisions qui manqu cruellement
d'ambition en matière de stabilisation
du déficit après l'amélioration
résultant de la fin de la crise
sanitaire la forte inflation de 2023
susciterait une forte revalorisation des
dépenses nous sommes qu'au début d'une
période d'aggravation du déficite cette
trajectoire financière inquiétante reste
un sujet préoccupant pour l'avenir et
les futures générations comme vous le
savez bien chers collègue un
hypothétique redressement de cette
situation ne serait pas concevable sans
des décisions difficiles en matière de
recettees comme de dépenses prendre des
décisions importantes fait peur
cependant on pourrait regretter de ne
pas l'avoir fait attendre fait mal oubli
fait mal mais ne pas savoir quelle
décision prendre est la pire des
souffrances affirmé polo Coello nous
tenons ainsi à saluer le choix des mesur
d'économie budgétaire et de régulation
des dépenses enrichies sensiblement par
la commission l'incitation au transport
sanitaire partager si l'état de santé
des patients le permet ou encore le
contrôle des prestations des arrêts de
travail ainsi la durée d'un arrêt de
travail prescrit ou renouvelé par
téléconsultation est limité à 3 jours
cette mesure est bienvenue contenue des
abus avéré le groupe Union centriste
propose aussi un amendement visant à
mieux encadrer les plateformes de
téléconsultation cette année encore le
pfss n'apporte pas de réponse appropriée
au défi du système de santé les mesures
relatives à la politique de santé nous
semblent d'une portée très limité ainsi
au-delà de quelques dispositions
relatives au médicaments ou à la
prévention le texte prétend porter une
réforme de financement de l'hôpital qui
n'est finalement qu'un trompeleœil et
retouche à la marge l'organisation des
soins il est toutefois indispensable que
les hôpitaux puissent s'engager
sereinement dans une réforme
structurelle avec une ligne claire et
des ressources sécurisé pouréquilibrer
les modes de financement c'est pourquoi
la Commission a prévu un report de cette
réforme au 1er janvier 2028 au terme
d'une expérimentation préalable
permettant d'affiner le modèle cible et
ainsi améliorer effectivement l'offre de
soins nous sommes favorables à la
délivrance gratuite en pharmacie de
préservatif pour les moins de 26 ans
sans sans prescription médicale il
s'agit d'une avancée certaine en matière
de prévention des infections
sexuellement transmissible et de
grossesse non désirée cependant on peut
regretter que par l'article 40
l'amendement du groupe Union centriste a
été considéré comme irrecevable alors
qu'il visait l'élargissement de ce
dispositif aux personnes handicapées la
sexualité fait partie intégrante de
projet de vie et constitue un droit
fondamental de la personne en situation
de handicap ce qui lui permet d'avoir
des liens sociaux d'estime de soi et
d'affectivité en outre le remboursement
intégral des fauteuils roulant des 2024
est d'une portée incertaine puisque les
conditions d'application de cette mesure
sont suspendues aux négociations à venir
j'ai été un peu interpellé par les
associations à ce sujet le texte
comprend aussi une disposition visant à
lutter contre le harcèlement scolaire
les professionnels de santé des
établissements scolaires sont désormais
autorisés à orienter des élèves vers les
psychologues du dispositif mon soutien
PSI concernant la branche au vieillesse
la réforme des retraites a permis de
réduire d'un tiers son déficit à
l'horizon de 2027 cependant elle ne
suffit pas à redresser sa trajectoire
financière on estime que la dégradation
serait rapide à compter de 2024 avec un
déficit provisionnel de l'ordre de 11
milliards d'euros en 2027 cette
situation nécessiterait des efforts
supplémentaire difficilement acceptable
par les Français face à cette réalité
indéniable nous som nous saluons des
mesures de bon sens visant à assurer la
justice et l'équité du système de
retraite ainsi le contrôle biométrique
de l'existence des retraités résidant à
l'étranger deviendrait obligatoire à
compter de 2027 cette décision serait
nécessaire pour lutter contre la fraude
aux pensions de retraite à l'étranger en
l'absence de politique familiale forte
et ambitieuse nous regrettons vivement
que le solde le solde excédentaire de
cette branche soit ainsi consommée sans
que les réformes nécessaires ne soient
mises en œuvre le contexte de chute
inquiétant de la natalité rend
nécessaire une prise de conscience
collective s'agissant de la branche
autonomie le pfss semble marqué un
tournant en matière de financement des
épades en
orçant la fusion des sections soins et
dépendan ce régime pérenne qui donne
naissance à la nouvelle section soins et
entretien de l'autonomie serait
toutefois optionnel pour les
départements ce qui pourrait aggraver
les disparité territorial par conséquent
nous soutenons une proposition de
commission qui consiste à se transformer
le régime adapté de financement en une
expérimentation d'une durée de 3 ans à
laquelle pourrai participer 10
départements il nous semble aussi
nécessaire de clarifier des relations
financières entre la Caisse nationale de
solidarité pour l'autonomie et les
départements afin d'en améliorer la
lisibilité et la transparence force de
constater que les moyens ne sont pas au
rendez-vous pour le virage domiciliaire
et que la situation financières des
éepades reste alarmante les raisons en
sont multiples des problèmes structurels
de gouvernance de recrutement la hausse
des prix et des et des rémunération s'il
est bienvenu le fond d'urgence de 100
millions d'euros prévu par l'article 3
n'est malheureusement pas à la hauteur
des besoins dans le contexte de
vieillissement de la de la population
enfin nous sommes heureux de la création
d'un service de repérage de diagnostic
et d'accompagnement précoce il s'agit
d'une avancée majeure pour les enfants
de moins de 6 ans présentant un handicap
et en part particulier un trouple du
neurodéveloppement si nous saluons cette
mesure de prévention nous nous
interrogeons sur l'articulation de ce
service avec les les outils déjà
déployés à savoir les PCO ou le le
forfait d'intervention précoce à ce jour
nous n'avons d'ailleurs pas obtenu de
réponse à nos interrogations sur les
situations préoccupantes des adultes le
moindre effort consiste à inscrire dans
la loi la limite d'âge de 12 ans nous
apprécions aussi le renouvellement de la
durée des droits de l'allocation
journalière du prochédent dans la limite
d'un an pour des cas de figurees précis
et proposant un amendement visant à
pérenis des mesures en faveur du répit
des aidants le groupe Union centriste
soutiendra ce texte à condition qu'il
soit amélioré par les amendements
proposés par le Sénat je vous remercie
de votre attention merci madame la
sénatrice la parole est désormais à
Madame Monique Lubin pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
pour 3
minutes merci euh madame la ministre
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
Président pardon monsieur le Président
de la Commission Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs ce que contient le
présent projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2024 sur la
question des retraites ne laisse pas de
m'interpeller le gouvernement y fait la
démonstration que sa politique en la
matière relève d'une navigation à vue
tout d'abord nous sommes préoccupés par
la volonté de l'exécutif de voir la
caisse nation d'assurance vieillesse
devenir comptable de son propre
équilibre après avoir absorbé les
déficits des régimes spéciaux la
question de la pérennité de la prise en
charge par l'État des compensations
relatives au régimes spéciaux se pose
semble-t-il l'article 9 du présent
projet de loi dispose de fait que le
régime général se substitue à l'état
dans le rôle d'équilibreur en dernier
ressort des régimes fermés une clé de
TVA serait prévu afin de compenser le
coût de cette prise en charge et serait
calculé à partir des crédits actuel de
la mission régimes sociaux et de
retraite il nous semble à nous que cela
décide un avenir de la knaf
particulièrement flou nous sommes par
ailleurs comme d'autres totalement
opposés à la volonté de l'État de puiser
dans les réserves de laagir cararco
cette dernière a constitué ses réserve
par sa bonne gestion dans le cadre d'un
paritarisme rigoureux cela a exigé des
efforts sensibles de la part de ses
bénéficiaires et ne saurait être
sanctionné par une ponction décidée
unilatéralement par le gouvernement
concernant les résultats des régimes de
retraite énoncés dans ce PLFSS et sur
lesquels j'aurai l'occasion de revenir
lorsque nous étudierons l'article àoc je
souhaite tout d'abord faire un rappel
peut-être évident mais néanmoins utile
le PLFSS par essence n'englobe pas les
chiffres des retraites complémentaires
je le précise au cas où certains
seraient tentés de procéder à des
comparaison hasardeuse on continue à
lancer à la figure des citoyens des
milliards qui finissent par ne plus
avoir beaucoup de sens à des échéances
variables 2027 2030 à regarder ces
chiffres de prês les régimes
obligatoires de base afficheraient des
déficits autour de 14 à 17 milliards
d'euros en 2027 et la réforme aurait
fait économiser 7 milliards d'euros à
2027 dans 4 ans j'ai envie de vous dire
il resterait donc encore 14 milliards
d'euros de déficit ou 17 hein ça dépend
enfin je vais pas faire les calculs ici
je précise toujours sans les excédents
des caisses complémentaires nous serions
donc très loin des équilibres annoncés
par la réforme pourquoi une fois pour
toutes ne pas plutôt décider de la part
du PIB que nous consacrerions aux
retraites afin de rendre le débat plus
clair et d'assumer ainsi les accidents
lorsqu'il y en a ce qui bien évidemment
est facile ou les déficits en tout état
de cause il nous revient donc de nous
accorder sur des étalons de mesures à
même de permettre aux citoyens de de
comprendre et de se positionner dans ce
débat mais aussi de trouver ensemblé
avec les partenaires sociaux les moyens
de permettre à notre système de retraite
de surmonter les conséquences d'une
situation économique ou démographique
dégradée qui pourrait se faire jour la
protection de notre système de retraite
mérite mieux que des réformes poussées
par des intérêts soumis aux aléas de la
politique politicienne et si des efforts
doivent être faits ils ne doivent pas
toujours être portés par les mêmes merci
Madame
le madame sénatrice la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur Calif califé pour
le groupe les républicains et ce pour 5
[Applaudissements]
minutes monsieur le Président madamees
et messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur générale
Mesdames et Messieurs chers collègues
quand on est emprun d'optimisme il est
particulièrement décevant de commencer
un mandat de sénateur et de se retrouver
pour examiner après la chétive PPL
Valtou
mplfss qui a longtemps et qui depuis
longtemps renoncé à sa vocation de 2000
de
96 ce projet de loi de financement de
sécurité sociale pour 2024 est le
premier texte budgétaire qu'il m'est
donné d'examiner et le professeur de
santé ne peut cacher son insatisfaction
face à un texte qui ne provoque pas
encore le déclic qui sortirait nos
professionnels du doute et nos
concitoyens du
désarrois l'exercice n'est pas facile
monsieur le ministre je vous le concède
d'emblé sur l'aspect financier comment
peut-on considérer ce
pflss comme un texte budgétaire alors
qu'il est déjà marqué par l'absence
d'une trajectoire claire et plus
inquiétant encore par un certain flou
dans sa construction et les incertitudes
sur les prévisions de
2027 alors que l'inflation reste forte
et que son impact n'avait pas
suffisamment été prise en compte l'année
dernière le projet 2024 ne couvre pas
non plus les coûts une progression 3,2 %
de londam est apparemment une bonne
chose mais annoncé en même temps 3,7
milliards
d'économie malgré l'annonce les mesures
annoncé laisse un fort doute sur la
sincérité des comptes mais j'espère
monsieur le ministre me tromper en
résumé malgré un énorme budget de 250
milliards d'euros consacrés à la santé
pourquoi ce texte n'apporte-t-il pas la
réponse aux interrogations des usagers
et aux craintes des
professionnels 2è point le projet pour
quel objectif à l'image de la PPL
valtous ce texte souffre d'un manque
cruel d'ambition structurelle et
certaines des dispositions proposées
manquent de pertinence je prends pour
exemple l'article 24 qui qui est
l'intérêt de mettre une régulation
dentaire aux urgences alors qu'on a plus
besoin d'une expertise en psychiatrie
voire même en pédiatrie au-delà de
l'aspect purement financier ce texte
doit tirer les leçons des constat d'hier
et le vécu d'aujourd'hui et d'éviter de
rajouter des couches à un millefeuille
qui est déjà bien épais cette absence
chronique de mesures concrètes contribue
largement au déficit et favorise
aujourd'hui la
financialisation de la médecine ce que
nous déplorons tous mesdames et
messieurs les ministres je caresse
l'espoir comm pour la loi Valtou que des
amendements proposés par le Sénat
puissent être
adoptés en ce qui concerne l'innovation
et la
prospective comme l'exige tout projet
j'ai dit futuriste ce PF PLFSS consacre
quelques mesures utiles telles que le
recours aux expérimentation de l'article
51 mais cela reste insuffisant la
prévention euh malgré tout ce qui a été
proposé et que nous saluons reste le
parent pauvre de la politique de santé
de même quelle est la place de
l'innovation dans ce texte alors même
que le rapport commandé par madame la
Première ministre apparu en août dernier
ce p l FSS ne semble pas en tenir compte
clairement et en particulier pour ce qui
concerne les produits innovants enfin
conna est-il de la réinternalisation de
la production des produits
pharmaceutiques pour conclure mesdames
et messieurs il est notre responsabilité
collective et nous en prendrons notre
part monsieur le monsieur le
ministre de mettre fin à cette fuite en
avant plus que jamais une réforme
structurelle pour une maîtrise
médicalisée et non comptable de nos
dépenses de soins et nécessaire pour
LEED donner confiance aux usagers et aux
professionnels et cela passera par trois
points optimiser et sécuriser le
parcours des patients évaluer les
pratiques professionnelles et la
pertinence des soins et surtout tout
faire pour assurer une diminution des
surcouts lié à la non qualité mesdames
et messieurs les ministres comme tout
professionnel de santé longtemps en
responsabilité j'observais avec beaucoup
d'admiration la construction d'un PFL S
je l'imaginis malgré sa complexité
malgré les interventions extérieures
malgré les lobbyes comme un document
rigoureux un pilote traçant la
trajectoire de notre système de santé
force est de constater que nous sommes
malheureusement loin de cette réalité et
ma déception est à la hauteur de nos
attentes je termine par une note plutôt
d'espoir suite à vos déclarations
respectives de ce soir je suis tenté d'y
croire mais les ma en pratique
nécessitera une volonté sans faille je
vous
remercie merci monsieur le sénateur la
parole est maintenant à madame la
sénatrice marido hashliman pour le
groupe les
[Applaudissements]
républicains monsieur le Président
madames et messieurs les ministres
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires sociales madamees et
monsieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 intervient dans un contexte de
crise multidimensionnelle paroxistique
qui a envahi l'entier périmètre des
comptes sociaux de la France comment ne
pas entendre la détresse des malades le
désarroi de nos soignants comment ne pas
voir la précarité qui fragilise qui
fragmente les familles comment ne pas
sentir les souffrances de nos aînés
isolés démunis ou en perte d'autonomie
face à ces crises les Français exigent
des réponses ils attendent des solutions
or à cet égard il existe à ce stade un
grand écart entre les discours
volontaristes du gouvernement et les
actes budgétaires la branche famille en
fourni un exemple flagrant avec un
projet de budget 2024 quasiment blanc
sans vraiment mesure pour remédier aux
difficultés éprouvées pourtant il y a
urgence la natalité est en baisse
constante depuis 10 ans et 2023 pourrait
être la pire année depuis
1945 avec moins de 700000 naissances
madame la ministre Aurore berger vous
déclariez récemment que la relance de la
natalité est la priorité absolue de
votre ministère vos mots sont forts et
nous avons très envie de vous croire
mais il ne trouve à ce stade aucun écho
dans cette proposition budgétaire qui
enjambre même 2024 pour un grand nombre
de mesures s'agissant de l'offre de
garde le renforcement du service public
de la petite enfance est en gestation il
est prévu de le faire porté par les
communes qui sont déjà asphyxié
financièrement et confronté à la pénurie
de personnel qualifié la réalité
aujourd'hui c'est que les communes
ferment des sections et réduisent
l'amplitude des crèches pour respecter
les taux d'encadrement nous saluons les
assouplissements apportés au complément
de libre choix du mode de garde mais
nous regrettons que les 93 familles
concernées doivent attendre 2026 pour
obtenir le tiers payant qui était déjà
promis dans le budget pour
2019 enfin à l'heure où diverses études
montrent que le désir d'enfant est élevé
le dégrochage de la natalité interpelle
au fond si les Français et les Français
ont moins d'enfants ce n'est pas par pur
choix mais du fait d'une appréhension
légitime de l'avenir et d'une politique
familiale qui échoue à les rassurer et à
les
soutenir la réforme du congé parental
est une autre illustration de l'écart
entre vos discours et vos actes l'heure
n'est plus à un aème rapport comme le
suggère l'article 46 quat dont la
finalité on peut l'imaginer est de
gagner du temps au fond tout est déjà
sur la table c'est pourquoi j'ai déposé
un amendement visant à annuler la
commande de ce rapport il est grand
temps de revenir sur les funestes
réformes de François Hollande qui a
réduit la politique familiale à une
politique sociale il est urgent de
rompre avec cet héritage qui a démantelé
la politique familiale et causé
l'effondrement des naissances en France
alors oui mes chers collègues oui mes
chers collègues ne vous en déplaise
c'est exactement le cas alors alors la
demande de la droite sénatoriale est
claire ayons le courage de Renou madame
à la parole encourage de renouer avec
les recettes qui ont fait le succès de
la natalité française rétablissons au
plus vite l'universalité des allocations
familiales pour toutes les familles et
dès le premier enfant réindexons les
prestations sur l'inflation et dès le
mois de janvier 2024 déplafonnons le
cootient familial laissons aussi aux
familles la liberté de prévoir ce mais
je vous en prie madame laissons aussi
aux familles la liberté de prévoir ce
qui est le plus adapté à leur vie
professionnelle et à leur projet
parental voilà les mesures de soutien
que les familles attendent madame la
ministre j'ai entendu et apprécié votre
intervention lors de la commission des
Affaires social et je sais que au fond
vous partagez toutes ces convictions des
amendements ont été proposé par la
majorité sénatoriale pour que ce budget
ne soit pas un rendez-vous manqué alors
saisissez la main tendue soyez fidèles à
cette belle promesse d'avenir qu la
famille je vous
remercie merci madame la
sénatrice la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Laurent Burgoa pour les groupes
les
[Applaudissements]
républicains
monsieur le Président Madame et
messieurs les ministres monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur générale
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues nous y sommes en
cette fin d'année voilà le temps
d'échanger sur nos différents budgets
pour
2024 ces débats sont toujours très
attendus tant il s'agit là d'une air de
la guerre chacun se présente à nous
parlementaire et à vous membres du
gouvernement avec sa liste de doléan il
s'agit alors de ne jamais perdre de vue
l'intérêt général il en va de la
crédibilité de notre institution en
effet comment pourrionss-nous au moment
des budgets suggérer toujours plus de
dépenses pour tel ou tel secteur et
ensuite durant le reste de l'année
réclamer plus d'économie
oui présenter un budget ce n'est pas
simplement
administré c'est priorisé renoncer
abonder à un mot c'est gouverner il
s'agit alors d'ajuster notre budget à
nos différents besoins ou plutôt à la
curence urgence et plus encore j'en
formule le vœux d'être capable de
retrouver une certaines liberté d'action
car c'est de cela dont nous parlons de
notre capacité à agir à changer le
quotidien des Français et àer protéger
en déplacement dans le gare lors de mon
premier mandat
un début m'avait dit monsieur le
sénateur nous ne manquons pas de tête
nous manquons de bras aujourd'hui je le
constate moi-même des études des
rapports des commissions nous en avons
et de qualité reste à mettre à mesure de
les mettre en œuvre je redoute le jour
où nous où ns discussions seront aussi
caricaturales qu'à l'Assemblée nationale
car à travers nos départements et
indifféremment de nos sensibilités
politiqu nous faisons les mêmes
constats de la même manière que nos
concitoyens réfléchissent parfois à deux
fois avant de se rendre au commissariat
de peur de s'engager dans une procédure
trop longue qui ne les empêchera de
croiser leur agresseur certains
concitoyen réfléchisse à deux fois avant
de prendre un rendez-vous médical qui
ils le savent sera dans les dans des
mois et des mois et souvent à des
kilomètres et des kilomètres de la même
manière que dans certains quartiers de
France des concitoyens passent à mettre
leur enfant dans le privé non pas pour
une quelconque éducation religieuse ni
pour une meilleure prétendue supérieure
mais simplement rendez-vous compte pour
la garantie d'une plus grande sécurité
et bien certains concitoyens ne
seetournent plus vers l'hôpital public
mais s'adressent directement au secteur
privé ou
associatif c'est notre contrat
républicain qui est ainsi
rongé pourtant
la France demeure l'un des pays dans
lesquels les prélèvements obligatoires
sont les plus importants elle sissent
même au sommet du classement en zone
euro alors de grâce ne disons pas que
les Français sont réfractaires à l'impôt
mais plutôt qu'il nous réclame
l'efficacité tant espérée de nos
politiques le personnel médical est à
bout de souffle nous le savons depuis
des années et s'il sont attachés à leur
mission nous devons l'être tout autant
si ce n'est plus lorsqu'on siège à
droite de cet hémicycle et que l'on
invite à réduire le train de vie de
l'État on nous répond parfois comment
vous souhaitez encore moins de lits dans
les hôpitaux moins d'infirmiers mes
chers amis c'est tout l'inverse s'il
nous faut être plus asszu c'est
justement pour avoir plus d'hôpitaux
plus d'infirmiers et mieux rémunérés
pourquoi d'autrre on s'engage toujours
dans la vie politique pour les plus
modestes et les plus fragiles
d'ailleurs et c'est parfois
contreintuitif même pour lutter contre
les fraudes de toutes sortes il nous
faut plus de moyens il y a donc des
réformes structurelles à mener et puis
disons-le il y a sans doute des
économies à faire dans tout un tas de
structures adoc et de comités théodules
si utile qu'il passe sous les radars si
nombreux qui grèvent nos budgets voilà
pour cette vue générale que je tenais à
vous exprimer les débats seront longs et
je fais pleinement confiance avec
l'ensemble de mon groupe à nos
rapporteurs et au présidents de la
commission pour veiller à ce que cet
esprit puisse se traduire tout au long
de nos votes je vous
remercie merci monsieur le sénateur
madame et messieurs les ministres
souhaitent s'exprimer ce que je voudrais
aussi parce que je crois que la
Commission doit se réunir tout à l'heure
c'est que vous soyez relativement concis
et je fais appel à votre esprit de
synthèse que je sais très grand et très
fort pour arriver à à ce que nous pour
pour que nous soyons que nous ayons fini
avant 20h à 20h s'il vous plaît monsieur
le
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs je
commencerai par remercier le sénateur
Burgoa qui dans sa sagesse toute
gardoise a montré la ligne de crête que
nous devons tenir sur la la nécessité de
maîtriser les les dépenses et en même
temps de de d'entend entendre les
besoins et l'engagement pour les plus
fragiles d'entre nous donc monsieur le
Président nous inviter à la concision je
voudrais dire que la peut-être ne
l'avons-nous pas dit suffisamment la
trajectoire de financement que nous
présentons et nous devons à la
représentation nationale de la clarté et
de la transparence sur les perspectives
à moyen terme mais évidemment et
notamment sur le champ de la régulation
de la dépense notamment par le biais de
de de la pertinence des actes et des
différents
c'est euh l'objectif de faire réduire la
dépense de ville et notamment la dépense
de médicaments qui est au cœur de la
négociation conventionnelle qui va se
réouvrir à partir de de demain et même
si 9 milliards sur 255 milliards d'euros
de dépenses ça pourrait faire rêver
quand sur le budget de l'État euh on ne
peut pas euh se dire qu'on finira en fin
de période avec 9 milliards de dépenses
euh d'Assurance Maladie de de déficit
pour pour euh répondre à ce que disait
notamment la sénatrice douanau et la
sénatrice guidz sur je je je dois dire
que je trouve que les les les propos qui
ont été tenus sur la réforme de la
tarification il y a eu les mots trompeur
inabouti trompe l'œil euh du côté enfin
qui ont été évoqués par par les
sénatrices hbert ou guidz là aussi euh
je crois que c'est c'est ça me
semble un peuad victoire avec la
proposition que vous faites de reporter
de de à 2028 oui il faut qu'on se lance
dans cette réforme on parle de la
réforme de la T2A depuis aussi longtemps
qu'on a lancé la T2A nous avons nous
proposons un dispositif cohérent avec
trois brique de tarification c'est une
demande qui revient PLFSS après PLFSS
alors après si nous disions que nous
renvoyons à l'année prochaine je pense
que d'autres que les le sénateur Milon
pourrait dire qu'ils font exactement
qu'il pourrait refaire le même discours
que l'an dernier je pense que nous
devons nous lancer dans cet exercice euh
pour ne pas repousser parce que je vais
enfin en tout cas pour ma part j'ai la
conviction que si on attend d'avoir le
système de tarification parfait qui ne
ferait pas de perdant pas de gagnant qui
serait et cetera qui aurait toutes les
vertus nous attendrons longtemps il faut
se lancer et nous évaluerons et nous
ajusterons euh sur la financiarisation
ce point qui a été souligné je veux
souligner le travail qui a été fait à
l'Assemblée nationale notamment à
l'initiative de Sté périste pour essayer
notamment de faire modifier enfin pour
modifier et lancer la modification de la
tarification et de de du financement de
la radiothérapie et de la dialyse qui
sont deux des secteurs dans lesquels on
sait aujourd'hui que beaucoup d'effets
de la financierisation se fait se font
sentir je
euh je je ne crois pas que les mesures
que nous présentons en terme de
prévention soient cosmétiqu j'avais
entendu les mêmes mots quand le
président de la République a annoncé la
gratuité des préservatifs euh ou la
prise en compte de la précarité
menstruelle quand on voit le volume que
cela représente ça montre que ça répond
à une véritable demande je pense en
outre que le texte évidemment je ne je
ne prétends pas qu'il qu'il que le
virage de la prévention est est pris
définitivement mais je crois quand même
que et notamment depuis quelques mois
tout ce qui est porté par le
gouvernement notamment sur la
vaccination et sur la prévention de de
certaines pathologie montre que ce
virage il est en cours mais et je le dis
là ça c'est une réponse un peu
structurelle et qui à mon avis qui est
un des points les plus importants ce qui
est sûr et je je réponds là notamment à
ce que ce qu'indiiquait Bernard jaumier
ou la sénatrice l sarade c'est que au
fond pour avancer notamment sur ces
indicateurs de santé publique et sur le
financement de la prévention sans doute
que l'ONDAM n'est pas aujourd'hui
l'outil le plus adapté on paye en hondam
23 les vaccins pour protéger du PAP de
de d'infection papillomavirus et de
cancer du col de l'utérus dans 30 ans
peut-être donc oui il y a un chantier à
conduire sur une réforme structurelle si
on veut mener cette ce chantier
structurel de la prévention qui pour moi
est par ailleurs l'explication majeure à
au recul que nous connaissons sur
certains éléments que vous avez cité que
ce soit la mortalité infantile ou
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé c'est
nous avons une but et on peut pas aller
j le tout curatif ne répondra pas à ça
et les inégalités sociales de santé
doivent être prises en compte je
remercie tous les les sénatrices nadie
les pantell qui ont qui ont souligné que
ces mesures de prévention n'étaient pas
n'étaient pas que que qu'accessoir parce
que je pense vraiment qu'elles ne le
sont pas on reviendra sans doute dans
les débats sur les médicaments et les
mesures concrètes qui sont prises et je
je pense que je pourrais illustrer à
cette occasion notamment en réponse à ce
qui a été dit par la sénatrice NAD le le
le fait que les mesures qui sont dans le
PLFSS en disposerait-on aujourd'hui que
ça serait déjà très précieux de pouvoir
de pouvoir utiliser des mesures de
police sanitair dans les mains de la NSM
que nous n'avons pas que nous n'avons
pas aujourd'hui je voudrais dire un mot
au sénateur de la au président au
sénateur de lae sur la la question des
des effets de la crise en une formule a
dit le Ségure et la crise je les met pas
tous les deux sur le même plan
exactement parce que je pense que le
segégur était une condition pour s'en
sortir mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que les effets structurels en santé de
la de la crise du covid ils ne sont pas
derrière nous et je pense notamment un
sujet qui est revenu et qui devra être à
mon avis un des cœurs du pfss25 qui est
la situation en matière de santé mentale
puisqu'on le sent tous dans le pays il y
a quelque chose qui s'est dégradé
massivement depuis euh quelques quelques
quelques années euh le président le
président mouillé mais mais le sénateur
Milon également on et comme la sénatrice
ber sont revenus sur euh la nécessité
d'avoir une une grande loi structurante
sur sur la santé je vous écouter
monsieur le le sénateur Milon et je je
me disais je on a toujours cette ce ce
rêve hein je je je de d'avoir une grande
loi euh euh à son nom moi je
souhaiterais on avance sur les vous en
avez parlé dans la PPL Valtou sur les
cts sur la réorganisation de la
gouvernance à l'hôpital euh le sas le
service d'accès aux soins 85 % de la
population sera couverte en fin d'année
euh les patients en al sans médecin
traitant nous avons cassé la courbe je
je vous rejoins sur les ordonnances de
Bré il y a des chantiers législatifs
sans doute devant nous mais pour ma part
à ce stade je ne suis pas convaincu que
rentrer qu' je l'ai dit je crois dans
ces termes quelquefois on rentre au
Parlement et à forturé l'Assemblée
nationale avec une cathédrale et on
ressort avec une chapelle de montagne ce
qui est ce qui est quelquefois aussi
beau mais pas forcément plus utile euh
je je je l'ai dit déjà mais je je le
redis à au sénateur Chassin nous allons
adapter en fonction des retours tous les
dispositifs d'accompagnement de la
vaccination
HPV je précise que les les la précarité
menstruelle nous avons étendu au
bénéficiaires de la C2S je le redis
santé mentale et santé des femmes seront
deux axes forts euh de euh de du PLFSS
de l'an prochain je crois qu'on est au
milieu du chemin à ce stade je finis en
disant que le je présenterai dans
quelques semaines le le plan national de
lutte contre le tabagisme avec des
annonces qui seront faites notamment sur
les propositions que nous portons en
matière de de prix et qui ne sont pas
neutres enfin la sénatrice brullin a
évoqué c'est mon deuxème enfin je crois
la sénatrice Brulin a évoqué la
réduction des dépenses que nous aurions
comme cap je crois que si nous avions ce
cap nous nous comme ça se ça se verrait
un tout petit peu plus mais je la
rejoins sur deux points un point majeur
sur comprendre ce qui se passe dans la
formation tion dans les ifs et notamment
la perte des des 30 % de de de de
d'infirmières qui commencent ces
formations et qui s'arrêtent en cours et
par ailleurs et c'est là aussi que je
veux dire que à la fois le PLFSS est un
texte ambitieux à la fois il n'est pas
tout vous avez évoqué par exemple la
remise de la garde ou de la permanence
des soins vous avez voté notamment grâce
à la bienveillance de la de la
rapporteur dans la loi Valtou une une
rédaction sur la la permanance de soin
établissement de santé qui qui me semble
être une réponse à ce que vous évoquez
voilà je je désolé de de de d'être à la
fois trop court et trop long C cette
merci monsieur le ministre vous aurez
l'occasion pend monsieur le ministre
vous aurez l'occasion pendant toute la
semaine de discuter à la fois sur les
articles sur les amendements madame la
ministre très rapidement si vous pouvez
merci Monsieur le le président vaessayer
en 3 minutes pour laisser le temps à mon
collègue de vous répondre en 45 secondes
sur atmpag Carco et les retraites alors
d'abord sur les enjeux autonomie oui
vous avez raison à la fois la
proposition loi bien vieillir et la
stratégie qu'on va pouvoir présenter
vendredi elle n'épuise pas le sujet
c'est la question de l'adaptation de
l'ensemble de notre société au
vieillissement qui doit évidemment
irriguer l'ensemble des Chan c'est pour
ça que c'est aussi une stratégie
interministérielle et c'est pour ça je
l'ai dit en commission que moi je suis
favorable à l'idée qu'on puisse
travailler ensemble sur une loi
d'orientation notamment pour poser les
questions qui sont les question de
financement c'est ce que vous avez dit
notamment monsieur le le sénateur sur
les questions de financement il y a
quand même plusieurs élément qui
s'ajoute il y a évidemment un fond
d'urgence et son nom l'indique bien
c'est un fond d'urgence qui n'est pas là
pour répondre aux enjeux qui sont les
enjeux structurel d'un certain nombre de
nos établissements notamment nos éepad
et qui doit pouvoir permettre
d'identifier de cartographier
établissement par établissement pour
savoir ceux qui sont en difficulté
conjoncturell ceux qui sont en
difficulté structurell et pouvoir enfin
proposer un véritable parcours
résidentiel et aujourd'hui on voit bien
qu'on en manque à cela s'ajoute et une
mesure en PLFSS 24 si vous l'adoptez qui
est 150 millions d'euros sur
supplémentaire via la CNSA au
département je crois que c'est une
mesure utile sur le financement
évidemment que nous devons au
département face aux mesures aPA et et
PCH mais nous devons aller plus loin
c'est la question de la fusion des
sections je l'ai dit en effet madame la
rapporteur alors je vois qu'il peut y
avoir évidemment des avis différents sur
le sujet moi je crois beaucoup à la
différenciation et à la capacité donc
d'avoir une expérimentation de manière
encore une fois en faire l'évaluation
avant toute généralisation si
généralisation il devait y avoir moi
j'ai pas posé en préalable l'idée qu'on
généralise alors même encore une fois
qu'on dit au département engagez-vous
dans des mesures qui sont des mesures
d'innovation et soyez des départements
pilotes en la matière c'est la raison
pour laquelle le gouvernement sera bien
favorable euh aux amendements sur les
questions d'expérimentation et réforme
en 2025 de la question des fond de
concours donc première évolution en 24
mais une vraie réforme des fonds de
concours en 25 sur la question des
contrôles j'en dis juste un mot on a
augmenté les effectifs des ARS de 120
personnes 120 ETP de manière à garantir
et ce sera le cas qu'en 2 ans l'
l'intégralité des epads et été contrôlé
plus nous avons ajouté en alfs 23
l'obligation de la comptabilité
analytique ce qui n'existait pas pour
les établissements privés lucratifs je
crois que là aussi ça permet d'avoir
quand même des résultats j'essaie
d'aller vite sur petite enfance oui le
SPPE le service public de la petite
enfance est une première brique elle
n'est pas la réponse à tous les sujets
mais il fallait encore qu'il y ait un
pilote nous ne laissons pas les
collectivités locales seules puisque
c'est bien la convention d'objectif et
de moyens que nous avons signé état etc
NAF qui va venir financer et accompagner
c'est un effort qui est quand même
majeur je sais que vous attendez des des
preuves d'amour et pas uniquement des
mots d'amour je l'ai bien retenu mais
entre 2023 et 2027 pour les structures
petite- enfance c'est 1,5 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires qui viennent
s'ajouter aux investissements déjà
réalisés notamment par par la CAF le
congé familial et je l'espère une autre
preuve d'amour donc j'entends ce que
vous avez dit sur le rapport moi j'ai
annoncé le fait qu'en 2025 il faut quand
même donner de la visibilité aux
familles ça pourra être le cas et je
crois que c'est important de dire
qu'encore une fois on redonne de la
liberté du choix des droits aux familles
pour garantir encore une fois monsieur
le rapporteur et bien qu'on puisse leur
assurer la possibilité de devenir des
parents dans des conditions sereines et
lutter contre toutes les causes qui font
qu'aujourd'hui on a un écart grandissant
entre le désir d'enfant et le nombre
d'enfants c'est la question en effet
d'une politique familiale universelle et
vous voyez bien que sur les nouveaux
droits que nous entendons créé que ce
soit la réforme du CMG ou le congé
familial il n'y a pas de différence et
bien l'ensemble des familles euh qui est
concerné on n'exclut pas des familles je
crois que c'est important je réponds
juste à une question qui a été posée
parce que je veux pas qu'il y a de mal
entendu j'ai entendu qu'il y aurait une
baisse des allocations dans ce budget
c'est l'inverse on va bien revaloriser
de 4,6 % l'ensemble des prestations
familiales en avril c'est 1 milliard
d'euros supplémentaire d'engagement de
l'État enfin rapidement handicap oui sur
les 50000 nouvelles solutions ma
priorité absolue c'est sur la question
madadame la
sénatriceavant tout des adultes en
situation de handicap on ne peut pas
avoir encore des adultes qui sont dans
des établissements qui sont dédiés à nos
enfants ça pose des questions évidentes
de dignité ça pose des questions
d'organisation c'est tout simplement une
question de justice de dignité de le
garantir c'est évidemment ce qu'on fera
là encore pour pas qu' d'ambiguïé sur la
question des fauteuils c'est bien à 100
% il y aura donc un reste à charge zéro
que le fauteuil coûte 3000 € ou qu'il en
coûte 30000 parce que parfois ça peut
aller jusqu'à ce prix-là c'est bien
l'état qui s'engage à prendre en charge
à 100 % les fauteuils je crois que
là-dessus c'est vra vraiment une petite
révolution pour les familles on va les
délester d'un poids financier mais aussi
d'un poids moral et je crois que c'éit
important de vous le préciser je vous
remercie merci madame la ministre pour
votre esprit de synthèse monsieur le
ministre
CASNAV monsieur le Président j'ai j'ai
une proposition à vous faire il y a de
très nombreuses questions qui relèvent
de de sujets financiers qui sont abordés
dans les dans les tous premiers articles
et je propose et je je prends
l'engagement de répondre aux questions
précises qui m'ont été posées par les
sénatrices et sénateurs à l'occasion de
l'examen des articles et et des
amendements si cela vous convient ce qui
vous permettrait monsieur le Président
de de tenir l'horaire de la
séance bravo je vous remercie je vous
remercie à la fois pour le travail de la
commission parce que la Commission doit
se réunir après et pour mes collègues
sénateur mes chers collègues je vais
suspendre la séance elle sera reprise à
21h35 pour l'examen des articles du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour